TWENTY SIX HEARING.
OF THE ASSEMBLY HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE OUR FIRST BILL HEARING
OF THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
TWENTY SESSION.
I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME OUR NEW
AND RETURNING MEMBERS TO THE
COMMITTEE AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
OUR WORK TOGETHER THIS YEAR.
TODAY ONCE WE'VE ESTABLISHED
QUORUM WHICH WE ALREADY HAVE WE
WILL BE VOTING TO ADOPT OUR
COMMITTEE RULES.
THEN WE WILL HAVE TO BILLS ON
THE AGENDA ONE OF WHICH IS ON
CONSENT.
PLEASE NOTE THAT WE LIMIT
TESTIMONY TO TO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND TWO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
EACH WITNESS HAS TWO MINUTES TO
TESTIFY.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES MAY ADD
ON BY STATING THEIR NAME AND
AFFILIATION.
IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING OUR BILL
HEARING WE WILL BE HOLDING AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING REGARDING
PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER.
AND THE PROVISION OF MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FOR FOSTER YOUTH.
DR A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR --
I'M SORRY.
THANK YOU SIR.
BUT THE STEPS QUORUM.
YES.
HERE MATHIS [inaudible]
ARAMBULA.
TôI HERE FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
MAIENSCHEIN.
STONE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible] ZERO IF
MOTION A SECOND TAKE REAL PLEASE.
ON THE COMMITTEE ROLLS REYES.
AYE REYES AYE MATHIS.
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE CHOI.
CHOI AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
STONE STONE I IT'S NOT.
ARAMBULA I CHOI.
CHOICE I FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN AYE
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
STONE STONE I THE CONSENT
CALENDAR HAS.
SIX THE CONSENT CALENDAR HAS SIX
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ITEM NUMBER.
ONE MISTER GIBSON WOULD LIKE TO
PRESENT YOUR BILL
.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE SEVENTY FIVE WHICH
SEEKS TO MODERNIZE.
THE FOSTER YOUTH BILL OF RIGHTS
BY ADDING THE RIGHTS THAT ARE
INCLUSIVE OF THE YOUTH
EXPERIENCE EASILY ACCESSIBLE TO
EMPOWERING THEIR DECISION MAKING.
FOSTER YOUTH HAVE TO OVERCOME.
MANY BARRIERS AND MANY BURDENS
AND HAVING HIGHER A HIGH RATE OF
UNEMPLOYMENT AND INCARCERATION --
THESE YOU HAVE FEW PEOPLE TO
TURN TO THAT CAN HELP THEM
UNDERSTAND THE RESOURCES AND THE
RIGHTS ENTITLED TO THEM UNDER
THE FOSTER.
CARE SYSTEM HERE IN THE STATE IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN I AUTHORED
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN SIXTY SEVEN
WHICH WAS SIGNED.
BY THE GOVERNOR AT THAT REQUIRES
TO CONVENE A WORK GROUP TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND UPDATE
PROVISIONS IN THE FOSTER YOUTH
BILL OF RIGHTS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL.
SERVICES DID NOT PROVIDE A
REPORT LAST YEAR AND HAVE
RECEIVED AN EXTENSION TO DO SO
HOWEVER WE ARE CONFIDENT THAT
THE CURRENT LANGUAGE REFLECTS --
THE NEED OF OUR FOSTER YOUTH IN
CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
SEVENTY FIVE WILL ADD RIGHTS
RELATED TO CULTURAL COMPETENT
CARE ACCESS TO COMPUTER
TECHNOLOGY.
PRIVACY AND RESPECT TOWARDS LGBT
STATUS AND GENDER IDENTITY.
WITH ME TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY ON ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
SEVENTY FIVE WE HAVE INDIVIDUALS
REPRESENTING WHO SELF INTRODUCED
HIMSELF THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
CONNECTION.
HI THERE MY NAME'S.
VANESSA HERNANDEZ I'M THE DOCTOR
POLICY FOR CALIFORNIA YOUTH
CONNECTION I'LL DEFER MY TIME TO
MY COLLEAGUE --
MY NAME'S JOHN.
SORRY MY NAME'S KIANA ARMED
BURKE I AM A MEMBER OF THE
CINEMA CHAPTER FOR CALIFORNIA
USE CONNECTION [inaudible]
ON ASSUME MOST OF YOU KNOW ABOUT
CALIFORNIANS CONNECTION BUT IN
CASE YOU DON'T.
IS A YOUTH LED ORGANIZATION OF
CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
WHO DEVELOP LEADERS WHO EMPOWER
EACH OTHER AND THE COMMUNITIES
TO TRANSFORM THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM THROUGH POLICY.
PRACTICE AND LEGISLATIVE CHANGE.
THE FOSTER YOUTH BILL OF RIGHTS
IS IMPORTANT FOR CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE.
BECAUSE WHEN WE HAVE RIGHTS AND
WE NEED OUR RIGHTS --
FOSTER PARENTS HAVE THEIR BILL
OF RIGHTS THESE ARE THE BILL OF
RIGHTS WAS ESTABLISHED IN TWO
THOUSAND ONE WHICH IS EIGHTEEN
YEARS AGO I'M TWENTY YEARS OLD.
AND TO ME --
I'VE BEEN THINKING THE CAR WAS
LIKE MAN I EIGHTEEN YEARS THAT
WAS.
AND SORRY.
IT IS JUST IS A LONG TIME
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
DEVELOPMENT WITHIN SOCIETY A LOT
OF TRANSITION AND OUR USE.
STILL NEED MORE.
SUPPORT AND NEED TO KNOW THEIR
RIGHTS -- IN
MY EXPERIENCE I HAVE FULLY I'VE
SEEN THE FOSTER CARE BILL OF
RIGHTS WITH MY SOCIAL WORKER
ONCE.
AND THEN I JUST LOOKED AT IT MY
FREE TIME.
ANOTHER TIME.
AND WHEN SHE SHOWED ME MY BILL
OF RIGHTS IT WAS JUST A SIMPLE
GLANCE THROUGH LOOK YOU HAVE
THESE BILL RIGHT SO IT'S LIKE
OKAY AND THEN WHEN I FINALLY SAT
DOWN BY MYSELF TO READ IT.
THEIR RIGHTS THE I DIDN'T EVEN
KNOW I HAD AND NOW THAT I'M NOT
IN THIS THE SYSTEM.
IT WAS KIND OF DISAPPOINTING FOR
EXAMPLE I DON'T KNOW THAT I HAD
THE RIGHT TO READ MY CASE FILE
AND TO BE INFORMED.
ABOUT MY SITUATION AND THE AGE
OF TWELVE THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOWN AND WOULD
LIKE TO BEEN INFORMED ON WHEN I
WASN'T CARE --
ALSO IT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE MY
BROTHER STILL CURRENTLY IN CARE
AND I DON'T BELIEVE HE'S EVEN
SEEN THE FOSTER CARE BILL OF
RIGHTS.
AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
MATTERS BECAUSE HOW ARE WE
SUPPOSED TO HOLD SOCIAL WORKERS
AND AGENCIES ACCOUNTABLE --
IF THE YOUTH THEMSELVES DON'T
EVEN KNOW THAT THESE RIGHTS
EXIST.
ON THEN UPDATING MATERIAL IS
REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT WILL
INCLUDE YOUTH LIKE THE LGBTQ AND
IT WILL IT EMPHASIZE THE ON GAPS
THAT ARE MISSING CURRENTLY WITH
THE OUT DATED INFORMATION IN THE
FOSTER.
CARE BILL OF RIGHTS.
ARM. FOR THESE REASONS I ASK FOR
YOUR EIGHT OF THREE I VOTE SORRY.
ON AB ONE SEVEN FIVE BY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON.
YOUR NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
HI I'M HERE AND JUST WOULD LIKE
TO ASK A LOT OF WHAT KIANA SAID
I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS.
IF NEEDED.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
.
BACK A KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF
OF THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MERRY THERE WITH
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
CALIPARI ALSO IN HUMBLE COUNTY
TRANSITION YOU CHOOSE
COLLABORATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
.
THANK YOU A CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS GREG BIRCH AND I WORK
FOR THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY THE
BILL GIVES FOSTER CHILDREN THE
RIGHT TO DEMAND THAT THEIR
FOSTER FAMILIES VIOLATES.
THEIR SINCERELY HELD RELIGIOUS
BELIEFS ABOUT GENDER.
AS I'M SURE YOU KNOW CHRISTIANS
BELIEVE THAT GENDER OR SEX IS
ENTIRELY BASED ON BIOLOGY.
ESTABLISHED AT THE MOMENT OF
CONCEPTION.
THIS IS SOMETHING SPECIAL GIVEN
TO US BY OUR CREATOR.
FORCING FOSTER PARENTS TO REFER
TO THEIR FOSTER CHILDREN AS THE
WRONG GENDER IS FORCING THEM TO
AFFIRM WHAT THEY BELIEVE IS A
LIE.
AND NOT ONLY A LIE BUT HARMFUL
TO CHILDREN.
AND THE MEDICAL SCIENCE BACKS IT
UP.
LOOK AT THE TESTIMONY I GAVE YOU
FROM DOCTOR ANDRIY VON BOWL A
REPRESENTED OF THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF PEDIATRICIANS ANY
NINE TIME FOSTER PARENT HIMSELF.
HE COULDN'T BE HERE TODAY SO HE
ASKED ME TO GIVE YOU HIS
TESTIMONY.
LOOK AT THE FIRST POINT.
TRANS AGENDA VACATION OR GENDER
DYSPHORIA AS HAS AN OVERWHELMING
PROBABILITY OF RESOLVING ITSELF
ON ITS OWN IF YOU DON'T
ENCOURAGE KIDS TO EMBRACE THEIR
GENDER CONFUSION AS THEIR NEW
IDENTITY.
LOOK APPOINT.
TO UNDERLYING PSYCHOLOGICAL IN
NEUROLOGICAL ISSUES NEED A
DRESSING FIRST.
AND THERE ARE MANY IN FOSTER
CHILDREN ARE MORE LIKELY TO HAVE
THEM.
AND THEY LOOK AT POINT SEVEN ON
THE SECOND DURING HAVE
DEVELOPING BRAINS IN OFTEN
CHANGE THEIR MINDS.
DON'T.
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND THE LONG
TERM CONSEQUENCES OF TAKING
PUBERTY BLOCKING DRUGS AND TOP
SURGERY.
THIS IS NOT SETTLED SCIENCE AS
THE AUTHOR OF THIS BILL WOULD
LIKE YOU TO BELIEVE.
I WAITED JUST GOOGLE FOR WORDS
SOCIAL CONTAGION GENDER GENDER
DYSPHORIA.
CHILDREN ARE FALSELY ASSUMING
THEY ARE TRANSGENDER BECAUSE OF
PEER INFLUENCE AND THERE'S
PLENTY OF BOTH ARTICLES BOTH
CONSERVATIVE AND LIBERAL SAYING
THE SAME THING.
MANY FOSTER PARENTS OR PARENT
ARE PEOPLE OF FAITH.
THEY SEEK TO OBEY GOD AND TO
FOLLOW GOD BY LOVING AND SERVING
OTHERS PARENTS OUR HEROES THESE
PARENTS ARE HEROES THAT YOU
SHOULD BE RESPECTING AND NOT
DRIVING AWAY.
THIS LAW PUSHES THEM INTO A
SITUATION WHERE THEY ARE GOING
TO HAVE TO MAKE A DECISION THEY
DON'T WANT TO MAKE.
OBEY THE STATE OR OBEY GOD.
THIS IS THE CHRISTIAN TEACHING
IS VERY CLEAR ON THIS POINT.
IF THEY HAVE --
THEY HAVE TO OBEY GOD IF THEY'RE
FORCED TO DECIDE.
PLEASE PLEASE SLOW DOWN.
READ TALK TO CHRISTIAN FOSTER
PARENTS THINK OF ALL THE GREAT
SELF WITH FILL PHYLLIS THEROUX
ICQ FOSTER PARENTS YOU'RE GONNA
LOSE IF YOU APPROVE THIS BILL.
DO YOU REALLY WANT TO CHASE THEM
AWAY BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT THIS
BILL IS GOING TO DO PLEASE VOTE
NO ON AB ONE SEVEN FIVE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS KEVIN SNYDER --
I'M AN ATTORNEY WITH THE PACIFIC
JUSTICE INSTITUTE CENTER. FOR
PUBLIC POLICY WHERE I SERVICE
CHIEF COUNSEL --
UP THE PROPOSED BILL ADDS AN ALL
TO AN ALREADY LONG LIST OF
MANDATED RIGHTS FOR USE YOUTH IN
FOSTER CARE.
AMONG THOSE HOUSE PRIVILEGES THE
BILL ALLOWS TEENS THE UNFETTERED
DISCRETION TO ATTEND RELIGIOUS
AND CULTURAL SERVICES IN
ACTIVITIES OF THEIR CHOICE.
SO IF A YOUNG PERSON EXERCISE
PRIVILEGE UNDER THE BILL TO USE
THE INTERNET BECOMES RADICALIZED
BY WHITE SUPREMACISTS AND FOSTER
PARENT I'M NOT GOING TO THE
CHURCH YOUTH GROUP ANYMORE I'M
NOW IN ODINIST SO DROP ME OFF AT
THE NORDIC.
TEMPLE SO I CAN BE WITH PEOPLE
OF LIKE FAITH IN LIKE RACE.
UNDER THIS BILL THE BILL
REQUIRES THE FOSTER PARENT TO
LISTEN AND OBEY THEIR TEENAGER.
THE BILL THEN TAKES ANOTHER
DANGEROUS TURN BY WEAPONIZE IN
AN ADOLESCENT WITH THE FORCE OF
LAW. TO COMPEL UNWILLING THIRD
PARTY ADULTS TOOK TO REFER TO
THE TEENAGER BY WHATEVER NAME
AND PRONOUN [inaudible]
THE TEENAGER.
DESIRES FOR EXAMPLE A TEENAGE
BOY COULD DIRECT A FOSTER PARENT
TO USE THE PRONOUN THEY INSTEAD
OF HE THIS IS A CONTENT BASED
RESTRICTION ON SPEECH.
IT IS IT IS ALSO COMPELLED
SPEECH JUST THIS LAST YEAR THE
US SUPREME COURT MADE IT CLEAR
THAT THE GOVERNMENT CANNOT
QUOTES COMPEL INDIVIDUALS. TO
MOUNT SUPPORT FOR VIEWS THEY
FIND OBJECTIONABLE THAT WAS THE
JANICE DECISION.
AND THEN REFERRING TO SACRAMENTO
LOFT MAKERS JUSTICE KENNEDY IN
THE LAST OPINION THAT HE WROTE.
SAID QUOTE GOVERNMENTS MUST NOT
BE ALLOWED TO FORCE PERSONS TO
EXPRESS A MESSAGE CONTRARY TO
THEIR DEEPEST CONVICTIONS.
IF YOU'RE RELIGIOUS CONVICTIONS
SCIENCE OR THE LOGIC OF GRAMMAR
LEAD YOU TO BELIEVE THAT A MALE
IS THE HEAT.
AND ONE PERSON IS NOT A DAY.
THEN THE GOVERNMENT CANNOT FORCE
AN INDIVIDUAL TO SAY SOMETHING
KNOWN TO BE DEMONSTRABLY FALSE.
IT IS S. ORWELLIAN IS FORCING
SOMEONE TO SAY TWO PLUS TWO
EQUALS.
FIVE YOUNG PEOPLE DO NOT NEED A
BIG BROTHER TO WRITE A LONG LIST
OF HOUSE PRIVILEGES THEY NEED
PARENTS.
WHO COULDN'T PARENT THEM THROUGH
THE TURBULENCE OF BEING A
TEENAGER?
MADAM CHAIRMAN WOMAN I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR IN FOR YOUR SERVICE TO
THE COMMUNITY AND I VOTE THE
COMMITTEE TO VOTE NAY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE IT WHAT
OTHER WITNESSES THAT IN IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
MEMBERS HAPPY CENTER LIKE WITH
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ALONE ARE.
WE'RE NOT IN OPPOSITION.
SORRY FOR THE WRONG GROUP TO GET
UP WITH A CAT IS AN EARLY
MADONNA WITH THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION I MISSED
MY WINDOW WITH THIS OTHER
SUPPORTERS I WANTED TO COME UP
AND LET YOU KNOW WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE LEGISLATION THANK
YOU.
MARIA JOSE FERNANDEZ FLORES WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE AND WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB.
ONE SEVENTY FIVE ARE THERE ARE
THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MARK CHILSON AMERICAN FAMILY
RIGHTS ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
I TO APOLOGIZE I'M COMING AT THE
WRONG TIME JOIN A KARMIC
CHILDREN'S LAWCENTER CALIFORNIA
CLEARLY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION BUT WE DON'T
HAVE A SECOND [inaudible]
QUESTION.
CAN WE GET A SECOND FIRST THANK
YOU.
YES.
MISS FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU TIME THANK YOU SOME
NUMBER GIPSON.
RAN THIS BILL FORD I DO HAVE A
QUESTION --
I THINK THERE WAS.
MAYBE ONE VALID ARGUMENT THAT
RACE BY OR AT LEAST QUESTION
RAISED BY THE OPPONENTS --
IF IT CHILD IN THIS BILL --
UNDER THIS BILL --
DID WANT TO JOIN A HATE GROUP --
OR COULD BE A DANGER TO THEM OR
OTHER PEOPLE WITH THIS BILL
PROHIBIT PARENTS FROM --
ALLOWING THEM TO DO THAT OR
FACILITATING THAT.
I DON'T BELIEVE SO.
SO IN OTHER WORDS IF THEY WANTED
TO JOIN A HATE GROUP.
THEY WOULDN'T HAVE TO UNDER THE
LAW THEY THEY WOULDN'T AND YOUR
BILL DOES NOT REQUIRE THE
PARENTS TO FACILITATE THAT THAT
IS CORRECT.
OKAY WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO
CLARIFY THAT PERHAPS AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD ABSOLUTELY OKAY
AND THEN ON THE OTHER QUESTION I
HAVE IS ABOUT THE INTERNET
ACCESS WHICH OF COURSE IS
SOMETHING IN TODAY'S WORLD THAT.
YOU COULD ARGUE IS VERY
IMPORTANT --
BUT THERE ARE TIMES WHEN
RESTRICTING OR EVEN STOPPING
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET --
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS COULD
BE APPROPRIATE A CHILD WHO IS.
USING THE INTERNET TOO MUCH NOT
CONCENTRATING ON THEIR STAY
VIEWING INAPPROPRIATE MATERIAL --
WITH THIS PROHIBIT PARENTS FROM
RESTRICTING THAT ACCESS BASED ON
ANY OF THOSE --
REASONS IT'S A REASONABLE --
IS REASONABLE ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET RIGHT NOW IS IS THERE
IS THERE GOING TO BE TO FIND
SOMEWHERE IN THE BILL OR WHO
WOULD MAKE THAT DECISION.
WHAT THE PARENTS?
THE PARENT MAKE ABSOLUTELY AND
ALSO THERE'S MECHANISMS TO
CERTAINLY MAKE SURE THAT A CHILD
IT ARE IN BACK NOT NAVIGATING TO
SITES THEY SHOULD NOT BE --
VIEWING AND PARTICIPATING IN SO
JUST SO I UNDERSTAND THERE'S A
LOT OF MEDALS IN THERE IF --
IF A FOSTER YOU THOUGHT THAT
THERE ACCESS WAS BEING
RESTRICTED UNREASONABLY.
WHO WOULD THEY BRING THAT TO
THAN TO THEIR CASE WORKER TO
MAKE THE TERM FINAL
DETERMINATION OF WHAT'S UP
THERE'S ODDS THERE'S THE ODDS
BUT CEMENT OKAY THAT?
THEY CAN MAKE THEIR CONCERNS
MADE KNOWN UNTO THOSE INTO TO
THAT INDIVIDUAL DEPARTMENT AND
THEN THEY WILL ACT AS A CONDUIT
TO WANT TO THE INVESTIGATION
ALSO TRIED TO RE WRITE
RESOLUTION PERFECT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU'RE WELCOME
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION.
THANK YOU AND AND I THINK WE
HAVE TO BE CAREFUL ABOUT.
MAKING POLICY BASED ON TESTIMONY
THAT'S FEAR MONGERING THAT'S
INACCURATE AND THAT IS IS REALLY
MEANT TO DRIVE AN EMOTIONAL
RESPONSE.
THE LOT OF THE LOGIC JUST.
SEEMS TO TO FAIL SO I I THINK.
MR GIPSON YOUR YOUR POLICIES IS
ABSOLUTE IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
WE HAVE TO BE VERY CAREFUL TO
MAKE SURE.
THAT FOSTER KIDS BE RESPECTED
WITH WHAT THEY'RE GOING THROUGH
AND AND NOT FALL INTO THE TRAP
OF THE IGNORANCE OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCE THAT A LOT OF TRANS
GENDER ANOTHER YOUTH ARE.
THE DIFFICULTIES THAT THERE
GOING THROUGH.
THIS NOTION THAT THERE WAS ****
NILLY THING AND CAN BE TALKED
OUT OF SOMETHING.
IS JUST THERE'S NO SCIENTIFIC
BASIS FOR IT AND HAS CAUSED A
GREAT DEAL OF OF STRIFE AND AND
PROBLEMS HISTORICALLY NOT JUST
AND FOSTER YOUTH BUT IN
TRANSGENDER YOUTH.
THIS IS HAPPENED IN.
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND AND
OTHER SO I I THINK YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY ON THE RIGHT TRACK
WITH THIS BILL AND I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
FROM.
I MEAN I I DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
I THINK --
THE POINTS THAT I FOR CALLING
MISS FRIEDMAN BROUGHT UP AS FAR
IS --
DEFINING SOME OF THESE POINTS ON
GOING FORWARD WOULD DEFINITELY
BE BENEFICIAL. FOR WERE MAY BE
PLAN OFF SOME POSSIBLE
OBJECTIONS FROM SOME OF THE
LANGUAGE IN THE FUTURE --
YOU KNOW I I DO HAVE A CONCERN
AND I SEE BOTH SIDES OF THIS.
AND I YOU KNOW I I THINK THE
BIGGEST PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE IN
MY AREA AND ESPECIALLY MY
DISTRICT IS THE LACK OF ACCESS
TO FOSTER PARENTS.
AND THE LACK OF HOMES LACK OF
HOMES ESPECIALLY --
FOR FOR SPECIAL NEEDS THAT NEED
TO GET INTO THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM BECAUSE OF BAD SITUATIONS.
AND I WOULD HATE TO SEE.
ANYTHING THAT WOULD PROHIBIT --
YOU NO MORE PARENTS BEING ABLE
TO GET IN --
A I DO WANNA MAKE SURE THERE IS
SOME KIND OF A MECHANISM WHERE
IF THERE IS A CHILD IN A FOSTER --
SITUATION AND AND THEY DO YOU --
DECIDE THEIR IDENTITIES
DIFFERENT OR THERE IS A
SITUATION WHERE THE FOSTER
PARENT NO LONGER FEELS
COMFORTABLE THERE IS AN OUT --
SO YOU DON'T HAVE SOMETHING IT'S
INTO SOMETHING BAD --
FOR EITHER THE PARENT OR THE
CHILD BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO
LOOSE --
GOOD FOSTER PARENTS --
REGARDLESS WHAT THEIR RELIGIOUS
VALUES ARE --
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE ON ENSURING THE CARE --
BECAUSE WE JUST DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH FOSTER'S THERE'S THERE'S
NOT ENOUGH --
ESPECIALLY --
FOR CHILDREN THE EYEPIECE AND
SPECIAL NEEDS.
SO I I JUST YOU KNOW MY QUESTION
FOR YOU --
MISTER GIBSON I KNOW YOU WORKED
VERY DILIGENTLY TO ENSURE THAT
DEFINITIONS GET DON AND POLICIES
OR SET STRAIGHT --
YOU KNOW IN YOUR OPINION DOES
THIS BILL HELP GET MORE FOSTER
PARENTS YESTER NOW.
I THINK THIS BILL HAS A GREAT
POTENTIAL OF ONE INCREASING --
OF PARENTS TO TAKING IN FOSTER
CHILDREN.
ALSO UNDERSTANDING.
OF THE COMPLEXITIES AND THE
TRAUMA THAT THESE FALSE SO
YOU'VE GO THROUGH THIS BEING A
FOSTER CHILD PERIOD --
PLEASE UNDERSTAND THIS BILL HAS
BEEN A COMMITTEE HAS BEEN PUT
TOGETHER --
LET.
WITH ADULTS AND BEING AT THE
TABLE TO HAVE A DISCUSSION.
FOSTER YOUTH BILL OF RIGHTS
HAVEN'T BEEN UPDATED SINCE ITS
FIRST CONCEPTION SO THIS IS
ALMOST TWENTY OF THIRTY YEARS
AGO I WOULD THINK SENATOR LIEU
FOUR ONE HER TENACIOUS NOUS
BRINGING US BEFORE US THAT WE
HAVE A FALSE THE BILL OF RIGHTS.
WE IN ADDITION TO THAT --
THIS BILL GOES A LOT FURTHER AND
I JUST WANT TO INVITE THE
COMMITTED TO LISTEN TO SOME OF
THE THINGS.
INCLUDES THE RIGHTS TO RECEIVING --
GROOMING AND HYGIENE PRODUCTS
REGARDLESS OF GENDER IT ALSO
TALKS ABOUT ALLOWING --
SPECIFIC HEALTHCARE --
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DID ORDER --
INFORMATION AND ALSO HEALTHCARE --
CALCINED BEING PROVIDED IT ALSO
DEALS WITH --
THE RIGHTS TO VISIT AND CONTEXT
SIBLINGS WE HAVE A NUMBER I JUST
SPOKE TO A YOUNG MAN JUST --
LAST WEEK WHO HAS NINE BROTHERS
AND SISTERS ALL IN THE FOSTER
SYSTEM BECAUSE MOTHER AND MOM
AND DAD IS IN THE PENAL SYSTEM --
RECONNECTED FOR THE VERY FIRST
TIME WAS BLOCKS AWAY FROM HIS
BIOLOGIAL --
BROTHER WHO WAS A TWIN AND SET
UP A DATE TO MEET THEM --
AND WAS KILLED NINE DAYS BEFORE
THAT MEETING TOOK PLACE.
SO HE LEFT WITH NOT EVEN HAVING
OPPORTUNITY STEVEN KNOLL.
LIKES AND DISLIKES OF HIS
BROTHER TO SEE IF WE EVEN HAVE
THE SAME KIND OF WALK OR OR
SPEECH JUST LIKE THEM ITS
SIMILARITIES AND SO THIS BILL
PROVIDE THAT OPPORTUNITY.
BUT THOUGHT INVITE THE COMMITTEE --
TO LOOK THINGS IN IT AS WELL AS
YOU KNOW YOU WERE OF FOCUS WHO
HAD INPUT ON THESE A FOSTER USE
THAT INPUT IN IN TERMS OF
CREATING THIS FALSE YOUTH BILL
OF RIGHTS.
AND CERTAINLY WE WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THIS BILL
MOVE FORWARD --
AND TAKE SUGGESTIONS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS MOVING FORWARD.
YEAH MYSTERIES THAT IT'S I I
KNOW A LOT OF THE MEASURES
WEIGHT WITHIN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM ARE THERE TO PROTECT --
OUR USE THAT ARE IN THE SYSTEM.
BECAUSE THEY MIGHT HAVE A
BROTHER SISTER WHO'S BEEN GIVEN
A HOLLER MY HAVE A RECORD OR
SOMETHING ALONG THOSE LINES IN.
A JUST WANNA ENSURE THAT AS YOUR
BILL MOVE FORWARD --
WE'RE INSURING THAT PROTECTIONS
ARE STILL THERE FOR THEM AND
THAT WERE STILL MAKING SURE THAT
THE FOSTER PARENTS AND THAT THE
SYSTEM CAN ENSURE THAT.
YOU KNOW JUST BECAUSE THEY HAVE
A BROTHER SISTER OR A FAMILY
MEMBER.
THAT YOU KNOW WE ARE LOOKING AT
OKAY WHAT IS THAT RELATIONSHIP
ARE WE GETTING THEM.
INTO POSSIBLE MORE TROUBLE BY
THE CONTACT OR IS IT GONNA BE
SAFE IN A SAFE ENVIRONMENT FOR
THEM YOU KNOW BECAUSE ULTIMATELY
THAT THE JOB HERE IS NOT TO DO
MORE HARM.
ON IN TO BE ABLE TO SHOW THAT
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT FOR THE
MILITANT OTHER SOMEBODY OUT
THERE THAT ACTUALLY LOVES THEM.
AND WILL TAKE CARE OF THEM ON IT
MOVING FORWARD I WILL SUPPORT
YOUR BILL TODAY --
BUT I DO ENCOURAGE YOU TO
TIGHTEN UP THE LOOSE ENDS ON IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AMONG --
GOOD AND BAD.
ASPECTS --
BY.
ADDING EDITION ORDER Là.
RIGHTS -- TO
THE FOSTER.
FOSTER CHILDREN --
THIS SOME MORE --
RESTRICTIONS SO.
OF TO ME --
FOR THE FOSTER PARENTS TO FOLLOW.
SO AS YOU HEARD THE I AM
CONCERNED --
WHAT THE POTENTIAL FUTURE FOSTER
PARENTS SO?
WOULD BE AFRAID TO TO
ACCOMMODATE THE OLDEST A NEW.
ONE RIGHTS.
AND THE MY OFFICE RECEIVED --
A SEVERAL PHONE CALLS TO FOR MY
DISTRICT AND DOES NOT --
FROM -- WAR
IN SUPPORT OF THAT THE AND I AM
CONCERNED. FOR EXAMPLE --
ON ON OCT WITH THREE INDIVIDUAL --
ALL OF THE ITEMS SO FOR EXAMPLE --
ONE OF THEM.
IS SOME MENTIONING OF AGE
APPROPRIATE THE ALLOWANCES.
IS THAT THE DANO DETERMINED WAS
SO AGE APPROPRIATE THE ALLOWANCE
OF IS SECONDLY IS THAT THE ARE.
IF A DOLLAR TERMS WOULD BE
DEFINED A IS THE GOVERNMENT PAID
THE OR TO FOSTER.
PARENT WOULD FORCED TO OUR OF
LAW GIVEN BUDGET THE OROVILLE
ONE POCKET THE SO THAT'S ALREADY.
CODIFIED ALREADY IN TERMS OF
WHAT STILL ALLOW ALLOW FOR IN
TERMS OF ALLOWING THINGS WORKED
OUT WITH THE FOSTER PARENT
ITSELF.
BUT ALSO YOU MADE MENTION IN
TERMS OF THE FOSTER PARENTS.
WERE LOOKING FOR LOVING HOMES
INDIVIDUALS WHO LOVE THESE KIDS
THESE CHILDREN --
FOR THEM OF LOVE FILLED WITH --
INVOLVEMENT IN INTO THEIR LIVES --
THIS BILL ONCE AGAIN --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS YOUTH FOCUS
YOUTH AND ADULTS TOGETHER
COLLABORATED TO PUT THESE AN
UPDATE THE THE BOSS OF YOU THE
BILL OF RIGHTS.
THESE ARE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO HAVE
FACED --
TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCES THEY WANT
THE SAME THING LET ME SAY THAT
THEY WANT THE SAME THING.
YOU HAVE CHILDREN THAT YOU'VE
GIVEN YOUR CHILDREN THEY WANT.
A WARM BED TO SLATE TO START TO
SLEEP IN INSTEAD OF YOU KNOW --
HAVING THERE'S ENTIRE LIFE
DISRUPTED BY BEING MOVED FROM
ONE PLACE TO THE NEXT.
THEY WANT STABILITY --
AND THIS BILL PROVIDES ONLY
STABILITY BUT IT INVITES PEOPLE
WHO WILL HAVE ACCESS --
WITH THE FOSTER YOU A TO
COLLABORATE THAT'S THE FOSTER
PARENTS AS SOCIAL WORKERS ABOUT
THE CHILD ITSELF THAT'S THE
COMMUNITY THAT'S THE SCHOOL THIS
WILL PROVIDE ALL THOSE
MECHANISMS --
THAT'S IN THIS IN THE BOSTON WE
SEE THIS YOUTH KNOWING THEIR
RIGHTS AND THE FOSTER PARENTS
KNOW THEIR RIGHTS ALSO
RESPECTING THOSE RIGHTS AS WELL.
BECAUSE WE'RE STILL TALKING
ABOUT -- ONE
OF THIS IS YOU KNOW AS OF
AMERICA AND THIS IS A STILL A
PLACE WHERE EVEN AS A CHILD HAVE
RIGHTS AS WELL.
THIS IS SAW SO REALLY LOVELY.
AND THE FOR THE LOVING FAMILY.
AND THE DISORDER STRENGTH AND
THAT THE I I HOPE.
YOU'LL --
FOR WOULD BE ACHIEVED --
IF IT PASSES --
HOWEVER --
THE TO ME IS SO IF THIS ARE
LOVING FAMILY --
FAMILY SHOULD THE BE GIVEN MORE.
AUTHORITY HOW TO CRY.
THEIR CHILDREN IN THE RIGHT AWAY.
RATHER THAN --
FOR EXAMPLE.
THE LINE'S TO SOMEWHERE I
THOUGHT I READ YOU CAN EVEN
CHOOSE YOUR NAME LAST NAME OR
WHATEVER.
IT IS THAT THE IN MY FAMILY --
TO WHY ALLOW MY CHILD THAT HEY
YEAH.
IN ALL I WANNA BE IN ALL.
OUR OWN AGENDA MY LAST NAME IS
SOMETHING ELSE SO WOULD I ALLOW
THAT.
NOT THE LOVING --
WHICHEVER NAME COMES WITH A
WOULD NOT CHANGE THE LAST NAMES --
TO SO I DON'T KNOW AS A PARENT --
UNSTABLE FOR A MOTION FOR LAWFUL
EMOTIONAL TRAUMA.
TYPICALLY THEY MAY BRING IN.
AND THE TEENAGE AREA AT THE ALL
THE GOOD CRITERIA. FOR THEM TO
BE GUIDED THE PROPERLY. FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE MUCH
EXPERIENCE.
SO HERE THIS SEEMS TO BE YA
EMPHASIZING.
INDIVIDUAL.
IN THE UNITED STATES INDIVIDUAL
WATER RIGHTS.
SO THAT TO ME IS A SEPARATING.
BUT THE PET FAMILY UNIT
[inaudible]
RATHER THAN.
ALLOWING HER EYES SO. TO DO
THEIR BEST.
TO ASSERT.
FAMILY.
HEY SINCE YOU ARE OUT FOSTER
CHILD WE HAVE DESCRIBED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE YOU CAN DO
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO DO.
DUST IMPRESSION I'M GETTING.
K. YOU WANT A RESPONSE TO THE NO
THAT WAS A STATEMENT OKAY
THICKNESS ANANUS WANTED TO
ADDRESS THE POINT YES THANK YOU
YOUR HONOR.
I CAN --
ADDRESS BOTH THE NAME --
TOPIC THAT YOU'RE REYES AND A
FEW OTHER ELEMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN ELEVATED HERE --
I GREW UP IN FOSTER CARE MYSELF
WHERE I EMANCIPATED --
I WAS ABLE TO BE IN THE SAME
FOSTER HOME BETWEEN THAT TIME
FRAME BETWEEN SEVEN EIGHTEEN
SORRY.
ARE THEY THE NAME CONVERSATION
DID COME UP THEY WANTED ME TO
ALSO TAKE THEIR LAST NAME BUT
FOR ME PERSONALLY IT FELT LIKE I
WAS LOSING A PIECE OF MY
IDENTITY.
THAT I DIDN'T FEEL COMFORTABLE
WITH LEADER GOT IT TATTOOED
BECAUSE THAT'S ALSO PERMANENT
AND IT WAS IMPORTANT THAT I
WANTED TO BE PART OF THIS UNIT.
BUT THAT'S MY DECISION AND
THAT'S WHAT I HAVE AS A PERSON
AND THAT FOR PEOPLE WHO GROW UP
IN OUR TAKEN FROM THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND THEIR FAMILY IN
PEOPLE THAT THEY KNOW.
SCRAPS OF IDENTITY OR SOMETIMES
THE ONLY THING WE HAVE SO FOR
THAT EXAMPLE SPECIFICALLY.
WITH THAT BEING SAID THAT DID
NOT WATER DOWN MY FAMILY BONDS
WHEN I SPEAK OF MY MOM AND MY
SISTERS.
THEY ARE MY MOM AND MY SISTERS
RATE -- SO
THERE'S THAT ELEMENT OF THAT AND
IT YOU KNOW I THINK THE FIRST
YOUTH BILL OF RIGHTS IS
BEAUTIFUL AND IMPACTFUL FOR LOTS
OF REASONS.
IT DOESN'T POWER THE YOUNG
PERSON A DOES HE QUIPPED
CHILDREN AND YOUTH TO KNOW WHAT
THEIR RIGHTS ARE BECAUSE A LOT
OF TIMES THEY'RE IN SURVIVAL
MODE.
AND A LOT OF TIMES THE SYSTEM
AND SOCIETY HAS GIVEN UP ON THEM
TIME AND TIME AND TIME AGAIN SO
IF WE CAN EQUIP THEM WITH ONE
POLICIES BILL OF RIGHTS ON HOW
TO NAVIGATE.
THE SYSTEM THAT'S THE LEAST THAT
WE CAN DO WHEN CHILDREN AND
YOUNG PEOPLE ENTERED THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ST WE CAN PARENT
BETTER THAN YOUR CURRENT
CIRCUMSTANCE.
AND SO BY A IN GIVING THEM
CERTAIN ENTITLEMENTS AND RIGHT
IT'S IT'S VERY MINIMAL MINIMAL.
THAT MEANS THAT NOT EVERYONE
FINDS PERMANENCY IN THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM A LOT OF FOLKS
EMANCIPATE WHEN THEY ARE
EIGHTEEN OR TWENTY ONE AND STILL
DON'T HAVE A FAMILY TO CALL
THEIR OWN.
GIVING THEM THE TOOLS THEY NEED
TO BE A SELF ADVOCATE TO
NAVIGATE COLLEGE IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
DOCUMENT THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS IT UPDATES IT FOR THE
YOUNG PEOPLE THAT.
DON'T FIND THE STABILITY WITHIN
THE TOLD IT'S IMPORTANT TO
SUPPORT THEM AND SO WITHOUT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
MR GIVES LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I
THINK THAT WE FOR REMEMBER THE
TITLE OF IT IT'S THE FOSTER
YOUTH.
BILL OF RIGHTS.
IT IS THEIR BILL OF RIGHTS IS
IT'S AN EXTENSION OF WHAT WAS
ALREADY PROVIDED TO THEM.
AND AS HAS BEEN NOTED BY OUR
COLLEAGUES.
IT'S ALREADY TRAUMATIC
EXPERIENCE GOING AND WE WANT TO
BE SURE THAT THEY KNOW THAT THEY
DO HAVE RIGHTS --
WE WE STILL HAVE AS WE KNOW THE
PRUDENT TO PARENT STANDARD.
SO THE PARENTS ARE STILL THE
PARENTS AND THEY'RE STILL GOING
TO WORK WITH THE CHILD THAT
THEIR LOVE THING.
AS THEIR FOSTER CHILD AS THEIR
CHILD I'M SO HAPPY THAT YOU HAD
TO ONE FOSTER FAMILY THROUGHOUT
YOUR TIME BUT WE KNOW THAT
THAT'S NOT.
THE WAY IT IS FOR MANY OF OUR
FOSTER YOUTH.
A SOME COMMENTS WERE MADE ABOUT
THE RIGHT TO RE ATTEND RELIGIOUS
SERVICES.
THAT ALREADY EXISTS THE ONLY
THING THAT WAS CHANGED AS I
UNDERSTAND TO MISTER GIBSON IS
TO BE ABLE TO ATTEND CULTURAL
SERVICES AS WELL.
SO THIS IS REALLY PART I DO
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM OUR
COLLEAGUES --
AND AND WOOD NAIL.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AS WELL AS ALL THE DIALOGUE THAT
HAS TRANSPIRED I CERTAINLY
REAPED BY APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION HAS TAKEN PLACE --
I JUST WANT --
TO JUST SAYING SIMPLY THAT THESE
CHILDREN ARE HUMAN.
THEY HAVE FEELINGS THESE ARE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEEN
TRAUMATIZED IN MANY MANY WAYS --
AND I AM A FIRM BELIEVER OF MARK
TWELVE AND THIRTY ONE LOVE THY
NEIGHBORS AS I SELF.
AND THAT'S WERE SAYING RIGHT NOW
THE CHILD THAT YOU SAY YOU WILL
BRING INTO YOUR HOME LOVE THEM
JUST LIKE THAT CHILD WAS YOUR
OWN BIOLOGICAL CHILD.
GIVE THEM THE SAME KIND OF LOVE
AND RESPECT THAT YOU WOULD GIVE
YOUR OWN BIOLOGICAL CHILD THAT'S
WHAT THEY WANT.
YES WILL PROVIDE THE GUIDANCE AS
PARENTS I'M TO THESE CHILDREN
WILL STILL DO THAT BUT ALSO
MAKING SURE THAT YOU LOVE THEM
REGARDLESS --
OF THE HICK UPS OR WHATEVER THE
THAT THEY GO THROUGH IN LIFE
UNDER YOUR CARE --
JUDGE MY CHART MY CHILDREN AS
MUCH AS I LOVE THEM THEY HAVE
FALLEN DOWN AND MADE MISTAKES
BUT GUESS WHAT.
I DISCIPLINE THEM I LOVE THEM MY
THE YOU KNOW THAT MY FATHER
LOVES ME UNCONDITIONALLY AS WELL
AND YOU CAN TAKE THAT.
BOTH WAYS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHAT I VOTE.
WE HAVE A MOTION FOR MISTER
DOCTOR RUMBULA SECOND DOCTOR
STONE.
TAKE PRO PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE RAY
S. ONLINE RAST AYE MATHIS AYE
MATHIS AYE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE CHOI.
CHOI A NO FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AYE GIPSON AYE GIPSON
R. MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I A STONE.
STONE I THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE VOTE IS.
SEVEN ONE THAT BILLS OUT.
WITH THE MEMBERS LIKE TO ADD ON
TO SEN.
CANCER.
SO.
IN ADOPTING THE COMMITTEES ROLES.
MATHIS BY MATHIS AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE FINAL VOTE EIGHT
TO ZERO ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
CURRENT VOTE SIX TO ZERO MATHIS.
MATHIS I AM MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE FINAL VOTE.
EIGHT TO ZERO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR ATTENDING OUR HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE.
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED.
I MAKE AN ANNOUNCEMENT THAT THE
INFORMATION
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT WILL NOW CONVENE AT
THE INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
I DO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
JOINING THE ASSEMBLY HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE TODAY FOR
THIS IMPORTANT INFORMATIONAL
HEARING. TO LEARN ABOUT HOW
PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER.
IMPACTS THE PROVISION OF MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FOR THE STATE'S
FOSTER YOUTH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEN COOLEY WILL
BE HERE SHORTLY HE STEPPED OUT.
AND WHEN HE RETURNS I WILL ASK
FOR HIS BRIEF COMMENTS AS CHAIR
OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
FOSTER CARE.
CHILDREN AND YOUTH.
WHO HAVE BEEN REMOVED FROM THEIR
HOMES AND ARE IN THE STATE'S
CARE?
AS A RESULT OF ABUSE AND NEGLECT
HAVE EXPERIENCED TRAUMA.
THAT CAN IMPACT THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH AND DEVELOPMENT NOT ONLY
IN THE IMMEDIATE IMMEDIATE TERM
BUT ALSO INTO ADULTHOOD.
WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
THESE CHILDREN AND YOUTH TO
ENSURE THAT THEY RECEIVE THE
SERVICES.
NECESSARY TO ADDRESS THE MENTAL
HEALTH.
IN OCTOBER OF LAST YEAR THIS
COMMITTEE ALONG WITH THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON FOSTER CARE
EXAMINED WHAT.
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ARE
AVAILABLE TO YOU AND THE STATE'S
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROVIDE THOSE
SERVICES.
THE PURPOSE OF TODAY'S HEARING
IS TO TAKE A CLOSER LOOK AT THE
IMPACT OF TRANSFERRING
RESPONSIBILITY FOR PROVIDING
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FROM A
FOSTER YOUTH ORIGINAL COUNTY. TO
THE YOUTH COUNTY OF RESIDENCE.
WE ARE INTERESTED IN LEARNING
ABOUT HOW THE SHIFTING OF
RESPONSIBILITY OR PRESUMPTIVE
TRANSFER IMPACTS THE PROVISION
OF MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES TO
FOSTER YOUTH WERE PLACED.
OUT OF THE COUNTY.
IN RECENT YEARS THE STATE HAS
UNDERTAKEN A SERIES OF EFFORTS
KNOWN AS KNOWN COLLECTIVELY.
AS CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM
WITHIN OUR CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM.
IN ORDER TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR
FOSTER YOUTH.
MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MARK STONE.
HAS OFFERED A NUMBER OF BILLS
THAT SERVE AS A FOUNDATION FOR
THESE REFORMS.
A KEY GOAL.
OF THE CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM
IS ENSURING THAT ALL FOSTER
YOUTH ARE PROPERLY ASSESSED
TRIDENTINE FARTHER MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS.
AND THEN PROVIDED WITH ADEQUATE
SERVICES TO ADDRESS THOSE NEEDS.
WE'RE ALL HERE TODAY BECAUSE WE
CARE ABOUT THE WELL BEING OF
YOUTH.
WHO ARE PLACED IN CALIFORNIA'S
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM?
IT IS IN THIS SPIRIT THAT I HOPE
WE ALL APPROACH TODAY'S HEARING.
I HOPE THAT WE CAN LEAVE AT THE
END OF THIS HEARING NOT ONLY
WITH A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER AS SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT HAVE ARISEN
IN ITS IMPLEMENTATION.
IT ALSO WITH THE SENSOR
PROMISING DIRECTIONS AND
SOLUTIONS.
I HOPE WE LEAVE TODAY.
READY TO TAKE THE NEXT STEPS TO
FULFILL THE PROMISE OF SERVING
ALL FOSTER YOUTH IN WAYS TO
PROVIDE THEM WITH STABLE LOVING
HOMES.
NECESSARY SERVICES AND BRIGHT
FUTURES.
I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
THE PANELISTS TODAY FOR TAKING
TIME TO SHARE YOUR EXPERIENCE
AND EXPERTISE WITH US.
IF ANY OF THE OTHER MEMBERS
WOULD LIKE TO GIVE SOME OPENING
REMARKS.
VERY GOOD AT THIS TIME I'D LIKE
TO INVITE THE FIRST PANEL. TO
JOIN US.
I'D LIKE TO ALSO NOTE THAT ERIKA
CRISTO FROM DH CS WILL BE
REPLACING DO YOU KNOW CAUCUS
GONZALEZ.
MISS CRISTO IS THE BRANCH CHIEF
FOR DH CS IS MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAM POLICY AND QUALITY
ASSURANCE BRANCH.
THE FIRST PANEL WE HAVE GREG
ROSE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
CHILDREN AND FAMILY SERVICES
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES.
VANESSA HERNANDEZ DIRECTOR
STATEWIDE POLICY AND CALLA.
HELD HERE.
OLSON YOUTH ORGANIZER SOCIAL
WORKER TO AT HUMBOLDT COUNTY
TRANSITION AGE USE COLLECTION
COLLABORATIVE COLLABORATION.
BURNED AGREE LISH ACTING DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER SERVICES.
AND AS MENTIONED EARLIER.
ERICA CRYSTAL.
OF FROM D. H. THE ELSE.
WHO IS REPLACING DINA
[inaudible]
COCOS GONZALEZ.
M. SUDIRMAN LCSW RETIRED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTOR AND
CONSULTANT TO THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION.
WHAT WE BEGAN WITH GREG ROSE?
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS GREG
ROSE FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES --
JUST WANTED TO FIRST --
MENTIONED THAT --
AS AS YOU MIGHT MENTION IN YOUR
OPENING YOU KNOW DEEPLY INVOLVED
COLLECTIVELY WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
DEPARTMENT SPECIFICALLY AND THE
NUMBER MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE CONTINUE OF
CARE REFORM AND HAPPY TO TALK
WITH YOU ALL ABOUT THE THOSE ON
ANOTHER DAY TODAY I'M HERE.
LARGELY TO TO PROVIDE A GENERAL
HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW OF THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM AND I THOUGHT IT
WOULD DO THAT LARGELY BY TRYING --
TO TRACK --
TAKE YOU THROUGH A SCENARIO --
OR A STEPS OF OF THROUGH THE
KIND OF THE LIFE OF THE CASE IF
YOU WILL --
AND THEN AND USING SOME NUMBERS
TO TRY TO FIND THE SIZE AND
SCOPE OF SOME OF THE OF THE
ACTIVITIES THAT --
AND NOT THAT OF THAT WE DO AND
THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN SERVED IN
DIFFERENT SITUATIONS.
SHOULD ALSO MENTION AT THE
OUTSET THAT CLEARLY --
AS A COUNTY ADMINISTERED STAY
THE DIE CHILDREN HAVE BEEN OFTEN
ARE PLACED OUTSIDE OF THEIR
COUNTY --
FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS AND OVER
THE YEARS THE LEGISLATURE
DIFFERENT ADMINISTRATIONS IN THE
DEPARTMENT HAVE TAKEN A LOOK AT
DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF IT TO TRY
TO SOLVE --
DIFFERENT ISSUES THAT HAVE
ARISEN OVER TIME --
AND SO PART OF WHAT I'LL
DESCRIBE TO YOU --
AT IN A FEW MINUTES IS IS WHAT
HOW WHAT'S AT HOW WHAT THOSE
NUMBERS LOOK LIKE AND AND WHY
THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE ARE --
OFF AND PLACED IT WHERE THEY ARE
PLACED WHITE WHERE THEY LIVE WHY
THEY LIVE WHERE THEY THEY THE
TWO LEFT.
BUT FIRST LET ME JUST START WITH
SAYING THAT THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT --
STARTS AT THE HOTLINE --
A HOTLINE CALL AND AT ANY GIVEN
TIME THERE'S AROUND --
AT ANY GIVEN YEAR THERE'S AROUND
FOR LAST YEAR THERE WAS NINE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED PLUS TO
THE HOT LINE OF THOSE.
A COUNTIES OFTEN HAVE HAVE TO
MAKE A DECISION ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT THE INFORMATION THEY HAVE IT --
A IS SUFFICIENT ENOUGH TO
WARRANT SOME KIND OF AN OF AN
INVESTIGATION WITH THE NEED TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THEY THEY LEAD
THEY THEY INVESTIGATE WITHIN.
TEN DAYS OR OTHER IT'S AN
IMMEDIATE INVESTIGATION WHEN
THEY DO INVESTIGATE --
THE THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
AROUND SEVENTY THOUSAND OF THOSE
YOUNG SEVENTY ONE THOUSAND OF
THE THOSE OF THOSE.
OF THOSE SITUATIONS RESULT IN A
SUBSTANTIATION OF ABUSE OR
NEGLECT.
SHOULD NOTE ALSO THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE YOUNG PEOPLE
THAT COME INTO OUR OUR CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM OR INTO FOSTER
CARE.
MORE SIR BY THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM ARE ARE COME IN AS A
RESULT OF OF NEGLECT OVER 70% TO
COME IN AND AS A RESULT OF OF OF
NEGLECT.
OF THE SEVENTY ONE THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED AND TWELVE
SUBSTANTIATION LAST YEAR --
TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND ENDED UP
IN NEW ENTRIES INTO FOSTER CARE.
AND AT ANY GIVEN TIME --
IN THE YEAR WE HAVE AROUND FIFTY
FIVE THOUSAND YOUNG PEOPLE IN
FOSTER CARE --
CASE MANAGE BOTH BY COUNTY HUMAN
SERVICES DEPARTMENTS AND SOME BY
THE PROBATION DEPARTMENT'S.
ON THAT'S DOWN FROM A HIGH OF
OVER A HUNDRED AND TWELVE
THOUSAND OVER A DECADE AGO.
SO WHEN CHILDREN ARE IN PLACE
MEANT WHEN THEY'RE BUT WHEN --
THEY LIVE IN DIFFERENT
CIRCUMSTANCES THE VAST MAJORITY
OF YOUNG PEOPLE LIVE IN FAMILIES --
34% OF THEM LIVE WITH RELATIVES
OR FOR OUR OR NON REAP WHAT WE
CALL NOT RELENT NOT RELATED
EXTENDED FAMILY MEMBERS THOSE
ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE.
UNKNOWN TO THE YOUNG PERSON WHO
THEY HAVE HAVE A CONNECTION WITH.
13% LIVE IN COUNTY APPROVED
HOMES 23% LIVE IN --
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES THAT ARE
A PRIVATE NONPROFIT PRIVATE --
YOU FOSTER FAMILY --
AND 7% LIVE IN CONGREGATE CARE --
AND WE'LL TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT THAT I THINK IT IS AS THE
DAY GOES ON SHOULD ALSO JUST
NOTE THAT THERE ARE NUMBER OF
OTHER PLACEMENT TYPES --
SO THOSE NUMBERS I GAVE YOU
DON'T ADD UP TO A HUNDRED THAT
OUR 2100% BUT A NUMBER OF THE UP
THERE ARE OTHERS OTHER PLACEMENT
TYPES WHERE YOUNG PEOPLE LIVE
COURT SPECIFIED HOMES PRE
ADOPTIVE HOMES.
TRIAL HOME VISITS A NUMBER OF A
NUMBER OF SITUATIONS --
AND AS WELL AS AS IT WAS
MENTIONED IN THE PREVIOUS
HEARING WE DO HAVE IN A NUMBER
OF YOUNG PEOPLE WHO --
ARE LIVING I'M IN IN
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PROGRAMS OR
IN ON THEIR OWN AS A RESULT OF
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE.
SO -- WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF THE MOST OF
THAT AND THAT THE MINOR
DEPENDENCE IN OUR SYSTEM LIVE IN
FAMILIES OF DIFFERENT --
IN A DIFFERENT --
TYPES.
SO THERE ARE THE THE QUESTION I
THINK THAT WE'RE HERE TO TALK
ABOUT --
ULTIMATELY IS SO WENT WHAT
HAPPENS WHITE WIRE YOUNG PEOPLE
PLACED.
IN SITUATIONS ARE IN IN HOMES
THAT AREN'T --
IN THE COUNTY IN WHICH THEY
THEIR FOR THEIR PARENTS HAVE
PRESIDED AND THERE'S A NUMBER OF
REASONS FOR THAT THE THE MOST
OFTEN IT'S BECAUSE THERE WITH
HER THERE WITH THE RELATIVE. TO
THAT THE RELATIVE OF MAY IN MAY
LIVE IN A DIFFERENT COUNTY BUT
IN ORDER TO PRESERVE THE THE
CONNECTIONS WITH THAT YOUNG
PERSON TO MINIMIZE THAT THE
EFFECTS OF TRAUMA --
A RELATIVE PLACEMENT IS OFTEN
SOUGHT AND SO THERE'S A GOOD --
I'LL GIVE YOU SPECIFIC NUMBERS
FOR THAT --
LATER --
ANOTHER REASON IS THAT SOMETIMES
YOUNG PEOPLE --
BECAUSE OUR IN ORDER TO PLACE
SIBLINGS TOGETHER TO KEEP KEEP
THAT LEVEL OF FAMILY CONNECTION
SOMETIMES THERE NEEDS TO BE A A
PLACEMENT ACROSS THE COUNTY LINE
EITHER.
AGAIN WITH A RELATIVE OR
SOMETIMES WITH A PRIVATE FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCY THAT'S ABLE TO
SUPPORT A LARGER GROUP OF OF
YOUNG PEOPLE TO STAY TOGETHER --
IN CERTAIN SOME SITUATIONS
DEPENDING ON THE THE NATURE OF
THE OF THE COUNTY --
AND THERE MAY NOT BE AS AT THAT
TIME AND SO IN ORDER --
TO HAVE AN EXPEDITIOUS --
PLACEMENT IN A FAMILY --
IT REQUIRES THAT A FAMILY --
BE -- ACROSS
THERE ANOTHER JURISDICTION BE
IDENTIFIED AND AND THE YOUNG
PERSON'S PLACE THERE.
AND THEN ALSO AS A PART IT
SOMETIMES AS A PART OF THE YOUNG
PERSON'S HEALING FROM THE
COMPLEX TRAUMA THAT THEY'VE
EXPERIENCED.
THERE --
THEY NEED A STRUCTURED
RESIDENTIAL PROGRAM AT LEAST FOR
IN A SHORT IT FOR A SHORT TIME.
AND THOSE OFTEN READ REQUIRE --
OUT OF COUNTY PLACEMENTS THOSE
RESOURCES MARKET EVERY
JURISDICTIONS --
THE PROGRAMS ARE SOMEWHAT
SPECIFIC SPECIFIC NEEDS PERCENT --
THEY THEY ARE --
PLACED OUT OF COUNTY.
SO I THOUGHT IT WOULD JUST GIVE
YOU A WAY --
TO A POTENTIAL WAY TO THINK
ABOUT THE NUMBERS AND HOW HOW
MANY YOUNG PEOPLE WERE TALKING
ABOUT IT.
OUT BY CATEGORY AND AND KIND OF
THE RATIO --
BY CATEGORY.
ITHINK THE THE BACKGROUND --
KIND OF OUTLINED --
PARTLY WHAT I DESCRIBED EARLIER
WHAT ARE THE MOST COMMON AND
PLACEMENT TYPES HER OUT OF
COUNTY --
PLACEMENTS I THINK OF ONE WAY
THAT I OFTEN LOOK AT IT IS HOW
MANY WITHIN THOSE CATEGORIES
WHAT'S THE PERCENTAGE OF THOSE
YOUNG PEOPLE THAT ARE IN COUNTY
VERSUS OUT OF COUNTY.
AND WHAT WHAT'S THE OVERALL
NUMBER AND SO IF YOU --
BEAR WITH ME I'LL JUST GIVE YOU
THOSE THAT SO WHEN YOU THINK OF
OF PLACEMENTS --
ABOUT PERCENT OF OF KIDS IN
RELATIVE PLACEMENTS ARE IN THE
COUNTY OF ORIGIN.
AND 20% OR IN A PLACE ACROSS
COUNTY LINES.
THAT RESULTS IN JUST UNDER FOUR
THOUSAND YOUNG PEOPLE --
PLACED OUT OF COUNTY BUT WHO ARE
LIT WHO ARE LIVING WITH
RELATIVES WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
THAT THE THE COUNTY APPROVED
HOMES OFTEN CALLED --
COUNTY FOSTER HOMES. 91% OF
THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE ARE PLACED
WITHIN THE COUNTY AND 9% OUTSIDE
OF THE COUNTY.
AND THAT'S AT THE END THAT
RESULTS IN ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED
JUST UNDER SEVEN HUNDRED YOUNG
PEOPLE IN COUNTY APPROVED HOMES
BEING PLACED OUT OF COUNTY.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT --
THE OF THE FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCIES OF PLACEMENTS. 70% OF
THOSE ARE IN COUNTY AND 30% OUT
OF COUNTY AND THERE IS THAT
THERE IS --
AROUND --
THIRTY EIGHT HUNDRED WHEN YOU --
OF YOUNG PEOPLE THAT ARE SERVED
IN AND FOSTER FAMILY.
HOMES AT THAT ARE OUT OF COUNTY.
AND THEN WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE R.
CONGREGATE CARE BOTH OUR SHORT
TERM RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC
PROGRAMS AND OUR GROUP HOMES --
THERE A 51% MAIN IN THEIR COUNTY
AND 4409% ARE PLACED OUT OF
COUNTY.
AB AS OF JANUARY FIRST OUR DATA
AS OF JANUARY FIRST SO THAT
RESULTS IN AND AROUND TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED YOUNG PEOPLE BEING
PLACED OUT OUT OF COUNTY FOR
THOSE VERY SPECIALIZED --
INTENSIVE SERVICES [inaudible]
SO -- WHICH
JUST KIND OF TICKET TO WRAP UP.
WE EAT AT THIS THIS THIS IS THE
DISCUSSION THAT WILL TAKE PLACE
LATER TODAY AND OR OR LATER ON
THIS PANEL AND AND IN THE END
THE PANEL LATER.
WE THE DEPARTMENT REMAINS YOU
KNOW COMMITTED TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND OTHERS --
TO AS TO IDENTIFY THE ISSUES AND
TO AND TO WORK THROUGH SOLUTIONS --
TO THAT THAT HAVE --
THAT NEED TO NEED TO OCCUR TO
MODIFY OUR CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
WITHOUT ALL --
POTS AND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
FOLKS MIGHT HAVE.
WHAT WOULD LEAVE THE QUESTIONS
TO THE END OF THE PANEL? FOR DID
YOU HAVE A SPECIFIC QUESTION.
VICE CHAIR MATH.
ON JUST REAL QUICK --
I DIDN'T HEAR YOU MENTION A
NUMBER ON HOW MANY LIKE SPECIAL
NEEDS -- I
EP KIDS AND I KNOW THAT'S ALSO A
LARGE REASON WHY --
CHILDREN GET PLACED OUT OF THE
COUNTIES SELL IT AS WE GO
FORWARD AND LOVE TO HAVE THE
NUMBERS ON THOSE AS WELL.
THANK YOU MR ROSE SEVEN ALSO
HERNANDEZ.
HI AGAIN.
I'M FIRST I'D LIKE TO SAY THANK
YOU TO THE CHAIRS AND STAFF FOR
ELEVATING IN THIS TOPIC --
FOR TODAY'S HEARING SPECIFICALLY
THAT THIS INTERSECTION IS ONE
THAT WE REALLY NEED TO TALK
ABOUT WE KNOW THAT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES THAT ARE QUALITY
CULTURALLY RELEVANT AND
ACCESSIBLE IS ONE THE MOST
IMPORTANT FUNCTIONS THAT THE
SYSTEMS CAN EXECUTE --
SOME FOLKS ALSO KNOW THAT SEE WE
SEE IS A YOUTH LED ORGANIZATION
WE HAVE CHAPTERS FROM STARTING
FROM HUMBLE ALL THE WAY DOWN TO
SAN DIEGO AND WE PUT OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE IN THE DECISION MAKING
SEE.
OF WHAT THEIR PRIORITIES ARE WE
ARE IN YEAR TWO OF A FOSTER
STABILITY CAMPAIGN AND THE
VISION OF THIS CAMPAIGN IS TO
CREATE A YOUTH CENTER PROCESS.
THAT WILL NURTURE THE MIND BODY
AND SOUL CARE THE GOAL OF THIS
CAMPAIGN IS TO FOSTER STABILITY
AND ALL ASPECTS OF THEIR LIVES.
INCLUDING PLACEMENT
RELATIONSHIPS AND LIFE
CONNECTIONS HEALTH AND WELLNESS
AND MENTAL HEALTH TODAY I THINK
WE CAN ASK OURSELVES ABOUT THE
LANGUAGE WERE USING AND HOW WE
TALK ABOUT THIS POPULATION WE
CAN CALL THESE PLACEMENT CHANGES
OR WE CAN CALL THEM LIFE
DISRUPTIONS.
TODAY WILL FOCUS ON THE LAST
PILLAR THAT MY MEMBERS HAVE
ELEVATED AND HIGHLY OUR MEMBERS
THOUGHT SENTIMENTS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS BOTH BROADLY AND
IN REGARDS TO PRESUMPTIVE
TRANSFER.
WHEN MY MEMBERS WHO HAVE LIVED
EXPERIENCE TALK ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH AND WELLNESS STORIES THAT
MISDIAGNOSES OVER MEDICATION
ABSENT CARE GIVERS AND
LONELINESS ARE THEMES THAT
QUICKLY EMERGE?
AND WHEN THEY TALK ABOUT
SOLUTIONS THINGS SUCH AS SYSTEM
CORONATION SOMEONE TO BE ON
THEIR SIDE BETTER SERVICES THAT
ARE NOT TYPICAL CLINICAL
APPROACHES SUCH AS ART THERAPY
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL ANIMALS --
THOSE THEMES EMERGE TO JUST AS
QUICKLY.
THEY'VE EVEN COINED A NEW TERM
CALLED THERAPISTS OF ORIGIN FOR
CONTINUITY IN SERVICES.
AND THE SENTIMENT ALWAYS ENDS UP
BEING.
WE WANT TO LEARN HOW TO HEAL
DEVELOP HEALTHY COPING SKILLS
AND LIVE THE REST OF OUR LIVES
TO BE HAPPY AND HEALTHY.
THIS IS WHAT MY MEMBERS ARE
SAYING.
YET WE KNOW THAT THE SYSTEM OF
DELIVERY IS INCREDIBLY
BUREAUCRATIC IT'S HARD TO
NAVIGATE AND IT'S NOT ALWAYS AS
YOU'D CENTERED AS IT SHOULD BE.
I'D LIKE TO SHARE MY TIME WITH
MY COLLEAGUES CALLA.
HELLO CALIPERS HEY ALL SAN AND I
AM AN ADVOCATE WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE A MENTAL HEALTH AND
THE YOUTH ORGANIZER AND FORMER
YOUTH ADVISORY BOARD MEMBER WITH
THE HUMBOLDT COUNTY TRANSITION
AGE YOUTH COLLABORATION OR EIGHT
CTC.
I WE ARE YOUTH LEADERSHIP AND
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION BASED IN
HUMBLE COUNTY THAT UP LET'S THE
VOICES OF YOUNG PEOPLE WITH
EXPERIENCE AND FOSTER CARE
JUVENILE JUSTICE.
HOMELESSNESS AND THE MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM.
SO I SUPPORT A YOUTH ADVISORY
BOARD AND ON MY YOUTH ADVISORY
BOARD I HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF YOUNG FOSTER LEADERS.
AT THE FOSTER LEADERS THAT I
SUPPORT TELL ME OF THEIR EXTREME
SOCIAL ANXIETY BEING FORCED TO
TAKE PSYCHOTROPIC MEDICATIONS AS
YOUNG AS AGE.
TEN LONELINESS ISOLATION AND
HOPELESS HOW THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
AND TRAUMA PREVENTED THEM FROM
HAVING SUCCESSFUL PLACEMENTS AND
LIFELONG CONNECTIONS PLACEMENTS
AND PEOPLE THEY WISH WERE STILL
IN THEIR LIVES BUT WEREN'T
EQUIPPED TO SUPPORT THEM.
MENTAL HEALTH HAS EVEN BECAUSE
SOME YOUNG PARENTS TO HAVE THEIR
OWN CHILDREN BE INVOLVED IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
THESE CHALLENGES INCREASE WHEN
THEY ARE REMOVED FROM THEIR
COMMUNITIES OF ORIGIN.
THERE'S AN INCREASING NUMBER OF
YOUNG PEOPLE IN OUR RURAL
COUNTIES THAT ARE PLACED OUTSIDE
DUE TO THE LACK OF ADEQUATE
FOSTER HOMES.
ISN'T ENOUGH.
THE EXPERIENCE CHANGES IN
PROVIDERS.
THEY DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO THEIR
NATURAL SUPPORTS AND THAT
CONSTANT DISRUPTIONS EXTREMELY
TRAUMATIZING BUILDING UPON THE
TRAUMA THAT THEY ALREADY HAVE
EXPERIENCE AND CAUSE THEM TO
ENTER THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE TOLD ME A
GOING MONTHS WITHOUT MEDICAL
SERVICES AFTER PLACEMENT CHANGE
AND A LACK OF ADEQUATE PLANNING
TO ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE THEIR
WELLNESS NEEDS MATT.
ADDITIONALLY MY YOUNG LEADER
STATE THAT A LACK OF CONNECTION
ISN'T SOMETHING THAT IS ABLE TO
BE MET WITH THERAPY.
THERE ARE VERY FEW THERAPEUTIC
FOSTER HOMES AND ASK YOUR TWO
PEAS IN RURAL COUNTIES THERE ARE
NONE IN MY COMMUNITY AND WE DO
NOT HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO
BE ABLE TO ADEQUATELY SUPPORT
FOSTER YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS.
AND AS A RESULT THEY ARE FORCED
TO LEAVE THEIR COMMUNITIES OF
ORIGIN.
WE NEED STRONGER COORDINATION OF
CARE AND FUNDING FOR RESOURCE
POOR AREAS OF CALIFORNIA SUCH AS
MINE TO ENSURE THAT OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE TO BE REMOVED
FROM OUR COMMUNITY IS.
IN CLOSING I'D LIKE TO POINT TO
THE KATIE A SETTLEMENT THAT IS
EXPLAINED ON PAGE THREE OF YOUR
BACKGROUND SHE I'M PRETTY
FAMILIAR WITH THE SETTLEMENT
BECAUSE THIS HAS BEEN A PRIORITY
FOR CALIFORNIA FOR SEVERAL YEARS --
AND THE PRIOR PRIORITIES INCLUDE
REALLY SUPPORTING SYSTEM
INTEGRATION AND COORDINATED
SERVICES SO WHEN I SAW THIS I
SCANNED RATHER QUICKLY BEING
SEMI FAMILIAR WITH IT --
WHEN I DID SOMETHING JUMPED OUT
AT ME IN A WAY I HADN'T BEFORE
KATIE WHO'S THE SADDAM IS NAMED
AFTER HIM GREW UP IN FOSTER CARE
AND HAD THIRTY SEVEN PLACEMENT
CHANGES?
THIS NUMBER STOOD OUT NOW
BECAUSE OF RIDLEY ALARMING BUT
HEALTH FAMILIAR WAS --
BOTH CALLIN NICER BUT IN
ORGANIZATIONS WHERE THAT IS NOT
UNCOMMON TO THIS VERY DAY WILL
CAN BOTH.
GIVE YOU A LIST OF YOUNG PEOPLE
THAT ARE STILL EXPERIENCING THIS.
WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE WITH
IS THAT THESE YOUNG PEOPLE?
OUR BRAVE FOR THEIR COURAGEOUS
THEIR PROBLEM SOLVERS AND THEY
DESERVE ALL THE SUPPORT IN COURT
NEEDED SERVICES THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE THEM AND SO MUCH MORE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU --
BRENDON CREOLIZATION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS APRENDER GRAY LUNCH
ACTING DEPUTY DIRECTOR MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER SERVICES.
I'M SO THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO COME TODAY
AND TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT --
THE SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
CERTAIN SERVICES SYSTEM WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES --
WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH OUR
SISTER AGENCY OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES ARE WORKING
ON THE SHARED POPULATION --
OF YOUTH WHO WERE IN FOSTER CARE.
I'M ALL CAN KINDA GO ABROAD ON
ON A A LARGE LEVEL ON WHAT BY
WHO WE ARE WITHIN THE
ORGANIZATION --
WITHIN THE ADMINISTRATION --
SO DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES IS THE SINGLE STATE
AGENCY FOR THE FEDERAL MEDICAID
PROGRAM SO WE OPERATE THAT AS
MEDI CAL IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES --
MY AREA OF THE DEPARTMENT IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR CONTRACTING WITH
THE COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH PLANS
UNDER AYE WHAT'S CALLED THE
NINETEEN FIFTEEN BE SPECIAL
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
WAIVER --
WHICH IS WHERE WE I INDIVIDUALS
WITH ON SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS
AND STUFF FOR CHILDREN SERIOUSLY
EMOTIONALLY DISTURBED CHILDREN --
AND WE HAVE I THINK FIFTY SIX
MENTAL HEALTH PLANS SOME THAT WE
CONTRACT WITH AND AND UNDER THAT
CONTRACT COUNTY IS ESSENTIAL WE
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
PROVISION OF OUR SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OR
ARRANGING FOR THE PROVISION OF
SERVICES SO OFTEN TIMES --
EITHER -- IT
COULD EITHER PROVIDE THE
SERVICES THEMSELVES OR CONTRACT
OUT FOR THOSE FROM --
SERVICES OR SOME COUNTIES MIGHT
HAVE A HYBRID OF BOTH --
FOR CHILDREN UNDER AGE TWENTY
ONE SERVICES ARE PROVIDED UNDER
WHAT'S CALLED EPS D. T. R. EARLY
AND PERIODIC SCREENING DIAGNOSIS
AND DIAGNOSTIC AND TREATMENT --
WHICH IS AN ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM
IT MEANS THESE CHILDREN --
WHO MEET SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES MEDICAL NECESSITY
CRITERIA ARE ENTITLED TO THESE
SERVICES --
THEIR CRITERIA FOR CHILDREN --
IS A LITTLE BIT LESS STRINGENT
THAN IT IS FOR ADULTS SEEKS TO
CORRECT OR AMELIORATE OR PREVENT --
FURTHER --
ISSUES FOR THE CHILD AND YOUTH
SO -- SO
THERE ARE A LOT OF CHILDREN AND
YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE WHO ARE IN
ON THE SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES SYSTEM WHEN WE HAVE A
DATA MANAGER DATA SHARING
AGREEMENT BETWEEN OUR DEPARTMENT
SO WE'RE ABLE --
TO MONITORED THAT THAT --
THAT IS THE SHARED POPULATION --
WE DO AN ANNUAL --
PERFORMANCE DASHBOARD --
WHERE WE MATCH THE DATA WITH OUR
SOCIAL SERVICES DATA FOR THESE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH --
AND JUST TO GIVE YOU KIND OF AN
IDEA -- WE
HAVE ABOUT 43% OF THE YOUTH IN A
PARTICULAR IN ANY GIVEN FISCAL
YEAR -- WHO
ACTUALLY --
PENETRATE INTO OUR SYSTEM SO HIT
OUR SYSTEM WHICH IS TYPICALLY AN
ASSESSMENT AND THEN ABOUT --
30% CAN CONTINUE ON HAVE YOU GOT
ON THAT FIGURE ON AND THAT IS --
IT'S OUT OF THE WHOLE MEDI CAL
POPULATION SO IT DOESN'T COST
SLICE IT MIGHT NEED --
THAT IS SOMETHING WE'RE WORKING
ON WITH OUR OUR SISTER AGENCY
AND WITH THE C. C. R. WITH
CONTINUE OUR CARE REFORM IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF KAONS ON THE
CHILD ADOLESCENT NEEDS AND
STRENGTHS --
TO ALL WILL BE ABLE TO DO THAT
SO WE'LL BE ABLE TO KIND OF
PLAYER ON THE SEA WHICH KIDS
NEED THOSE SERVICES --
AND THEN AND THEN SEE WHAT THE
REFERRALS THE SCREENS IN THE
REFERRALS AND KNOW WHICH ONES
ACTUALLY GET IT --
AND JUST FOR COMPARISON --
FOR THE ENTIRE MEDI CAL CHILDREN
AND YOUTH POPULATION IT'S ABOUT --
4% --
PENETRATE INTO THE SYSTEM AND
ABOUT 3% CONTINUE ON FOR
SERVICES.
SO DEFINITELY A LOT OF MONEY A
MUCH HIGHER PROPORTION OF FOSTER
CARE SIR --
CHILDREN RECEIVE SPECIAL TO
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES THAN THE
GENERAL MEDI CAL POPULATION --
IN ADDITION TO THE SPECIAL TO
MENTAL HEALTH CARVED OUT SYSTEM
WITH THAT'S WERE OPERATED WHERE
COUNTIES --
IF THROUGH THE AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT AS OF JULY JANUARY ONE
TWENTY FOUR TEAM --
THE STATE OUR DOCTOR THE
ESSENTIAL --
HEALTH BENEFITS KLAY EXPANDED --
BENEFITS IN THE MANAGED CARE
AREA -- FOR
SO PRIMARY CARE TO BE ABLE TO
DELIVER NON SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OFTENTIMES IT'S
REFERRED TO AS MILD TO MODERATE
BUT CHILDREN WITH MILD TO
MODERATE CAN ALSO RECEIVE
SPECIAL TO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES --
WE ALSO DO TRACK THOSE DATA TO
THIS TO SEE WHICH SYSTEM THAT
THE CHILDREN AND YOUTH OR MOST
OFTEN RECEIVING THEIR SERVICES --
AND SO -- SO
WE HAVE THESE TWO SYSTEMS WE
HAVE MANAGED CARE AND AND IN
TERMS OF UTILIZATION TO OUR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH WHO WERE IN
FOSTER CARE ABOUT HALF OF THEM
ARE IN MANAGED CARE AND ABOUT
HALF OF THEM ARE IN FEE FOR
SERVICE.
THERE'S NO MANDATE THAT CHILDREN
NEED TO GO INTO MANAGED CARE
IT'S AN OPTION --
BUT WE'RE SEEING IT CHANGE AND
SHIFT OVER TIME ABOUT 80% OF THE
GENERAL MEDICAL POPULATION IS IN
MANAGED CARE --
IN TERMS OF KT EIGHTY OF A LOT
OF WORK HAS BEEN DONE BETWEEN
OUR DEPARTMENTS --
AS WAS MENTIONED BEFORE --
ARE IN TERMS OF BUILDING OUT THE
THE SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES THAT ARE AVAILABLE SO
UNDER THE COR PRACTICE MODEL WE
HAVE --
INTENSIVE CARE COORDINATION AND
INTENSIVE HOME BASED SERVICES I
SEE SEE AN H. B. US --
THERAPEUTIC FOSTER CARE IS IS
GOING TO BE WRIST IS TO BE
BUILDING OUT --
TO PROVIDE CHILDREN AND YOUTH
WITH THE SUPPORT THE AND HAPPY
AND HEALTHY --
AND WE'VE BEEN CONTINUING TO
WORK ON THAT AS RUSSIAN HOUSE
ROLLED INTO THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE REFORM --
AND IN TERMS OF CONTINUUM OF
CARE REFORM WE'VE BEEN DOING A
LOT OF WORK WITH ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND WORKING WITH OUR COUNTIES --
TO MAKE SURE THAT --
YOU KNOW THAT STR TV'S THE SHORT
TERM RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC
PROGRAMS ARE ON GETTING WEEK
WE'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAM APPROVAL SOMEONE
FOR LICENSING DONE WE WE HAVE A
ROLE IN THAT.
AND SUPPORTING OUR COUNTIES
WE'VE BEEN --
HOLDING -- A
LOT OF TRAININGS AND CONVENIENCE
AND I'M DOING A LOT OF WORK WITH --
WITH -- ARE
COUNTY PARTNERS AND AND OUR OWN
SISTER AGENCY --
TO TO MAKE SURE INFORMATION IS --
DISSEMINATED WE'VE DONE
INFORMATION NOTICES --
AND AND AND HOLD RIGHT MEETINGS
WERE WE TO IS THAT COME UP --
SO WE'RE WE'RE WORKING VERY
CLOSELY AND QUITE A OF AUSTIN A
LOT OF TIME WORKING ON TO TO
HELP THOSE WHO ARE POPULATION.
ACCESS THE SERVICES I THINK WITH
THAT [inaudible]
CONCLUDE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AKA.
KRISTA.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AT THIS
TIME I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO
ADD FOR DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES.
VERY GOOD [inaudible]
KIM SUDIRMAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M CONSIDER MEN
AND I AM A RETIRED BEING ABLE
HEALTH DIRECTOR AND A CONSULTANT
FOR THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION.
BY WARNER FIRST SAY AS A LICENSE
CLINICIAN --
SERVING FOSTER KIDS IS JUST
CRITICAL. TO ADDRESS THEIR NEEDS
AND SO I'M JUST REALLY GLAD THAT
THEY'RE HERE.
AT THE TABLE TODAY.
SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I'M
GONNA BE SHARING ITS KIND THAT I
KNOW THAT WITH THIS WHOLE PANEL
IS ABOUT THAT BIGGER PICTURE.
YOU'RE GONNA HEAR THE NEXT PANEL
ABOUT MORE DETAILS AND SO FIRST
OF ALL I'VE BEEN ASKED TO SHARE
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT AN
EXAMPLE OF THE PROCESS WITH THE
JURISDICTION COUNTY --
WHEN THERE IS A PLACEMENT FIGHT
NEED AND UNFORTUNATELY THAT
FOSTER CHILD OR YOUTH CANNOT --
RESIDING IN THE COUNTY SO THERE
HAS TO BE A PLACEMENT OUT OF
COUNTY AND USUALLY THAT'S
RELATED AS MR ROSE SAID.
THE SERVICE NEED LEVEL ISN'T
AVAILABLE AND IN MANY COUNTIES
THERE IS NOT --
THAT SUFFICIENT RESIDENTIAL
NEEDS AS WELL FOR THE CHILD SO
THEY DO HAVE TO BE PLACED ON A
COUNTY --
THAT PART OF THAT PROCESS
PARTICULARLY THAT WITH C. C. R.
INCLUDES A CHILD AND FAMILY TEAM
WHICH MUST INCLUDE THE CHILD OR
YOUTH TO PARTICIPATE IF AGE
APPROPRIATE.
AND THE FAMILY --
TO PARTICIPATE IN WATER THE
NEEDS THAT CAN --
THAT CAN BE IDENTIFIED SO THAT
THE PLACEMENT IS APPROPRIATE AND
HELPFUL AS POSSIBLE AND TO AVOID.
MULTIPLE PLACEMENTS SO THAT'S
REALLY CRITICAL THE PLACING
AGENCY AND IN THIS INSTANCE I
USE -- CHILD
WELFARE IS THE EXAMPLE ALTHOUGH
WE KNOW OF COURSE THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM ALSO PLACES
CHILDREN --
SO COUNTY A CHILD WELFARE --
PLACE IT DETERMINES THEIR TO AN
INTER AGENCY MEDI --
THE TEAM HAS DISK NEEDS IN INTER
AGENCY MAYBE WE'LL TALK ABOUT
THE NEEDS IF IT'S THAT THE NEED
OF A NOW USED TO BE CALLED A
GROUP HOME.
AND NOW --
ESSERE TP A SHORT TERM THERAPY
SHORT TERM THERAPEUTIC --
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT PROGRAM
AND SO AS THEY GO INTO THAT LOOK
FOR THAT I'M THE MIDDLE HEALTH
PLAN WILL DO AN ASSESSMENT TO
DETERMINE MEDICAL NECESSITY IF
THE CHILD HAS NOT ALREADY BEEN
ASSESSED FOR MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS.
AND THEN.
THERE WILL BE A DISCUSSION ABOUT
WHETHER PERCENT OF TRANSFERS
NEEDED AND I KNOW YOU'LL BE
TALKING ABOUT THAT.
SOME MORE IN THE IN THE NEXT
PANEL -- THE
MENTAL HEALTH PLAN MAKES CAN
MAKE A RECOMMENDATION AS PART OF
THE INTERAGENCY PLACEMENT
COMMITTEE OR THE CHILD AND
FAMILY TEAM BUT DOES NOT HAVE A
LEGAL AUTHORITY. TO FORMALLY --
IDENTIFY OR APPEAL ANY
RECOMMENDATION THAT IS MADE AND
THAT IS SOMETHING AS A TREATING
AGENCY THAT IT'S BEEN A CONCERN
OF THE MENTAL HEALTH PLANS THAT
HAS BEEN EXPRESSED IN OTHER
SETTINGS.
BUT I WANT TO MENTION THAT
BECAUSE AS THE RESPONSIBLE --
THE RESPONSIBLE IN IT'S BECAUSE
OFTEN WE KNOW --
CLINICALLY IN RELATION TO THE
CHILD NEEDS AND WOULD LIKE TO
PLAY A ROLE IN THAT IN IN
SOMETIMES IN A DEEPER WAY THAN
WE CURRENTLY ARE ABLE.
TO SO IF THE CHILD IS PLACED OUT
OF COUNTY THEN THE MENTAL HEALTH
PLAN -- AND
THE CHILD IS PRESUMPTIVELY
TRANSFERRED THEN THE HOST MENTAL
HEALTH PLAN HAS RESPONSIBILITY
TO RANGE FOR AND PROVIDE.
FOR THE MEDICALLY NECESSARY
SPECIAL.
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
THAT MIS READ MS GREEN WHICH WAS
TALKING ABOUT.
AND SO.
I'M THEY RECEIVE THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY PRIOR TO SERVICES
IT'S SO IMPORTANT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AS WAS MENTIONED IS A
PART OF HEALTH SERVICES.
AND SO BEFORE SERVICES CAN BE
CAN CONSENT FOR TREATMENT.
INFORMED CONSENT FOR TREATMENT
AS WITH ANY HEALTH SERVICE
MENTAL HEALTH IS A PART OF
HEALTH SERVICES NEEDS TO BE GAME
AN ASSESSMENT WHICH HOPEFULLY
HAS BEEN DONE ALREADY.
NEEDS TO THE HOST MENTAL HEALTH
PLAN IS TO RECEIVE AN
AUTHORIZATION NEEDS TO BE GIVEN
AGAIN AS IT WOULD IN ANY HEALTH
SERVICE.
WHETHER YOU NEED SURGERY OR WITH
YOU NEED SPECIAL TO MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES THE HEALTH PLAN
AUTHORIZES --
THE SERVICES SO TO AGAIN TO
DETERMINE MEDICAL NECESSITY WE
ALWAYS WOULD PREFER TO HAVE THE
COURT APPROVED JB TO TWENTY FORM
WHICH BASICALLY ALLOWS.
IF IF MEDICATIONS ARE PRESCRIBED
REST.
AND SO THOSE ARE SOME DOCUMENTS
THAT ARE VERY CRITICAL BEFORE
SERVICES CAN REALLY BEGIN.
AND THEN THE PRACTITIONER WHO'S
GOING TO WORK WITH THE CHILD OR
YOUTH.
WORKS WITH THEM TO DEVELOP A
CLIENT PLAN TALK ABOUT SERVICES
TALK ABOUT FREQUENCY AND SET THE
GOALS AND OBJECTIVES AND SO
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
AS THE PROCESS BEGINS.
SO THEN WE GET THE CONTRACTS AND
OF COURSE THERE'S MONEY INVOLVED --
AND SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES --
BECAUSE SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT AS WE LOOK AT WHAT ARE
THE NEEDS --
WE DEVELOP CONTRACTS AND WE
TALKED ABOUT --
THERE ARE MENTAL HEALTH PLANS
THAT PROVIDE THE SERVICES
DIRECTLY AND THEY'RE ALSO VERY
MANY COUNTIES MOST COUNTIES
CONTRACT OUT.
MUCH OF THEIR FOR A LARGE
PORTION OF THEIR MEDI CAL
SPECIALTY MIDDLE HEALTH SERVICES
PARTICULARLY FOR THOSE CHILDREN
WHO ARE IN.
RESIDENTIAL CARE --
IN A S. T. R. T. P. AND MANY
TIMES IN --
IN A FOSTER HOME AS WELL.
IN A RESOURCE FAMILY HOME AND SO
ON WE CANNOT DO THE COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH PLAN CANNOT DO
THEIR SERVICES WITHOUT OUR
PARTNER.
THE COMMUNITY BASED PROVIDERS
THAT IS SO CRITICAL AND SO WE DO
CONTRACT WITH THEM AND SO
THERE'S A WHOLE PROCESS FOR
NEGOTIATING RATES.
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT COSTS THE
PROJECTION OF AMOUNT OF SERVICES
BOTH FOR AN INDIVIDUAL CHILD BUT
ALSO.
OVERALL IF MOST COMMONLY
PROVIDERS SERVE MORE THAN ONE
CHILD -- SO
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE PROJECTED
AMOUNT OF MINUTES AND THAT'S HOW
YOU COME UP WITH THE RATE.
AND IN THE MEDICAL SYSTEM THERE
ARE MULTIPLE KINDS OF SERVICES
SO UNFORTUNATELY THERE IS A RATE
FOR EACH KIND OF SERVICE.
SO AS YOU CAN SEE THE
CONTRACTING PROCESS IS NOT A
SIMPLE PROCESS AND OUR OUR
PARTNERS WILL BE PROBABLY
MENTIONING THAT WHEN IN THE NEXT
PANEL.
BUT THAT'S KIND OF THE PROCESS
FOR DEVELOPING THE CONTRACT
THERE STILL HAS TO ALL OF THE
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH PLANS HAVE
TO GO BACK TO THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS MAKES
THE DECISION AND AUTHORIZES AND
APPROVED THE CONTRACT AND SIGN
IT.
THERE ARE SOME COUNTIES THAT ARE
ABLE TO DO --
BROADER AGREEMENTS THAT ALLOWS
HIM INDIVIDUAL FLEXIBILITY ON A
CASE BY CASE BASIS.
AND SO DOES IT TO COUNTY BY
COUNTY DECISION AND SO AS YOU AS
IS REALLY SHOULD MENTION THERE
ARE FIFTY SIX MENTAL HEALTH
PLANS SO THERE'S A LOT OF
NEGOTIATION BACK AND FORTH.
AND THEN SO JUST A COMMENT ABOUT
FUNDING --
SO MENTAL HEALTH PLANS THE WAY
THEY'RE REIMBURSED FROM FEDERAL
FINANCIAL PARTICIPATION IS A
MUST INCUR THE COST FIRST IT'S A
REIMBURSEMENT SO THEY MUST PAY
THE PROVIDER WHETHER THE
PROVIDER IS THEIR OWN COUNTY
EMPLOYEE.
OR WHETHER IT IS --
AND CONTRACTED PROVIDER THEY
MUST FIRST PAY THEM AND THEN
THEY CAN SUBMIT CLAIMS FOR
REIMBURSEMENT SO AS YOU CAN SEE
THERE'S A PROCESS THAT TAKES
SOME TIME.
SO FOR A CONTRACT PROVIDER IT
CAN TAKE AROUND AND THIS IS AN
AVERAGE THREE TO FOUR MONTHS BY
THE TIME A CHILD SO.
IT THE PROCESS TAKES SOME TIME
SO IF IT IF A CHILD RECEIVE
SERVICES IN MONTH.
ONE AT THE END OF MONTH ONE THE
PROVIDER WILL INVOICE THE COUNTY
IN MONTH TO TO BE REIMBURSED.
IN MY THREE AND FOR THE COUNTY
PROCESS BACK AND FORTH WITH THE
PROVIDER TO MAKE SURE
EVERYTHING'S LINED UP ALL THE
EYES ARE DOT AND HE'S OUR CROSS
TO SUBMIT THE CLAIMS.
AND SO THAT'S IN MONTH THREE AND
FOUR AND SOMETIMES AT THAT
PROCESS GOES QUICKLY AND
SOMETIMES ARE SOME PUMPS AND YOU
HAVE TO DO SOME NEGOTIATION.
AND MONTH FOREIGN FIVE THEN THE
COUNTY ALL OF THEIR PROVIDERS
AND THEIR OWN COUNTY EMPLOYEES
AND THEY CAN SUBMIT A CLAIM. TO
THE STATE THROUGHTHE I. T. W.
S. SYSTEM AT DH CS AND TEY THAT
IS HOW THEY ARE BEGINNING TO
DRAW DOWN THEN.
THE FEDERAL FINANCIAL
PARTICIPATION SO THAT'S THE 50%
THAT THEY ARE REIMBURSED FOR THE
100% COST OF SERVICES THAT THEY
HAVE INCURRED.
INITIALLY.
THE STATE WILL THEN PROCESS THE
CLAIMS THAT CAN TAKE.
ON THAT MOVES YOU INTO MONTH
FIVE OR SIX AGAIN BACK AND FORTH
DEPENDING ON HOW THE PROCESS
GOES.
AND THEN SOMEWHERE IN MONTHS
SEVEN EIGHT OR NINE AGAIN
DEPENDING ON THE PROCESS THE
COUNTY IS REIMBURSE THE 50%.
FROM MONTH.
ONE THAT'S FROM THE FIRST FROM
THE FOR SERVICE SO THAT'S KIND
OF HOW THE FUNDING GOES --
THE OTHER 50% COUNTY USE THE
REALIGNMENT THEY RECEIVED --
BETWEEN. NINETEEN NINETY
NINETEEN NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT
TWENTY ELEVEN AND THEN THERE ARE
WITH SOME OF THE
RESPONSIBILITIES UNDER CC ARE.
THERE ARE SOME PROP THIRTY
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
IN THE GENERAL FUND BUDGET THAT
THE COUNTIES ALSO RECEIVE SO
THAT'S KIND OF A REAL QUICK --
FINANCIAL PIECE OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH COSTS AND THEN JUST A
QUICK COMMENT ABOUT CHALLENGES --
AS YOU CAN SEE MET BASED ON THAT
TIME FRAME THE MENTAL HEALTH
PART PLANTS ARE OPERATING ON
PREVIOUS REVENUES THEY'RE NOT
OPERATING IN THE YEAR.
THAT THEY'RE PROVIDING SERVICES
BASED ON THE REVENUE THEY
RECEIVE THE CAP BECAUSE THEY
HAVEN'T RECEIVED IT YET.
SO THAT IS JUST THE COUNTIES ARE
USED TO THAT BUT THAT IS THE
PROCESS THINKER THE COST THERE'S
A CEILINGS WITH THE GENERAL FUND
THAT THEY HAVE --
WORK THROUGH WITH THEIR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
AND SO THEY HAVE A BUDGET
CEILING SOME COUNTIES GET
GENERAL FUND FROM THE COUNTY
SOME MENTAL HEALTH PLANS.
GET GENERAL FUND DOLLARS FROM
THE COUNTIES SOME DO SUPERVISORS
SO CASH FLOW CAN BE A CHALLENGE
AT TIMES AND SO THOSE THINGS AS
WE NOW LOOK AT CROSSING COUNTY
LINES.
WITH PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER
THERE'S AN IMPACT BECAUSE NOW
THERE ARE AS WE SET TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER THERE ARE.
COUNTIES WHERE THERE ARE NO --
RESIDENTIAL GROUP HOMES FOR
FOSTER HOMES LOCALLY AND SO KIDS
ARE PLACED AT A COUNTY AND SO
THERE'S AN IMPACT THERE.
AND THEN I JUST WANTED TO
COMMENT NEVADA COUNTY WANTED TO
MAKE SURE TO DATE THEY HAVE
TWENTY EIGHT KIDS --
PLACE IN THEIR COUNTY UNDER
PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER WHICH
REPRESENTS SIXTEEN COUNTIES --
SO THAT'S HOW MANY OF THE
COUNTIES ARE FUNCTIONING TODAY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH.
QUESTIONS FROM THE I ADDED IT
WANTED TO TOUCH ON WHAT IT'S
IT'S MISS SODERMAN CORRECT
[inaudible]
A THE A THINKING OUT IT I MEAN I
I HEAR IT'S SIX TO EIGHT MONTHS
ON THE FAST SIDE AND I'VE HEARD
OF BACKLOGS OF OVER TWO TO THREE
YEARS.
AND THAT'S TO ME THAT'S JUST
UNACCEPTABLE.
AND YOU KNOW YOU WOULD THINK BY
NOW WE WOULD HAVE HAD SOME KIND
OF A STATEWIDE STANDARD SO
EVERYBODY'S TALKING TO EACH
OTHER BACK AND FORTH AND I I'D
LOVE TO HEAR MORE ABOUT THAT BUT
SOMETHING AND I'M INTERESTED IN
TALKING WITH THE CHAIR.
ABOUT FIGURING OUT SOMETHING AND
MAYBE AS A COMMITTEE BILL. TO
FIX SOME OF THESE KINKS SO WE
CAN HAVE THE ACROSS THE BOARD
FOR OUR YOUTH AND ACTUALLY HAVE
THE REIMBURSEMENTS COMING IN ON
TIME.
MISTER ROSE READ I I SAW HANDLE
IT FOR YOU KNOW I I GRABBED THE
MIKE AND THEN REALIZE THAT YOU
WOULD THINK I WOULD RESPOND BY.
BUT TECHNICALLY THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES IS --
IS THOUGH THAT AS HAS BEEN
SKRILLEX DESCRIBED AS THE FOR IS
THAT PAYER FOR THAT SO I I CAN'T
SPEAK ON THEIR BEHALF AND AND I
I'M I'M I'M AWARE I'M ALSO ON
BUDGETS OF ONE AND I MEAN I'M
HAPPY TO ADDRESS THAT IF YOU
WANT TO MAYBE --
IS SUPERMAN MIGHT NOT REALIZE
BUT I'M HIS BECAUSE SHE'S NOT
INVOLVED IN THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT DEAL WITH --
TO THE BASE AND THE GROWTH --
ALLOCATION DISCUSSIONS FOR THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SUB ACCOUNT --
BUT WE EVERY YEAR AND FOR IT FOR
CERTAIN QUITE A FEW YEARS SINCE --
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN THAT RELY
MOSTLY DOWN NO THAT'S FINE --
BUT EVER SINCE THEN --
FROM SINCE REALIGNMENT THIS
REALIGNMENT --
TO WITHOUT ANNUAL DISCUSSIONS
AND IT'S IT'S WITH --
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE THE C.
SACK --
CALPERS EXHORTATION OF COUNTIES --
HAVE EXTENSIVE DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
THE ALLOCATION AND SO --
TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES WE
ACTUALLY WERE ABLE --
TO COME UP WITH A METHODOLOGY --
THAT JUST STARTED THIS PAST YEAR
OR TWO WHERE WE WERE WERE ABLE
TO USE -- WE
USE CLAIMS AS PART OF IT --
WHICH WHICH INSTRUMENT TALKED
ABOUT -- BUT
WE'RE ALSO USING --
FOSTER CARE AND DISABLED EIGHT
CODES IN MEDI CAL TO BE ABLE TO
DETERMINE THE OTHER HOUSE SO
THAT WE CAN GET THAT MONEY OUT
TO THE COUNTIES SO.
JUST JUST TO KIND OF UPDATE ON
THAT PIECE OF IT BECAUSE THAT'S
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT'S
HAPPENED RECENTLY SOME.
THANK YOU FOR SHARING THAT --
MY AT MY OTHER QUESTION AND IT'S
IT'S JUST KIND OF MORE TO KIND
OF KEEP US ON THE SAME PAGE THE
MY UNDERSTANDING AND BASED ON
YOUR TESTIMONY --
YOU KNOW IF IF THE CHILDREN ARE
ENTITLED TO EXERCISE BUT OF
SERVICES.
THE COUNTIES DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY EITHER I I KNOW ONE OF
MY COUNTIES LITERAL ONLY HAS --
ONE FOSTER HOME THAT DOES SIGN
LANGUAGE --
FOR SPECIAL NEEDS KIDS SO.
SHE'S COMPLETELY BLOCKED.
AND SO TO GET AND I KNOW --
BECAUSE I ACTUALLY KNOW HER
THROUGH ANOTHER ORGANIZATION BUT
YOU KNOW THERE'S TIMES WERE THE
COUNTY POLITICAL CAN USE WHOLE
THIS KIT FOR ENACT.
IN AND THEN WE GET INTO THE
GROUP HOME SCENARIO AND I KNOW A
LOT OF THE CRITICISMS WE GET
WITH THE GROUP HOMES IS YOU KNOW
THESE ARE KIND OF TRAINING CAMPS
FOR THE BAD KIDS.
AND YOU DON'T WANT A NEW KID AGO
NECESSARILY THERE --
OFF THE BAT BUT IN SOME CASES
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS --
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T GET A HOLD OF
ANOTHER FAMILY MEMBER OR
SOMETHING ELSE.
DELICIOUS I MEAN FOR FOR ME AS A
DAD ABILITIES AND THINGS IT'S
IT'S VERY CONCERNING --
THAT WE HAVE SO MANY COUNTIES OF
SPECIAL IN OUR RURAL AREAS --
AND THEN READING OVER YOU KNOW.
WITH WITH KATIE --
EVEN IN LA WERE HAVING THESE
PROBLEMS SO IT TO ME IT'S
SOMETHING MORE IS GOING TO BE
DONE -- TO
ENSURE THAT THESE THINGS ARE
HAPPENING.
SO ON DEFINITELY OPEN TO
SPEAKING WITH ALL OF THE ON WAYS
TO ADDRESS THAT.
YES.
I JUST WANTED TO COMMENT THAT --
YOU KNOW I THINK WE HAVE A HUGE
SHORTAGE OF FOSTER HOMES NOW
REFER TO AS RESOURCE FAMILY
HOMES --
THAT WE HAVEN'T REALLY MANY
STELLAR --
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES TODAY
THAT ARE IN CONGREGATE CARE AND
OF COURSE WE WANT THREE CC ARE
TO BE ABLE TO BRING KIDS INTO A
FAMILY SENDING AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE WHICH WE THAT THE
NUMBERS HAVE REALLY GREATLY
DECREASED CONSIDERABLY.
BUT I DO KNOW THAT THERE ARE
TIMES UNFORTUNATELY WHERE
CHILDREN DO NEED TO BE IN
CONGREGATE CARE INSTEAD OF IN A
FAMILY HOME AND WE HAVE SOME
STELLAR ONE SO I DO REALLY WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THAT.
WE HAVE A SHORTAGE BECAUSE THERE
ARE MANY COUNTIES THAT DON'T
EVEN HAVE ONE RESIDENTIAL
FACILITY IN THEIR COUNTY AND
THERE'S A NEED FOR THAT AS WELL.
WERE ALSO WORKING ON THAT WITH
THE LETTERMAN COALITION FOR SOME
HOUSING THINGS.
IF I MAY I JUST WANTED TO
ADDRESS BRIEFLY THE PORTLAND AND
SO.
OFTEN HISTORICALLY THERE IS A
LOT OF THE WORK HAS BEEN AND I'M
KIND OF ROUTINE AND KIND OF
REGULAR RECRUITMENT --
KIND OF G. THAT I WHAT I OFTEN
THINK OF HIS GENERAL RECRUITMENT --
GOING -- TO
LOCATIONS AND TALKING TO PEOPLE
WHO -- WHO --
ARE HISTORICALLY KNOWN FOR
HELPING OTHERS AND AND
RECRUITING FROM THAT BASE WHAT
WE'VE LEARNED RECENTLY --
ACTUALLY NOT SO RECENTLY BUT OR
WREAKING CONTINUING TO LEARN
ABOUT RECENTLY IS REALLY THAT
NEED TO FOCUS ON CHILD SPECIFIC
RECRUITMENT AND ESPECIALLY FOR
WHEN YOU HAVE --
YOUNG PEOPLE THAT HAVE --
SOME PRETTY --
A PARTICULAR NEED OR OFTEN WITH --
WITH TEENAGERS --
PARTICULARLY AS WELL SO I THINK
OUR CAR COUNTIES ARE OFTEN --
YOU KNOW DOING TWO THINGS DOING
RECRUITMENT AT TWO LEVELS ONE IS
KIND OF A GENERAL RECRUITMENT TO
KEEP.
A NEW FAMILIES ENGAGE IN THE
SYSTEM AS AS OTHER FAMILIES --
ADOPTING LEAVE OR TAKE
GUARDIANSHIP AND A RENEWED --
NEED AND COMMITMENT FOR A CHILD
SPECIFIC RECRUITMENT TO TO
ADDRESS THE SPECIAL NEEDS OF OF
MANY YOUNG PEOPLE.
THANK YOU --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STUFF.
THANK YOU AND I'M AND AND I'M
GLAD TO SEE THAT SOME OF THESE
PIECES ARE ARE STARTING TO WORK
TOGETHER BUT I REMAINED A LITTLE
BIT CONCERNED.
BECAUSE WE'VE TRIED TO PUT SOME
OF THE MENTAL HEALTH PIECES INTO.
THE CC ARE UP FRONT AND THAT HAS
BEEN REALLY BAD A CHALLENGE IN
IMPLEMENTATION AND HEARING FROM
SOME OF THE COUNTIES IN HEARING
FROM SOME.
OF THE FOLKS WHO REALLY TRYING
TO MAKE THIS WORK.
WITH THIS NOTION WITH THE
BEHAVIOR HOUSE SYSTEM REALLY
JUST WANTING TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THAT CASES ARE DIAGNOSED CIVIL
THAT THAT THERE'S BEEN.
MORE OF AN EMPHASIS ON
CONTROLLING UTILIZATION REALLY
THAN BEING CREATIVE AND MAKING
SURE THAT EVERY KID WHO COMES IN
THE SYSTEM BECAUSE BY DEFINITION
EVERY KID WHO COMES IN THE
SYSTEM.
HAS SIGNIFICANT MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS.
IT MAY NOT NECESSARILY RISE TO
LEVEL DIAGNOSIS NOTED NOR SHOULD
IT BUT THEY ARE THEY'RE COMING
WITH TRAUMA.
AND EVERY STEP THAT WE MAKE
THESE ADD TO THAT TRAUMA.
AND WE LOOK MORE BROADLY AT THE
SYSTEM WITH ALL THE MHSAA MONEY
THAT THE COUNTY CITY OR SITTING
ON THAT THE STATE'S SITTING ON
AT IT SEEMS ALMOST THAT WE HAVE
SO MANY HURDLES AND GATES. TO
GETTING SERVICES PROVIDED TO
KIDS WHEN THEY NEED IT AS THEY
NEED IT.
THAT THE SYSTEM HAS BECOME
OVERLY CUMBERSOME.
I KNOW SOME COUNTIES ARE
STRUGGLING GETTING ASKED YEAR
TEEPEES THE LICENSES THAT THEY
NEED AND AND THEN MAKING SOME
DECISIONS.
OF WHERE THOSE.
FACILITIES NEED TO GO AND
POTENTIALLY EVEN LICENSING S.
YOUR TV'S OUT OF COUNTY FOR
THEIR OWN KIDS.
WHEN SOMETIMES THEY HAVE SOME OF
THOSE SOME POTENTIALLY GOOD
PROVIDERS INSIDE AND SOME OF
THAT'S LOCAL POLITICS AND?
AND OTHER DISCONNECT BETWEEN
SOME OF THE SYSTEMS THAT NEED TO
WORK BUT WE'VE GOT TO GET
OURSELVES.
OVER THOSE.
CHALLENGES AND ADD OVER THOSE
CONFRONTATIONS BETWEEN.
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL AND AT THE
STATE LEVEL AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE ON THAT SAME PAGE HELPING
COUNTIES IMPLEMENT PROVIDING THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AS
NECESSARY.
GETTING THEM TO THE POINT WHERE
THEY CAN BE SPENDING MONEY IN
THE WAY THAT WE ENVISIONED WITH
WHAT C. C. R. WAS WAS ULTIMATELY
TRYING TO DO AND I AM JUST NOT
SURE THAT THAT MENTAL HEALTH
PEAS.
HAS IT IS JELLING IN THE WAY OR
AS QUICKLY AS WE HAD INTENDED
UNDER CC ARE SO THAT'S A PIECE
THAT I THINK WE ABSOLUTELY NEED
TO WORK ON AND IF WE CAN START
TO RETHINK THE SYSTEM MAY IT'S
OF THE KIDS.
THEN WE CAN DO A BETTER JOB IN
SOME OF THE MORE RURAL AREAS
WHERE THERE HAVEN'T
TRADITIONALLY BAD.
BAD AS MUCH SUPPORTS.
AND YOU KNOW THE COMMENTS THAT.
THERE ARE SOME GOOD COVERAGE
CARE FACILITIES YET POTENTIALLY
BUT THERE ARE SO MANY THAT ARE
NOT GOOD FOR KIDS.
THAT'S WHY THESE HUGE PUSH AWAY
AND MORE FOR INDIVIDUALIZED
PLACEMENT AND WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE THE SYSTEM OF BEST YEAR
TEEPEES WHERE WE TO BRING KIDS
AND GIVE THEM A HOUSE OR IS A
NEED GIVEN THE HELP THAT THEY
NEED.
AND THEN.
AND CONTINUE TO HELP THEM IN THE
US HERE WHO GET THE READY FOR
PLACEMENTS YEAH WE ABSOLUTELY
NEED TO HAVE THOSE PLACEMENTS IN
EACH COUNTY. FOR THE SERVICES
NEED TO GO AND WRAPAROUND AND
REALLY HELP THAT CHILD ONCE
THEY'RE OUT AND THE FAMILIES
BECAUSE AS WE ARE AT THIS ROSE I
ABSOLUTELY AGREE AND THAT THAT
CHILD SPECIFIC RECRUITMENT.
BECAUSE SOME OF THESE FAMILIES
NEED TO BE BETTER PREPARED FOR
THE KIDS THAT THEY'RE TAKING IN
THE CHALLENGES THAT THAT THEY'RE
HAVING.
AND THAT'S WHY WE TEND TO FOCUS
ON KIND OF A MID LEVEL KIDS AND
I'M NOT SURE WE WE HAVE REALLY
ADDRESS THE MOST CHALLENGING
DIFFICULT.
KIDS TO SERVE.
IN THIS PROCESS IS WE REALLY TRY
AND SORT THROUGH.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO FOR AGES KIDS
SO WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO GO
I'M I'M?
GLAD A VERY HAPPY TO HEAR THAT
YOU FEEL YOU MAKING PROGRESS IN
WORKING ACROSS AGENCIES.
BUT I WOULD ASK THAT WE REALLY
START TO FOCUS EVEN MORE ON THAT
THAT WE MAKE SURE WE'RE ABLE TO
SPEND THE MONEY AND ASSIST THE
COUNTIES. FOR KIDS AS THEY COME
INTO THE SYSTEM THAT THEY GET
THE HELP THEY NEED.
AS THEY NEEDED AS THEY PERCENT.
GIVEN THE THE COMPLICATIONS THAT
THEY HAVE AND JUST DOESN'T QUITE
SEEM TO BE WORKING THAT WELL IF
THERE ARE THINGS THAT WE CAN DO.
TO BREAK DOWN SOME OF THAT.
THE RED TAPE THE THE OLD WAYS OF
DOING THINGS THE RELUCTANCE.
TO ABLE TO APPLY THOSE MONIES AS
AND WHEN NEEDED THEN WE NEED TO
BE A PART OF OF THAT
CONVERSATION TO SIDE I THINK SO
LONG THE WAY WE SEE SIERRA
FERMENTATION.
AND AND A LOT OF IT HAVING TO DO
WITH.
NOT ALWAYS UNDERSTANDING OR
BEING ON THE SAME PAGE WITH
RESPECT TO THE WAY SERVICES
REALLY NEED TO GET THE LIVER AND
AND I THINK WE NEED TO ALL KIND
OF WRAP THAT UP AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE BEING AS RESPONSIVE
AS POSSIBLE.
GETTING MENTAL HEALTH.
SERVICES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
SUPPORTED AND FUNCTIONING AND
THEN MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE
THE ABILITY TO SERVE KIND OF
ACROSS CALIFORNIA INCLUDING IN
RURAL COUNTIES WHERE.
IT'S BEEN MORE DIFFICULT TO
SERVE.
BUT THEY DON'T ALWAYS HAVE THAT
THE INFRASTRUCTURE ALWAYS HAD
THE ABILITY. TO TO MEET THOSE
NEEDS AND SO WITH THAT BUT WE'VE
GOT TO GET THE SYSTEM
FUNCTIONING AND FUNCTIONING
SMOOTHLY EVEN IN PLACES WHERE WE
KNOW IT CAN WORK.
AND THAT'LL HELP US GET OUT TO
THE MORE RURAL AREAS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE THE ABILITY.
TO TO ADDRESS ALL THESE KIDS SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK I'VE I
JUST WANT TO KEEP.
THE PADDLE DOWN.
KEEP WORKING MAKE SURE WE ARE
ENGAGE WITH THINGS THAT THAT
THAT NEED TO BE HAPPENING BUT I
ALSO MAKE SURE THAT THAT WE ARE
NOT [inaudible]
BLOCKING. TO JUST TRY TO CONTROL
UTILIZATION THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
BE CREATIVE.
THAT WE'RE ABLE TO GET THE
SERVICES WHERE THEY'RE NEEDED
ADDRESS THE KIDS ISSUES AS THEY
AS THEY COME UP BECAUSE THERE'S
NOT THAT MANY KIDS ULTIMATELY
STATEWIDE IF WE CAN'T SERVE
THESE KIDS WE REALLY CAN'T SERVE
ANY KIDS.
THIS IS THIS IS THIS IS THE
POPULATION WE HAVE TO BE MOST
RESPONSIVE TO AND I THINK THAT
THAT HELPS US.
SERVE ALL KIDS AND WE HAVE TO BE
A LITTLE BIT MORE CREATIVE MAY
BE AND HOW WE PULL ALL THAT
TOGETHER SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU DOCTOR STONE DR CHOI.
YEAH I KNOW TODAY YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT THE MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES BUT THE I HAVE A MORE
LITTLE BIT --
GENERAL QUESTION AS SECURITY IS --
TO ONE OF MY DISTRICT ARE STAFF
MEMBERS SO THEY CARE ABOUT TWO
BORIAS SO FORM NUMBER BEER SO
THIRTY FOUR YEAR OR SO.
SO --
INDUSTRY IS TALKING ABOUT THE
ADOPTING THE CHILDREN SO.
IN CALIFORNIA I WONDER WHAT THE
ORDER NUMBER OF CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE HOMES.
AND THE IF YOU HAPPEN TO HAVE A
NUMBER FOR ORANGE COUNTY.
AND THIRD QUESTION IS --
IF THE CURRENT FOSTER PARENT OR
A TOP SPEED OF CHILDREN.
THEN DO THEY GIVE UP OR WHATEVER --
THE GOVERNMENT'S RENDON YOUTH
AND FOSTER CARE IN THE IN THIS
IN THE STATE --
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND CHILDREN ARE --
TOUCHED BY OUR SYSTEM THROUGHOUT
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR NOT ALL IN
FOSTER CARE --
BUT IN OTHER OTHER SETTINGS AS
WELL WAS ROUTE WITH REGARD TO
THE ORANGE COUNTY NUMBER I DON'T
HAVE THAT WITH ME NOW BUT BY.
THE END OF THE HEARING I CAN
HAVE IT -- I
CAN PULL IT UP ON MY PHONE
ACTUALLY --
AND WITH RICK OF WITH RESPECT TO
THE THE SUPPORT --
THAT ADOPTIVE FAMILIES GET --
COUPLE THINGS NOTES SO.
TYPICALLY ON ON ALMOST ALWAYS --
WHEN A FAMILY ADOPTS THEY ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE ADOPTION
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM THE ADOPTIONS
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES
FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO THE FAMILY --
AT AT ROUGHLY THE SAME RATE AS
THE FOSTER CARE PAYMENT YOUNG
PEOPLE CONTINUE TO OR THAT THAT
CHILDREN TO CONTINUE TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICARE ALLAH
CETERA SO.
THE OVER THE YEARS THAT VARIOUS
LEGISLATURES HAVE DONE THEIR
BEST TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS
THAT THAT THERE AREN'T FISCAL
INNOCENCE OR DISINCENTIVES FOR
FAMILIES TO TO ADOPT SO ROUGHLY
THE LEVEL OF SUPPORT IS IS IS
THE SAME.
OKAY THEN FINANCIALLY --
THAT'S ABOUT THE SAME ABOUT THE
WHAT ARE THE DIFFERENCES --
OF THE FOSTER PARENTS.
OR BECOMING ADOPTIVE PARENTS.
SO THERE REALLY ISN'T ANY
FINANCIAL DIFFERENCE THEY WOULD
GET END UP WITH THE SAME LEVEL
OF FINANCIAL SUPPORT AS IF THEY
WERE AS THEY WERE RECEIVING --
WHEN THE CHILD WAS A FOSTER
CHILD AT AFTER ADOPTIONS THROUGH
THE ADOPTIONS ASSISTANCE PROGRAM?
THEIR MEDI CAL WOULD STAY INTACT
AS WELL SO THAT HAVE.
THAT THE DIFFERENCE IT
POTENTIALLY IS THERE --
THAT NO LONGER GETTING DIRECT
SERVICES FROM EITHER THE THAT
FROM THE COUNTY IN TERMS OF A
CASE MANAGEMENT SERVICES BECAUSE
ONCE THE ADOPTION AND IT IN IS
DETERMINED TO BE KIND OF A
PERMANENCY AND AN EXIT FROM OUR
SYSTEM.
SO THERE'S NO LONGER COURT
INVOLVEMENT AND NO LONGER --
COUNTY --
SOCIAL WORK VISITS --
AND AT BUT AS THE AS THE BOTH
THE THE CASE WORKER AND THE
ADOPTIONS WORKER CONTINUE TO TO
LINK.
FAMILIES TO THE SUPPORTS THEY
WILL NEED IN THE IN THE IN THE
COMMUNITY SO THAT BY THE TIME
THAT THERE'S NO LONGER --
SYSTEM INVOLVEMENT IF I CAN USE
THAT TERM THE FAMILY HAS AND
KNOWS WHERE THEY CAN GET OTHER
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTS HAS THE THE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES --
THEY NEED AND EVERY TWO YEARS
THEY CAN CON --
AND RENEGOTIATE THE ADOPTIONS
ASSISTANCE PAYMENT RATES OF
SOMETHING SIGNIFICANTLY CHANGES
YOUR DOCTOR YOUNG CHILD --
AND THEN SOMETHING IN LATENCY OR
TEENAGERS HAPPENS THAT THAT IS
SIGNIFICANT --
THEN THERE IS THE ABILITY FOR
ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL RESOURCES
TO BE PROVIDED TO THAT FAMILY SO
THAT THEY CAN PURCHASE SERVICES
OR OTHER SUPPORT FOR THAT YOUNG
KID.
AS THEY GROW INTO ADULTHOOD JUST
SO THAT WE KEEP IT ON TRACK WITH
TODAY'S HEARING DOCTOR CHOI --
THE A TO GO ALONG WITH THAT
QUESTION WHAT ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH BENEFITS TO THOSE
CHILDREN THAT ARE ADOPTED.
OKAY AT THE SCHOOL QUESTION.
AS I AS I MET A TOSSED TO THE
SIDE OF THE TABLE THERE ARE
EAGERLY AWAITING THAT BUT I
WOULD JUST SAY BECAUSE OF THE
THE THE MEDI CAL CONTINUATION
AND BENEFIT SHOULD TRICK ARE THE
SAME I DON'T KNOW IF YOU WANT TO
ADD.
I DO WANT TO ADD BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S REALLY CRITICAL
PARTICULARLY FOR THEM MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES --
THERE IS A TENDENCY FOR ADOPTIVE
PARENTS TO BELIEVE THAT THEIR
HEALTH PLAN.
THEIR PRIVATE HEALTH PLAN WILL
PROVIDE --
THAN MEDI CAL AND I THINK MEDI
CAL GETS A BAD RAP AT TIMES BUT
I'LL TELL YOU IN THE MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM.
I AS A BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTOR IN BACK IN THE DAY WHEN
I STERN DIRECT SERVICE PROVIDED
WAY MORE.
MORE FREQUENT MORE SERVICES AND
BETTER SERVICES THAT I COULD
HAVE EVER GOTTEN FROM MY OWN
CHILDREN SO THEY ARE CONTINUE TO
BE ELIGIBLE AND WE ALWAYS
ENCOURAGE ON THE MENTAL HEALTH
SIDE BACK IN THE COUNTY. FOR THE
PARENTS TO KEEP UP THE MEDI CAL
STAY INVOLVED WITH THAT EVEN IF
THEY ALSO --
ENGAGE THEIR HEALTH PLAN.
THANK YOU SOUNDS LIKE A GOOD
COMMERCIAL FOR MEDI CAL RIGHT
THERE.
JUST.
COULD I ADD ONE THING TO THAT --
ONE THING.
WE HAVE RECENTLY PUBLISHED A
SERIES OF GUIDES FOR DIFFERENT
TYPES OF OF MEDICAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS TO UNDERSTAND
THE NUANCES THAT --
ADOPTED CHILDREN --
EXPERIENCE AND SO I'D BE HAPPY
TO MAKE THAT THAT INFORMATION
AVAILABLE TO THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU HEIGHT THAT APPRECIATE
THAT -- MS
FRIEDMAN AND THEN MR COOLEY.
THANK YOU FIRST I WANT TO THANK
YOU OFFER I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE WORK THAT YOU DO WHICH
IS.
SO INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND ALSO
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT AT TIMES
HEARTBREAKING SO THANK YOU ALL
FOR BEING THE ADVOCATES THAT YOU
ARE -- I
JUST WANTED TO YOU KNOW I AM NOT
AN EXPERT IN THIS FIELD BY ANY
STRETCH OF THE IMAGINATION YOU
ALL ARE.
SO PLEASE TAKE THIS WITH A HUGE
GRAIN OF SALT --
BUT I DID WANT TO SHARE A LITTLE
BIT OF MY OWN PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE JUST TO GIVE YOU MAY
BE SOME INSIGHT ABOUT.
THE FALLING INTEREST OF PEOPLE
TO BECOME FOSTER PARENTS --
I SPENT TWO YEARS BECOMING A
FOSTER PARENT.
THROUGH LA COUNTY --
IN OUR QUEST TO ADOPT A CHILD.
AND IT WAS ONE OF THE MOST
FRUSTRATING AND DIFFICULT
EXPERIENCE THAT I'VE EVER HAD
WITH ANY GOVERNMENT AGENCY --
EVERY TIME WE HAD SOMEONE COME
TO OUR INSPECTOR HOME WHICH WAS
A MULTITUDE OF TIMES THEY
CONSTANTLY WILL COME UP WITH
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT IN SEEMING
VERY ARBITRARY --
REQUIREMENTS FOR US --
EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE REQUIREMENTS
YOU KNOW THAT WOULD HAVE COST US
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS OF
IMPROVEMENTS TO OUR HOME --
I WAS TOLD AFTER GOING THROUGH
THAT I ASKED TOO MANY QUESTIONS
AND CLEARLY I WAS NOT THE KIND
OF PERSON THAT THEY WANTED IN
THEIR SYSTEM.
AND OF YOU KNOW I'M NOT GOING TO
DEBATE ABOUT WHETHER ADOPTION IS
GOOD OR BAD BUT IT WAS BEEN MADE
VERY CLEAR TO ME AT THE TIME I
AND I THINK SUBSEQUENTLY
REINFORCED OVER AND OVER TO ME.
THAT THIS IS A SYSTEM THAT DOES
NOT VALUE ADOPTION.
THAT THAT'S NOT THAT'S THE LAST
RESORT AS FAR AS THEY'RE
CONCERNED AND THAT MESSAGE IS
GIVEN TO A POTENTIALLY ADOPTIVE
PARENTS.
AND YOU KNOW BEING TOLD THAT
YOU'RE SORT OF THE IF EVERYTHING
ELSE FAILS MAYBE WILL CONSIDER
YOU BUT YOU'RE GONNA TAKE CARE
OF THIS CHILD AND WE EXPECT YOU
TO LOVE THIS TRIAL BUT WE ALSO
EXPECT YOU.
TO FAVOR UNIV NOT JUST RE
INVOCATION REPLACEMENT WITH THIS
FAMILY MEMBERS --
I'M NOT GONNA ARGUE WHETHER
THAT'S GOOD FOR THE CHILD OR NOT
BUT I DEFINITELY BELIEVE IT ENDS
UP WITH A LOT OF PARENTS NOT.
NOT WANTING TO GO INTO THE
SYSTEM WHO WERE POTENTIALLY GOOD
PARENTS.
A LOT OF CHILDREN BEING
SEPARATED FROM PARENTS AFTER.
ONE TO THREE YEARS.
I'VE SEEN IT MYSELF OVER AND
OVER AGAIN I'M BACK INTO THE
SYSTEM.
AND AGAIN I AM NOT GONNA I THIS
IS NOT THE PLACE TO HAVE AN
ARGUMENT ABOUT WHETHER THAT'S
APPROPRIATE ARE GOOD FOR THOSE
CHILDREN OR ANY OF THOSE ISSUES
AND I UNDERSTAND THEIR
COMPLICATED AND NUANCED.
THERE'S LOTS OF PERSPECTIVES BUT
FROM A SOMEONE WHO SPENT YEARS
YOU KNOW IN THE SYSTEM AND THEN
YEARS AGAIN ADOPTING MY CHILD --
I I I I I I HAVE DEALT WHY HAVE
COME IN CONTACT WITH SO MANY
PARENTS WHO HAD THEIR HEART
BROKEN -- IN
THE YOU KNOW ON THERE AND FROM
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM SO IT'S
TRAUMATIZED CHILDREN AND A LOTTA
TRAUMATIZED ADULTS OUT THERE AND
I. IF YOUR RATES OF PEOPLE
WANTING TO DO THIS ARE FALLING.
AFTER DOING TRYING TO DO IT
MYSELF I AM ABSOLUTELY NOT
SURPRISE I'M SURPRISED ANYONE
DOES IT AT ALL SO THAT'S JUST.
MY PERCENT MY MY PERSPECTIVE
AGAIN THANKS FOR THE WORK THAT
YOU DO.
THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY WHO IS
ALSO THE CHAIR OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE OFFER FOSTER YOUTH.
WELL ON THAT I WOULD JUST SAY
AMEN TO MS FRIEDMAN --
YOU KNOW STORIES ON THIS POINT
OF HOW TRAUMATIC FOR PROSPECTIVE
ADOPTIVE PARENTS --
ACTION --
COUPLE RIGHT NOW WHO SORT OF
WE'RE LOOKING TO ADOPT AND AND
IF HAVE SORT OF GOT.
THE WOBBLE OF THEY'RE LOOKING TO
ADOPT AND YET.
SEEMINGLY OUT OF THE BLUE THE AT
THE OPTION DISAPPEARS.
A PAINFUL AND I AND I GET IT I
HEAR FROM PEOPLE IN THAT.
THE MOST STRIKING ONE FOR ME
ACTUALLY IS --
COUPLE I KNEW.
WHO ARE CARING FOR CHILD LOOKING
TO ADOPT [inaudible]
OF WENT TO WITH THEIR WHOLE
FAMILY TO DISNEYLAND.
AND WERE TRAVELING DOWN FOR I
BELIEVE IT WAS THE THANKSGIVING
WEEKEND ONE YEAR.
AND GOTTA CALL AT ABOUT TWO
THIRTY IN THE AFTERNOON WATER
SOUTHBOUND ON I..
FIVE FROM SOMEBODY INFORMING
THEM THAT THEY NEED TO HAVE THIS
CHILD BACK IN A SECOND COURT
ROOM ON TUESDAY.
BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING ELSEWHERE.
AND TO ALL APPEARANCES IT WAS
SOMEBODY THAT WAS SORT OF CARING
THEIR QUEUE ON A WEDNESDAY
AFTERNOON BEFORE THANKSGIVING.
HAD NO IDEA THEY WERE TALKING TO
PEOPLE ACTUALLY BEEN CARE FOR
THIS CHILD FIRST EMPEROR LOOKING
TO ADOPT.
AND WHAT MADE THE STORY STAND
OUT OF MY MIND BECAUSE HE SPENT
THREE DAYS IN THE HAPPIEST PLACE
ON EARTH.
AND THAT CHILD WHO WAS WITH HIM
DIDN'T APPEAR IN ANY OF THE
PICTURES.
IF I COULD JUST WAS SO TRAUMATIC
FOR THEM.
THEY THEY STARTED EDITING RIGHT
AWAY -- BUT
THAT'S ACTUALLY NOT.
THE POINT I DEFINITELY THINK.
WE DO NEED PEOPLE.
WHO ARE?
ON BEHALF OF KIDS WHO WERE IN
THESE.
DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCE YOU DO
NEED PEOPLE OF GOOD CARING
HEARTS --
FOR ALL THE CRAP THAT COMES DOWN.
EIGHTY A FOSTER PARENT A GOOD
FOSTER PARENT IS SOMEBODY WHO'S
BASICALLY SAYING.
THEY'RE WILLING TO TRY TO HELP A
CHILD GROW WHOLE.
IN LOVE'S OVERFLOW.
BRING THAT CHILD IN THE HOUSE
AND SO.
THEY HAVE PEOPLE WHO WERE
WILLING TO BE THAT PERSON.
WHO TAKE THEMSELVES OUT OF THE
SYSTEM IS ACTUALLY A GREAT
DISCREDIT TO LOTS OF KIDS --
SO I APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUE --
PROVIDE HER FIRST PERSON ACCOUNT
BUT I CERTAINLY.
HEAR HEAR THOSE STORIES SOME
PEOPLE MYSELF.
ARE I ACTUALLY JUST WANTED TO
SAY.
I'M SO GRATEFUL FOR CALIFORNIA --
BEING HERE.
I THINK IN THIS WHOLE SYSTEM THE
THE ONE QUESTION I WOULD ASK IS.
TO WHAT EXTENT HAVE WE IN A
SYSTEMATIC WAY.
OR CAN WE IN A SYSTEMATIC WAY.
IN SOME OF THESE RURAL COUNTIES.
FIND A WAY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
TWO STRUPPER CONVERSATION ABOUT
WHAT TO THE LOCAL INS LOOKS LIKE
THE THINGS THAT.
IF YOU'RE IN MODOC COUNTY OR
TAME A COUNTY OR DEL NORTE
COUNTY.
WHAT TO THE LOCALS WHO HAVE A
CONCERN IN THIS AREA WHO BE SORT
OF THE PEOPLE WHO WANT?
TO HELP KIDS GROW UP HOLDEN
LOVES OVER FOR THE TYPE OF
PERSON.
WHAT DID THEY SEE IS THE THING
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL THAT THEY
COULD DO MOST DIRECTLY? TO HELP
SOLVE THE IMPLEMENTATION SOME
THESE PROGRAMS.
I THINK --
MY COLLEAGUE MISTER STONE HAS
BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN
[inaudible]
KIND OF FRAME THIS CONVERSATION
WERE SPENDING YEARS WORKING TO
IMPLEMENT IT.
BRING IT DOWN THE COUNTY LEVEL.
AND IT'S GREAT FOR US IN
SACRAMENTO KINDA CONCEIVE OF
THESE THINGS AND AND TRY TO ROLL
THEM OUT.
BUT I AM REMINDED THAT THE END
OF THE DAY WE NEED TO RELEASE
ENERGY.
IN ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES ON
THESE PROBLEMS.
AND THAT MEANS YOU HAVE.
TO BE SUCCESSFUL AND KIND OF
UNDERSTAND WHERE THAT ENERGY IS.
AND I I'LL GIVE A SHOUT OUT --
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO I WORKED
ON A BILL AUTHORED BY LOU PAP
BUT WHICH WAS THE FIRST BILL
DEAL WITH CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION.
WHICH CONCEIVE OF PUTTING.
A LARGE SUM OF MONEY AND ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES TO SUPPORT
OF LOCAL CONVERSATION.
ON WHAT MIGHT MAKE SENSE AT THAT
LOCAL LEVEL TO DO A CHILD ABUSE
PREVENTION.
SO IS NOT A CASE OF SURPLUS AND
THIS IS HOW YOU'LL DO IT.
IT WAS A CASE OF SACRAMENTO
PUTTING RESOURCES INTO SUPPORT A
CONVERSATION ABOUT WE THINK THIS
IS AN ISSUE.
WHAT MAKES SENSE TO LOCALLY ON
HOW TO TACKLE THAT?
IT'S SORT OF WITHIN AS WE AS WE
WORK ON THIS SYSTEM OF REFORMS.
AND TRYING TO SUPPORT.
THE TRANSFER ACROSS COUNTY
BOUNDARIES WHERE THAT'S GOING TO
HELP A CHILD.
HOW DO WE GET ACROSS AT COUNTY
LINE AND HAVE THE MOST
HOSPITABLE IMPLEMENTATION?
AND I DO APPRECIATE CAM YOUR
EMPHASIS UPON THE FINANCIAL SIDE.
WHICH IS OURS TO KIND OF OWN AND
THINK ABOUT IN COURT DATE WITH
OUR PARTNERS AT THE COUNTY.
BOARD OF SOUPS AND OTHER LOCAL
AGENCIES.
BUT IT JUST SEEMS TO ME THAT.
WE NEED TO TAP INTO WHAT'S GOING
ON AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
HOW THEY UNDERSTAND IT FIND
THOSE FOLKS WHOSE HEART IS IN IT?
AND TRY TO WORK WITH AND
UNDERSTAND.
WHEN THEY HEAR THE IDEA WHAT OF
THE OPTIONS ARE PRESENT
THEMSELVES?
ARM.
IN A WHAT WOULD WORK THE LOCAL
OF AND FOR HOW WE CAN --
TWELVE THAT SO ANY COMMENTS
COMMENTS PEOPLE HAVE ABOUT THE
EXTENT WE'VE DONE.
THESE LOCAL CONVERSATIONS.
WOULD BE HELPFUL.
OTHERWISE YOU JUST MORE
OBSERVATION I THINK.
YOU KNOW WE'VE DONE A LOT.
BUT AS EXPRESSIONS WHEN YOU'RE
90% DONE YOU'RE HALFWAY THERE.
AND I THINK THAT'S KIND OF WHAT
I HEAR MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE
MONTEREY BAY SAY.
WE WE REALLY NEED THEIR LAND THE
AIRPLANE.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY THANK
YOU FOR THOSE COMMENTS.
I DO WANT TO THANK ALL THE
PANELISTS FOR YOUR COMMENTS FOR
YOUR ANSWERS AND I WOULD LIKE TO
CALL THE NEXT PANELING ALSO VIEW
WILL BE RETURNING. TO GIVE US
SOME IDEAS ON HOW WE SOLVE THIS.
SO THE NEXT PANEL AS ARE COMING
UP.
ON PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER WE HAVE
CAROL SCHROEDER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR EMERITUS.
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES.
SIMONA CATALDO BUT DOCTOR SIMONA
CATALDO.
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER VICTOR
TREATMENT CENTERS CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER VICTOR
COMMUNITY SUPPORT SERVICES
[inaudible]
KATHY SANDERLING.
DEPUTY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA.
DIANA WAGNER BRANCH DIRECTOR OF
SHASTA COUNTY HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCIES.
I WOULD REQUEST THAT WE LIMIT
OUR COMMENTS TO FIVE TO SEVEN
MINUTES
AND LET'S BEGIN WITH THE CAROL
SCHROEDER.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
I'M CAROL SCHROEDER I AM WITH
THE EGGS CALIFORNIA LIES CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES WE REPRESENT --
HUNDRED THIRTY CREDIT PRIVATE
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDING CARE
SUPPORT AND SERVICES TO OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND CHILDREN
FAMILIES ANNUALLY --
AMONG THE SERVICES PROVIDED AT
MENTAL HEALTH AND FOSTER CARE --
I WANTED TO START TO IT JUST FOR
A MINUTE AND AND AND TAKE A
SECOND -- TO
TO DEFINE PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER
IN THE CONTEXT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT.
AND REALLY WHAT PRESUMPTIVE
TRANSFER AS THAT FOR ANY CHILD
HIS PLACED OUTSIDE THEIR COUNTY
REGIONAL JURISDICTION THAT IS.
THEY'RE PLACED IN A COUNTY OTHER
THAN COUNTY WHERE THERE IS THE
THERE THE THEIR DEPENDENTS ARE
RATHER WORK TO THE COURT --
WHEN THAT OCCURS STAND THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY FOR PROVIDING SIT
SPECIALLY MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
MOVES IS PRESUMPTIVELY
TRANSFERRED IN HAVE TO APPLY?
YOU DON'T HAVE TO ASK YOU NOT
THAT YOU KNOW IT PRESUMPTIVELY
TRANSFERS FROM THE COUNTY OF
ORIGINAL JET FROM MENTAL HEALTH
PLAN THE COUNTY ORIGINAL
JURISDICTION. TO THE MENTAL
HEALTH PLAN OF THE COUNTY WHICH
THE CHILD'S LIVING THAT'S THE
DEAL --
THERE ARE IT WILL END AB TWELVE
ANY ANSWER YES WILL BE IN AB --
TWELVE NINETY NINE WITH WHICH WE
ARE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR WITH
THAT STEINBERG INSTITUTED THE
WOMEN'S POLICY INSTITUTE.
WE ALSO MADE PROVISION FOR
WAIVERS WHEN CERTAIN EXCEPTIONS
OCCUR.
AND THOSE EXCEPTIONS REALLY
RELATE TO THE BEST INTEREST OF
THE CHILD CONTINUITY OF CARE AND
SO ON WHEN THOSE THINGS OCCURRED
THEN -- AND
THEN A WAIVER OF PRESUMPTIVE
TRANSFER CAN BE REQUESTED BY THE
COUNTY SOCIAL WORKER --
AND THAT CAN BE --
IN THAT CAN BE APPROVED BY THE
THE JUVENILE COURT --
I THINK IT AND LISTENING --
TO TO MINSITER INCEST MONNING
SOME OF THE OTHER THINGS YOU
HEARD FROM THE OTHER STATE FOLKS
REALIZE HOW COMPLICATED SYSTEM
COULD BE AND HOW QUICKLY GETS
COMPLICATED --
THEY THE QUESTION THAT YOU ASK
IS IS SORT OF THE TITLE FOR THE
HEARING A HEALTH PRESUMPTIVE
TRANSFER IMPACTED THE PROVISION
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES TO FOSTER
YES.
I THINK WE CAN ANSWER NOT AS
MUCH AS WE HAD HOPED --
BUT HOPEFULLY WE'RE GETTING
THERE AND I THINK THAT --
MISTER COOLIES POINT ABOUT THE
AND THAT YOU KNOW 90% DONE HALF
WAY THERE'S A GOOD --
ONE THE STORY OF AB TWELVE
NINETY NINE IS IT WHICH CREATED
PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER IS REALLY A
STORY ABOUT HOW LIKE HOW
CALIFORNIA STRUGGLED.
AT LEAST SINCE --
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE TO ENSURE
THAT CHILDREN PLACED IN FOSTER
CARE OUTSIDE THEIR COUNTIES WERE
JURISDICTION HAVE ACCESS TO THE
MENTAL HEALTH AND MEDICAL FUNDED
SPECIALLY MENTAL SERVICES.
THAT THEY BOTH NEED TO WHICH
THEY'RE ENTITLED --
UNDER FEDERAL LAW --
THE ISSUE THAT WE REALIZED AT
SOME POINT DURING ALL THIS AND
I'LL GET TO THAT.
IS THAT IS MEDI CAL SPECIALLY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA --
OR PROVIDED USING A SYSTEM OF
COUNTY BASED MANAGED CARE PLANS
WHICH WE CALL MENTAL HEALTH
PLANS --
UNDER CONTRACT DEPARTMENT HEALTH
CARE SERVICES AND UNTIL A. B. --
TWELVE NINETY NINE THE WAY THAT
THAT WORKS WAS THAT REGARDLESS
OF WHERE A CHILD IN FOSTER CARE
WAS PLACED.
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THOSE
SERVICES REMAIN TO JURISDICTION.
SO CHILD AND ALAMEDA COUNTY --
IS PLACE WITH HER GRANDMOTHER IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY BUT THE BROUGH
THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES REMAINS IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY WITH ALL THE
ATTENDANT PROBLEMS YOU COULD SEE
CONCEIVABLY COULD ACCRUE TO THAT
THAT KIND OF SITUATION --
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN AND THEN
CENTER STEINBERG --
COASTAL AND END OF AB ATWATER
BUILD THE SB SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE
WHICH IS CO SPONSORED BY US.
THEY'LL HELP NOW THE OLD MENTAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION L.
BEHAVIOR ALL DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND CWD A WHICH
CODIFIED A SERIES OF
RECOMMENDATIONS --
THEY CAME OUT OF A WORK GROUP
THAT HAD BEEN --
BROUGHT TOGETHER BY THE SELLER
BACK --
FAMILY FOUNDATION --
AND IN THE THAT CODIFICATION
SAID IT WAS THE FIRST ATTEMPT AT
DEALING WITH THIS ISSUE A
STATUTORILY.
AND SO WHAT IS AB BASICALLY
OFFER TO SOLUTIONS AT OR TWO
PARTS OF ONE SOLUTION THE FIRST
PART WAS IT SAID. FOR ANY CHILD
WHO HAS BEEN ADOPTED OUT OF THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM OR IS LIVING
A CAN GUARDIANSHIP SITUATION
WHERE THEY'RE THEY'RE LIVING
WITH FAMILY MEMBERS --
IT A WHO ARE THERE GUARDIANS AND
IF THAT'S OUTSIDE OF THE COUNTY
OF ORIGINAL JURISDICTION THAN
THOSE YOU KNOW THOSE THOSE YOUNG
PEOPLE THEIR MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
WILL BE TAKEN CARE OF BY THE
MENTAL HEALTH PLAN OF THE COUNTY
WHERE THAT BUT FOR EVERYBODY
ELSE WE'RE GONNA KEEP IT.
THE WAY IT AS BUT WHAT SEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE DAY WAS A CREATED --
BASICALLY SOME IT IS SOME GREASE
TO LUBRICATE THE THE THE GEARS
IN THE WHEELS TO KIND OF MAKE
ALL THAT STUFF HAPPENED THAT
THAT KIM WAS TALKING ABOUT --
EXPERIENCES BENT THAT WHILE IT
DID LUBRICATED SOMEWHAT THERE
CONTINUE TO BE A PROBLEM AND IN
FACT IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN THE
CALIFORNIA WELFARE COUNCIL
PUBLISHED REPORT.
COMPILED BY ITS OUT OF COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES WORKER OF
CHINA CHILDREN PLACED IN FOSTER
CARE OUTSIDE THEIR COUNTIES ROOT
ROOT OF ORIGINAL JURISDICTION.
WERE MORE LIKELY TO BE DIAGNOSED
WITH A SERIOUS MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDER IN THOSE PLACED IN
COUNTY.
BUT WERE 10215% MORE LIGHT LESS
LIKELY TO GET ANY SERVICE AT ALL.
AND OF THOSE THAT DID RECEIVE
SERVICES THAT YOU CAN GET TO A
PLACE THAT A COUNTY A RECEIVE
FEWER SERVICES ELECTED LESS
INTENSE OF SERVICES.
THAN THOSE WHO ARE PLACED IN
COUNTY.
WE THEN --
COSPONSORED AS I SAID ALONG WITH --
THE STEINBERG INSTEAD WOMEN'S --
POLICY --
INSTITUTE --
A. B. --
TWELVE NINE NINE THAT MR RIDLEY
THOMAS CARRIED ACTED --
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICE CONVENE A SERIES OF
MEETINGS A STAKEHOLDERS TO WORK
OUT THE PARTICULARS HELPERS UP
DID PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER IS
GOING TO WORK.
WE CONTINUE TO SEE PROBLEMS THAT
THAT EXIST IN THIS BY AND THE
THE STATE REALLY BOIL DOWN TO
TWO THINGS ONE AS YOU WOULD
EXPECT --
WITH FIFTY I'D COUNTIES --
IT IN THEIR OWN INDIVIDUAL
MENTAL HEALTH PLANS IS
INCONSISTENT IMPLEMENTATION
BETWEEN THE COUNTIES.
AND ONLY TAKE AN OPPORTUNITY --
TO THANK DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES IN BEAVER HAVERHILL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION FOR
THEIR ASSISTANCE IN ADDRESSING
ON A ON A COUNTY BY COUNTY CHILD
BY CHILD PROVIDED BY PROVIDER
BASIS THOSE GLITCHES THAT COME
UP -- SO I
DON'T WANT TO LEAVE HERE WITH
YOU THINK YOU KNOW MY IDEA AND
NOTHING'S HAPPENING AT FOLKS ARE
WORKING ON THIS.
BUT THE BIGGER ISSUE THAT WE
HAVE SEEN --
IS THAT THAT REALLY HAS IMPACTED
THIS IS THE ISSUE THAT RELATES
TO COUNTIES WHERE THERE ARE HIGH
CONCENTRATIONS SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC PROGRAMS.
AT WHICH ARE STATUTORILY
REQUIRED TO HAVE A CONTRACT TO
PROVIDE SPECIALLY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR THESE YEARS.
AND WHEN YOU HAVE CERTAIN
COUNTIES THAT ARE HIGHLY
IMPACTED BY THE PRESENCE OF
THESE THEN THEY ARE FACED WITH
AND AN OVERWHELMING AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT THEY THEN HAVE TO PUT
UP FRONT.
IN ORDER TO PROVIDE THE SERVICES
THAT THEIR STATUTORY THE
STATUTORILY REQUIRED TO AT TO
MAKE SURE HAPPENS.
SO -- WE'RE
TO CRISIS POINT NOW FOR THAT I
THINK WE NEED TO ADDRESS THAT
IMMEDIATELY MY HOPE IN THIS
HEARING IS THAT IT'S GOING TO
PROVIDE FURTHER EVIDENCE FOR THE
SPEEDY RESOLUTION OF THESE
ISSUES.
BECAUSE I RECKON THE TWENTY FOUR
YEARS ABOUT LONG ENOUGH TO GET
THIS PROBLEM SOLVED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
SCHROEDER OF SIMONA COULD TELL
THE DOCTOR COULD TELL THEM.
GOOD AFTERNOON --
MY NAME IS THE ONE I COULD TELL
THOUGH I AM.
C. L. FOUR VICTOR THREE NINE
CENTERS AND THE SEE ALL FOUR
VICTOR COMMUNITY SUPPORT
SERVICES AND JUST TO CLARIFY
THAT THE JURY IS OUT MULTI
COUNTY ORGANIZATION COMPRISED OF
TWO AGENCIES UNDER ONE
ADMINISTRATIVE UMBRELLA AND
STILL.
TOTAL WITH.
THAT --
TODAY I'M HERE TO OFFER
TESTIMONY FROM A PROVIDER
STANDPOINT --
VESTI OUR TV SERVICES AND THE
INTERACTION BETWEEN THAT AND
PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER AND WHILE
WE'VE.
EXPERIENCED AS THE SENSATION AS
OF COURAGE.
SO PRIOR --
TO A. B. TWELVE NINETEEN NINE A
WE HAD -- TO
THIRTEEN EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT
CONTRACTS WITH IN OUR GROUP
HOMES -- WE
HAVE THREE LOCATIONS --
WHINING RIDING WHINING SANTA
ROSA AND ONE ENOUGH PASADENA
WE'VE THE EXCEPTION OF THE
LOCATION IN PASADENA WHICH ONLY
SERVES --
KIDS ALL THE LA COUNTY THE OTHER
TWO LOCATIONS TO SERVE KIDS OF
FROM ANY COMPANY --
PRIOR TO A. B. TWELVE NINETY
NINE ANY COUNTY WE HAD A
CONTRACT WITH.
WELL WE'VE SEEN WITH TWELVE
NINETY NINE NEEDS A COUPLE OF
THINGS --
FIRST OF ALL THE MAJORITY OF
COUNTIES HAVE CHOSEN TO MAINTAIN
A CONTRACT WITH US --
ONLY A HANDFUL LAWS COMPANIES
HAVE THAT --
NOT RENEW WITH THAT THEIR
CONTRACTS --
DUE TO THE FACT THAT THAT --
THEY HAVE CHOSEN TO USE
PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER WHENEVER
THEY ARE IN NEED OF PLACING A
TIED THE KNOT S. C. R. T. P.
PROGRAM.
THERE IS ALSO AVAILABILITY
BETWEEN THE TWO SITES WHERE ONE
SITE A WE SEE THE MAJORITY OF
KIDS BEING --
PRESUMPTIVELY TRANCE THIRD
WHEREAS THE OTHER SIDE HE'S
EXPERIENCING ONLY A HANDFUL OF
KIDS ARE BEING PRESUMPTIVELY
TRANSFERRED WITH THE COUNTIES
THAT NORMALLY EVERY FURTHER INTO
THAT HE'S PROMPTING --
THAT CHOICE THAT MY ASSUMPTION
IS THAT --
SOME OF THOSE COUNTIES THAT
CHOOSE TO WAIVE OUR LARGER
COUNTIES.
WHICH PROBABLY HAVE --
MORE SERVICES TO PROVIDE --
ONCE A THE THE CHINESE RETURNED --
BACKING COUNTY.
SO -- WH
WHAT WE ARE SEEING WHAT WE WERE
HOPEFUL THAT WE'VE --
PRESUMPTIVE TRANSPORTING PLACE A
WEEK COULD ACTUALLY LIMIT THE
NUMBER OF INTERACTIONS WE'VE
COUNTIES BECAUSE AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE EACH CONTRACT COMES WITH
DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS DOCUMENTATION
REQUIREMENTS TO SO WE WERE
REALLY.
THINKING THAT A PRESUMPTIVE
TRANSFER WAS GOING TO STREAMLINE --
THESE PROCESSES WHILE WE'VE
EXPERIENCED ACTUALLY IS THE
OPPOSITE THAT --
WE ARE SEEING MORE COMPLICATION
MORE DOCUMENTATION AND THAT WE
ARE IN NOW --
NOT ALWAYS COMFORTABLE PLACE
SELF TRYING TO MEDIATE BETWEEN
PLACING COUNTY AND RECEIVING
COUNTY -- TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE PAPERWORK IS
IN PLACE SO THAT WE CAN --
RECEIVE THE CHILD AND STUFF OF
THE REQUIREMENTS OF A C. R. T.
P. AND ONE OF THE PURPOSES FOR
REST THE RTP.
IS OF COURSE THESE KIDS COME IN
WITH VERY HIGH INTENSITY NEEDS
AND A VERY SHORT STAY AND WE
WANT TO WE ARE COMMITTED TO
MAINTAINING THAT --
STAY AS SHORT AS POSSIBLE
BECAUSE WE REALLY TRULY BELIEVE
THAT KIDS NEED TO BE SERVED IN
THE COMMUNITY IN WHICH THEY ARE --
CONGREGATE THEY CARE IS GOOD FOR
SOME THINGS BUT IT'S NOT EXACTLY
THE NORMALIZED PLACEMENT
EXPERIENCE THAT YOU WANT TO TRY
TO HAVE.
SO WE SEE OURSELVES AS KIND OF
LIKE THE EQUIVALENT OF A NICE
YOU RIGHT YOU GO TO THE I SEE
YOU BECAUSE YOU ARE IN AN ACUTE
STATE.
THAT -- STAY
IN THE I SEE YOU ALLOWS YOU TO
NOT BE AS A CUE TO WHICH DOESN'T
MEAN YOUR FIXED BY YOU ARE WELL
ENOUGH TO BE THREE DEAD.
AT AT THE FACT THAT YOU KNOW AT
A DIFFERENT LEVEL OF HEALTH CARE.
STILL OUR HOPIS THE READ THAT
DAVIES STREAMLINING OFF THIS
PROCESS IS SO THAT --
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE WE ON A
POSITION ODDS AND MEETING THE
CHILD AS SOON AS WE GET READY
FOR ALL AND THAT WE CAN START
PROVIDING SERVICES AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
WAS THE RIGHT NOW WHILE WE ARE
SEEING IS --
ED ENOCH QUEST THE FOR PAPER
WORK WHERE ACTUALLY DELAYING
THAT --
INTAKE.
AND ALSO WE ARE SEEING DENIALS
THAT BEFORE WE DID AND YOU.
AS A COMMUNITY THAT WE NEED TO
COMMUNICATE WITH AND AND THEY
HAVE TO COMMUNICATE WITH EACH
OTHER SO DISEASE.
THIS IS COMPLICATING THAT --
THAT PROCESS A LITTLE BIT OF
FUNDING IS ALSO A NEED TO AS
MANY HAVE ATTESTED --
TO BECAUSE FOR EXAMPLE IN ONE OF
OUR SITES --
WHAT WE ARE EXPERIENCING IS THAT --
LAST MONTH ALONE TWENTY TWO OUT
OF THIRTY KIDS WHERE PRESUMPTIVE
TRANSFERS --
AS OPPOSED TO THE NORM ALL FOUR
TO FIVE TO SIX KIDS TOP OF THAT --
THAT THAT COUNTY WAS PREVIOUSLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR FROM PAYMENT
STANDPOINT AND WHAT THAT MEANS
IS THAT WHEN WE HAVE A CONTRACT
A CONTRACT ALSO ESTABLISHES THE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING THAT IS
AVAILABLE.
AND THEREFORE WHEN --
OF COURSE WITH THE INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF OF KIDS BEING PLACE
THAT ARE PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFERS --
WE ARE IN A POSITION OF NEEDING
TO REQUIRE ANY A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE SOMETIMES OF THE
FUNDING NECESSARY FOR US TO
CONTINUE.
TO OPERATE UNDER THAT CONTRACT.
THANK YOU FOR THE OUT OF HOME
KATHY SANDERLING PLACE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
KATHY SAID KNOWING WHAT THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION I WANT TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE ROLE THAT
SEE WTA PLAYED IN TWELVE NINETY
NINE AND GIVE SOME THOUGHTS ON
PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER.
AND TALK ABOUT A COUPLE THEMES
THAT WE'RE SEEING AND HEARING
ABOUT FROM COUNTIES I KNOW IT'S
SORT OF THE LAST RABBIT PANEL
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY PROVIDE SOME
SUGGESTIONS AS WELL SO I WANT.
TO TRY TO I'LL TRY NOT TO GET
TOO MUCH INTO THAT --
AT THE MOMENT.
SO AS FAR AS FOUR YEARS AGO --
AS NOTED IN THE MATERIALS IN THE
BACKGROUND PAPER IT WAS CLEAR WE
WERE ENGAGED FOR MANY YEARS AND
THIS LONG STANDING ISSUE IT WAS
FRUSTRATING. TO NOT BE ABLE TO
GET OUR YOUTH AND CHILDREN THAT
WE PLACE OUT OF COUNTY --
FOR THE REASONS THAT MISTER ROSE
NOTED IN HIS TESTIMONY --
THOSE SERVICES AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE AND FOR THERE TO BE
CONFUSION ABOUT WHO WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT AND NOT A
LOT OF CONSISTENCY THERE.
SO WE WORKED WITH THE OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS IN WITH THE TWO
SPONSORS TO HELP IN DRAFTING THE
FINAL BILL WHICH WE WERE ABLE TO
SUPPORT.
AND WE DID SUPPORT THE
PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER AS WELL.
WE SUPPORTED IT BECAUSE WE
REALLY NEEDED THAT CLARIFICATION
BUT WE ALSO FELT THAT IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO HAVE THAT ABILITY
TO WAIVE THAT IN CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES AND MR CHARTER
EXPLAINED A LITTLE BIT OF THIS
BUT SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE
WOULD LOOK AT OUR THE STABILITY
OF THE THERAPEUTIC.
RELATIONSHIP THAT THAT YOU THIS
ALREADY FORMED IF THEY'RE
RECEIVING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES IN THEIR EXISTING
COUNTY --
AND IF YOU COULD MAINTAIN THOSE
AND IT WAS ABOUT THE BAY AREA OR
IT MIGHT NOT BE THAT LONG ACROSS
COUNTY LINES [inaudible]
HAS OR OF OTHER SORT OF
NONTRADITIONAL SERVICES AS MS
HERNANDEZ NOTED ON THE FIRST
PANEL SUCH AS ART THERAPY ONCE
YOU'VE GOT A REALLY GREAT
RELATIONSHIP ESTABLISHED YOU
WANT TO THINK ABOUT WHETHER YOU
SHOULD --
POTENTIALLY SEVER THAT EVEN FOR
A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME WHILE THE
YOUTH IS IN THAT --
I S. T. R. T. P. OR PLACED WITH
A RELATIVE OUT OF COUNTY --
SO THE ABILITY ALSO FOR THE HOST
COUNTY -- OR
FOR THE PLACING COUNTY TO BE
ABLE TO DO A CONTRACT WITH THE
PROVIDER WHO'S IN THE COUNTY
THAT AT THE YOUTH IS LIVING IN
WAS ALSO A CONSIDERATION AS WELL
IF THEY ALREADY HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP AND THEY CAN JUST
EXPAND THAT CONTRACT.
THATMAKES A LOT OF SENSE IF
IT'S BRAND NEW THERE'S NO
CONTRACT THERE'S NO EXISTING
RELATIONSHIP.
PERHAPS BETTER THAN TO ALLOW
THAT PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER TO
OCCUR AND HAVE THAT CONTRACT IS
PICKED UP BY THE COUNTY --
OF PLACEMENT.
WE ALSO FELT IT WAS VERY
IMPORTANT FOR THE COUNTY SOCIAL
WORKER THE PLACING AGENCY TO BE
MAKING ALTERNATELY THAT
DETERMINATION WITH INPUT FROM
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS WITH INPUT
FROM THE CHILD AND FAMILY TEAM.
BUT ULTIMATELY WERE THE ONES
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE CARE CUSTODY
AND CONTROL OF THAT YOUTH AND WE
FELT IT WAS IMPORTANT TO SORT OF
VAST THAT DECISION ULTIMATELY
WITH THAT COUNTY SOCIAL WORKER.
ON AND FINALLY I DO WANT TO SAY
AND REMIND US THAT THE WE'RE
TALKING A LOT ABOUT THE S. T. R.
T. P..
AND GROUP HOME RELATED ISSUES
THIS APPLIES TO ALL CHILDREN AND
YOUTH AND MUCH OF OUR
CONVERSATION IN THE ORIGINAL
ORIGINAL LEGISLATION THOUGHT
ABOUT THOSE PLACES WITH RELATIVE
CARE GIVERS WHO MIGHT LIVE
ACROSS COUNTY LINES.
WHO DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW TO
NAVIGATE THE SYSTEM AND HOW CAN
WE MAKE IT AS EASY AS POSSIBLE
FOR THEM TO RECEIVE SERVICES SO
THAT ISSUES I THINK ARE MORE
ACUTE AND WE'RE TALKING MORE
ABOUT THEM WITH THE?
CONGREGATE FACILITIES BUT I DO
THINK THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT WE HAVE OPPORTUNITIES
TO MAKE THINGS BETTER FOR OUR
RELATIVE CAREGIVERS ANOTHER
FOSTER PARENTS RESOURCE FAMILIES
WITHIN THESE CHILDREN ARE PLACED.
SO SOME OF THE THEMES THAT WERE
HEARING I THINK KIND OF CLOSER
TO TWO AREAS ONE IS COMPLEXITY
AND YOU'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT
DIFFERENT CONTRACTS ACROSS
DIFFERENT COUNTY LINES WHEN
WE'RE PLACING FROM ONE COUNTY TO
ANOTHER.
JUST EVEN THE FORMS ARE
DIFFERENT CONSENT FOR THEY
DIFFER BY COUNTIES THERE THERE'S
FIFTY PLUS OF THOSE AS WELL --
THE CONTRACTING DIFFERS BY
COUNTY WHAT THE CONTRACT LOOKS
LIKE WHAT THEY CHOOSE TO PAY FOR
AND THOSE SORTS OF THINGS.
AND THEN ALSO IT'S IMPORTANT
REMEMBER BECAUSE OF THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE OF FORMER
RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF THAT
TRANSITION FROM THE OLD GROUP
HOME FACILITIES INTO THESE S. T.
R. T. PEAS.
AND SO WITH A REQUIREMENT THAT
THEY ALL HAVE THAT MENTAL HEALTH
CONTRACT ON THERE JUST NOT A
PLACE YET AND THAT CAN LEAD TO A
LACK OF TIMELINESS OF SERVICES.
MISTER COOLEY.
YES MISTER COOLING JUST A VERY
BRIEF QUESTION ON THIS SO AS
YOUR COMMENT UPON THE
DIFFERENCES AMONG THE FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES I MEAN THAT KIND
OF IMPLIES.
IF YOU COULD STANDARDIZE THINGS
THAT WOULD BE ADVANTAGEOUS I
THINK THERE COULD BE SOME
STANDARDIZATION ACROSS THE
THINGS I THINK WHAT WE'RE SEEING
RIGHT NOW AND I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE HARD WORK AT THE
STATE BOTH DEPARTMENTS TO TRY TO
HELP WITH THIS --
THERE IS A A CLEARING HOUSE
WHERE ALL OF THOSE RELEASE OF
INFORMATION CONSENT FORMS ARE
BEING POSTED ON THE INTERNET SO
IF THE COUNTY IS PLACING OUT OF
COUNTY THEY CAN GO AND PULL DOWN
THAT TOOK LEASES AVAILABLE.
THE CONTRACTING I THINK IT'S
TRICKY BECAUSE YOU ALSO HAVE
FIFTY PLUS COUNTY COUNCILS YOU
HAVE THE WE'VE DONE IT THIS WAY
THESE CONTRACTS WORK THERE IN
PLACE.
CERTAINLY I THINK MORE
TRANSPARENCY AROUND THE
CONTRACTS AND WE'D LOVE TO WORK
WITH FOLKS TO SEE IF THERE ARE
SOME COMMON ELEMENTS THAT COULD
BE STANDARDIZED AND THEN MAYBE
THE COUNTY.
KIND OF ADS IN A FEW THINGS THAT
MIGHT BE COUNTY SPECIFIC IT
REGARDING --
LOCATIONS OF TREATMENTS ARE
PROVIDERS THAT MAKES THE STOMACH
COUNTY VERSUS ANOTHER AND THAT
SORT OF THING BUT IT WOULD I
THINK BE GREAT AND USEFUL IF
THERE WASN'T ABILITY. TO TRY TO
MAKE SOME STANDARDIZATION AND
CERTAINLY TRANSPARENCY ACROSS
THAT THAT'S COUNTIES IT'S IT'S A
GREAT QUESTION THANK YOU CAN.
RECOMMEND.
THANK YOU I'M I THINK AS FAR AS
THE CAPACITY IN THE SORT OF
FALLS RIGHT IN LINE WITH WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT --
YOU HAVE CAPACITY OF JUST THE
AVAILABILITY OF BEHAVIOR HEALTH
PROVIDERS WE KNOW THAT THERE IS
AN ISSUE ACROSS BOTH ADULT AND
CHILDREN'S SERVICES WITH
PROVIDERS WHO HAVE THE RIGHT
TRAINING TRAUMA INFORMED CARE --
ALTERNATIVE TYPES OF BIG OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT
AGAIN AS THIS HERNANDEZ NOTED --
AS WELL AS THIS AND THAT
PENETRATION RATES THAT WERE
STILL I THINK WORKING WITH OUR
PARTNERS ON BEHAVIOR HOW TO TRY
TO INCREASE INCREASE TIMELINESS
INCREASE THE SERVICES THAT ARE
PROVIDED TO THE YOUTH.
IN ALSO --
INSURE THAT THE DATA ARE REALLY
THERE SO WE CAN TRACK THAT OVER
TIME -- SO
SO IT'S SORT OF A CAPACITY ISSUE
THERE CAPACITY REGARDING THE S.
HERE TO BE IS NOT HAVING THOSE
CONTRACTS IN PLACE AGAIN RAN
TRANSITION.
AND THEN I THINK FINALLY JUST
SORT OF A CAPACITY OF PROVIDERS
AND THAT INCLUDES AS CHAIR
TEEPEES.
THERE'S SOME THERE'S MANY
THEY'RE NOT MAKING THE
TRANSITION FOR SOME REASON
WHATEVER REASON THERE'S A NUMBER
OF REASONS THAT ARE VERY
LEGITIMATE THEY DECIDED NOT TO
DO THAT.
SO THEY'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO
YOU KNOW RECEIVE OUR CHILDREN
ANYMORE AS PLACEMENTS THERE ARE
SOME WHO ARE WORKING WITHOUT
WORKING WITH THE STATE TO TRY TO
DO THAT.
BUT WE KNOW THE STATE DOESN'T
BELIEVE THEY'RE GONNA MAKE IT
THEY'RE SORT OF ON A LIST OF I
DON'T THINK THEY'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO PUT A PROGRAM TOGETHER
THAT WE CAN BLAST.
SO WE'RE GONNA LOSE SOME
CAPACITY THERE.
THE THING IS CC ARE THE WHOLE
POINT IS TO GET THE YOUTH OUT OF
THESE FACILITIES TO HAVE THESE
BE SHORT TERM VERY THERAPEUTIC
AND I MEAN JUST AS DOCTOR
CATALDO WAS TALKING ABOUT --
YOU'RE NOT FIX NECESSARILY BUT
YOU'RE TO A POINT WHERE WE CAN
HELP PLACE YOU IN THE COMMUNITY
WHAT WOULD REALLY RATHER DO AND
WHAT I THINK SEIZE HERE SUCCESS
DEPENDS ON AS THE COUNTY'S
ABILITY TO REALLY RECRUIT AND
SUPPORT FAMILIES.
AND SUPPORT THEM WHERE THEY ARE
RAP SERVICES ARE THOSE BEDS IN
THOSE THE THAT ARE MORE CALL
SURE IS OKAY WE OKAY WITH THAT
THE SERVICES HAVE GOT TO BE
THERE IN THE COMMUNITY.
AND WE'RE JUST WE'RE NOT THERE
YET -- I
THINK MR ROSE'S POINT ABOUT THE
CHILD SPECIFIC RECRUITMENT WE
ARE DOING A GREAT JOB WE THINK
OF FINDING RELATIVES OR OTHER ON
SORT OF NON RELATED BUT EXTENDED
FAMILY MEMBERS WHO CAN TAKE IN
THE CHILDREN.
BUT WHAT HAPPENS IS THEN IF THAT
CHILD IS REUNIFIED OR SAY THEY
TAKE GUARDIANSHIP OR ADOPTION
THEY DON'T TEND TO TAKE ANOTHER
KID THEY'RE GOD THEY'RE NOT A
FOSTER HOME IN THE SENSE OF THE
TRADITIONAL.
LICENSE TONE THAT MAY HAVE
ADDITIONAL CAPACITY OVER TIME
OKAY WE'VE WORKED WITH THAT
YOU'D NOW WILL TAKE ANOTHER.
ONE AND SO --
I THINK THERE WAS SOME THINKING
THAT PERHAPS THE SORT OF ODD
STABILITY FUND THE FOSTER PARENT
RECRUITMENT FUNDING WOULD BE ONE
TIME AND THEN WE KIND OF GET
ENOUGH OF AND WE CAN BE DONE
WITH THAT --
WERE DEFINING THAT THAT'S NOT
THE CASE THAT THIS IS AN ONGOING
ISSUE HAVE A BUDGET REQUESTS AND
RELATED TO THAT AS WELL AS
RELATED TO SOME ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT THAT WE WANT TO BE ABLE
TO YOU.
PRESERVE FAMILIES STABILIZE
FAMILIES IN THE VEIN OF WHAT MS
HERNANDEZ WAS TALKING ABOUT HER
MEMBERS CARE ABOUT WE'RE ON THE
SAME PAGE THERE WITH THEM.
SO I'LL WRAP UP THERE AND I'M
SORT OF SAVE THE SUGGESTIONS BUT
ON BE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I ANA WAGNER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE DIANA
WAGNER SHASTA COUNTY HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY FRENCH
DIRECTOR OVER BOTH MENTAL HEALTH
AND CHILD WELFARE --
I'VE WORKED WITH THE COUNTY FOR
FIVE YEARS PRIOR TO THAT I
WORKED AT A LOCAL LOCAL LEVEL
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN GROUP HOME FOR
SIXTEEN YEARS AND HAVING THEM
NUMBER OF YEARS EXPERIENCE
WORKING WITH FOSTER YOUTH.
AND PROBATION IS --
TO AB TWELVE NINETY NINE THERE
WERE SOME COUNTIES IN THE STATE
THAT DID NOT PROVIDE SPECIALLY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR
FOSTER YOUTH WHO ARE PLACED
OUTSIDE OF THEIR COUNTY OF LOCAL
JURISDICTION.
THIS WAS A PROBLEM THAT WE RAN
INTO AND SHASTA COUNTY WHEN
PLACING YOUTH INTO OTHER
COUNTIES WITH RELATIVES OR
WITHIN THEIR FOR FOREVER FAMILY.
I BELIEVE THIS JOB AT ADDRESSING
THE ISSUE FOR YOUTH PLACED
OUTSIDE THE COUNTY OF ORIGINAL
JURISDICTION INTO FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCIES.
COUNTY FOSTER HOMES.
INTO RELATIVE HOMES AND EVEN
INTO NON RELATED EXTENDED FAMILY
MEMBERS WHAT I DO NOT BELIEVE
THE BILL TOOK INTO CONSIDERATION
WAS A BEFORE --
THREE THE CONTINUE OF KERRY FORM
AND THE REFORM OF GROUP HOMES
INTO.
S. T. R. T. PEAS THAT ARE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE SPECIALLY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ON SITE
TO ADDRESS THE ACUTE MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS OF FOSTER YOUTH
PLACED IN CONGREGATE CARE
SETTINGS. FOR SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME.
MOST FOSTER YOUTH PLACED UNDER
CONGREGATE CARE HAVE BEEN A PART
OF THE FOSTER CARE AND MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS.
NEXT TO THE USE THEMSELVES THE
MENTAL HEALTH PLAN IN THE COUNTY
OF ORIGINAL JURISDICTION HAS THE
GREATEST KNOWLEDGE OF THE FOSTER
USE MENTAL HEALTH HISTORY.
AND SERVICE NEEDS.
THIS LANDS TO THE CONTINUITY OF
CARE OF FOSTER YOUTH BEING BEST
SERVED BY THE MENTAL HEALTH PLAN
OF THE COUNTY OF ORIGINAL
JURISDICTION.
IN MY ROLE AS THE CHILD WELFARE
DIRECTOR.
I CONTINUE TO SEE NOTICES GIVEN
ON YOUTH PLACE TO CONGREGATE
CARE AND BY WAVING PRESUMPTIVE
TRANSFER ON THESE USE.
THE MENTAL HEALTH PLAN OF
ORIGINAL JUST JURISDICTION ARE
ABLE TO PLAY A ROLE IN ENSURING
THESE USE NEEDS CONTINUE TO BE
MET REGARDLESS OF WHERE THE
YOUTH THIS PLACE.
IT IS DUE TO THIS REASON THAT A
NUMBER OF COUNTIES WAVE PROVIDE
SOME TO TRANSFER.
AMONG USE PLACE TO CONGREGATE
CARE SETTINGS IN ORDER TO HAVE
THE ABILITY TO MONITOR THE
TREATMENT PROVIDED TO THEIR
YOUTH PROVIDE INTENSIVE CARE
COORDINATION.
AND CONTRACT FOR SERVICES TO
ENSURE THAT THEIR FOSTER YOUTH
ARE BEST INTEREST --
FOR FIELD HOWEVER THERE'S ALWAYS
AN EXCEPTION TO THAT STATEMENT.
AN EXAMPLE OF THIS WAS A YOUNG
MAN HE WAS PLACED IN FRESNO
COUNTY IN A GROUP HOME.
HE WAS PLACED THERE BECAUSE HIS
FATHER Là THIS WAS PRIOR TO
PRESENT TO TRANSFER BEING IN
PLACE.
UNFORTUNATELY HE BLEW OUT OF
THAT PLACEMENT.
ON BECAUSE THEY WERE NOT.
ADEQUATELY EQUIPPED TO MEET HIS
NEEDS OF THE ALCOHOL AND DRUG --
USE THAT HE HAD SO HE WAS PLACED
INTO THE BAY AREA.
BECAUSE WE CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN
CARE AND CUSTODY AND ALSO
OVERSIGHT A MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES WE WERE EASILY ABLE TO
FIND HIM AN APPROPRIATE
PLACEMENT.
AND THE BAY AREA AND STILL THE
PLAN IS TO MOVE HIM BACK TO
FRESNO TO BE NEAR HIS FATHER.
AT WHICH TIME PRESUMPTIVE
TRANSFER WOULD BE PUT IN PLACE.
SHASTA COUNTY IS A RECEIVING
COUNTY OF FSTER YOUTH MEANING
THAT THERE ARE A NUMBER A
GREATER NUMBER OF FOSTER YOUTH
PLACED IN SHASTA COUNTY BY OTHER
COUNTIES.
THAN SHASTA COUNTY SENDS OUT OF
COUNTY.
AT THIS TIME THERE A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FIVE AUSTRIA'S PLACED IN
SHASTA COUNTY BY OTHER COUNTIES
WITH FOR CONGREGATE CARE
PROVIDERS OF HIGH NEEDS FOSTER
YOUTH.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE TODAY
EIGHTEEN PRESUMPTIVELY
TRANSFERRED FOSTER YOU THINK
CONGREGATE CARE SETTINGS AND
NUMEROUS OTHERS PLACED IN FAMILY
HOME SETTINGS.
AS PART OF OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
ALL YOU.
WHETHER THEY ARE PRESUMPTIVELY
TRANSFERRED OR THERE THE
JURISDICTION OF SHASTA COUNTY.
WE CONDUCT SCREENS COMPLETE.
CHILD ADOLESCENTS NEEDS AND
STRENGTHS.
COMPLETE AND REVIEW ASSESSMENTS
REGULARLY COMPLETE TREATMENT
PLANS ATTEND CHILD AND FAMILY
TEAM MEETINGS TO ENSURE THE
COORDINATION OF SERVICES PROVIDE
SERVICES.
AND OR AUTHORIZE SERVICES TO BE
PROVIDED BY CONGREGATE CARE
SETTINGS OR BY OUR CONGRESS --
BY OUR CONTRACTED PROVIDERS IN
THE COMMUNITY.
BECAUSE PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER AND
TAKING RESPONSIBILITY OF THOSE
YOUTH AND SHASTA COUNTY IS MORE
THAN JUST ABOUT A PAYMENT.
IN JULY TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
WHEN AB TWELVE NINETY NINE FIRST
BEGAN.
THERE WERE NUMEROUS
CONVERSATIONS THAT I HAD WITH
CHILD WELFARE DIRECTOR DIRECTORS
DISCUSSING AB.
TWELVE NINETY NINE THE MEANING
BEHIND THE BILL.
THIS ALSO OCCURRED MORE OFTEN
WHEN COUNTIES PLACE FOSTER YOUTH
IN THE GROUP HOMES OR THE
CONGREGATE CARE SETTINGS LOCATED
IN CHEST COUNTY.
THERE WAS A LACK OF
UNDERSTANDING TO THE LAW.
AND OF THE REQUIRED DOCUMENTS
THE IN ORDER FOR THOSE YOUTH TO
RECEIVE THE SERVICES.
EVEN AS I SPEAK TODAY THERE
CONTINUES TO BE ISSUE WITH THE
PLACING AGENCIES PROMPTLY
PROVIDING IMAGE PEAS WITH THE
REQUIRED DOCUMENTS FOR CLIENTS
TO BE OPENED TO SPECIALLY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
AC SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
WITHIN THREE BUSINESS DAYS OF
THE TERMINATION OF PRISM TO
TRANSFER THE PLACE AN AGENCY IS
TO CONTACT THE MENTAL HEALTH.
PLANS POINT OF CONTACT. FOR THE
FOSTER THE FOUR ON THE FOSTER
USE BEING PLACED OUT OF THEIR
COUNTY OF ORIGINAL DIVERT
JURISDICTION AND PROVIDE
CONTRACT CONTACT INFORMATION ON
THE YOUTH.
ON THE PLACEMENT THE CHILD IS
GOING.
TO CONTACT INFORMATION FOR THE
SOCIAL WORKER OR PROBATION
OFFICER.
A SIGNED CONSENT FOR SERVICES.
X. SIGNED CONSENT FOR MEDICATION
THAT INCLUDE THE JV.
TO TWENTY AND THE MOST RECENT
MENTAL HEALTH ASSESSMENT.
AND WHILE THESE FORMS ARE
READILY AVAILABLE. TO COUNTY
WORKERS ONLINE.
THIS STILL CONTINUES TO BE AN
AREA FOR IMPROVEMENT.
WHAT PERCENT OF TRANSFER?
HAS IMPACTED MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
DUE TO LACK OF WORK FORCE DUE TO
LACK OF FUNDING RECEIVING THAT
RECEIVING COUNTY IS FOR PURPOSE
PROVIDING SERVICES.
THERE NEEDS TO BE A REVISION.
IT IS THE LAW THAT TRULY
BENEFITS YOUTH PLACED WITH
RELATIVES WITH AN F. A PHASE
WITHIN COUNTY HOMES AND WITH NON
EXTENDED.
NON RELATED EXTENDED FAMILY
MEMBERS.
BUT IT IS A LOT THAT NEEDS TO BE
LOOKED AT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
MISTER CARROLL.
NUMBER STIR SCHROEDER.
ANSWERS ALMOST ANYTHING.
THE USER PROVIDING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES TO OUT OF COUNTY FOSTER
YOUTH HAS BEEN A FOCUS. FOR
SOMETIME IT ISN'T SOMETHING
THAT'S NEW.
IN YOUR OPINION WHAT IS MADE
THIS ISSUE OF PROTECT.
IN PARTICULAR SO DIFFICULT TO
ADDRESS.
WELL I THINK IT'S PROBABLY A
COMBINATION OF THINGS --
IF YOU GO BACK FAR ENOUGH --
IT -- AND
MISTER COOLEY WAS IT WAS TALKING
ABOUT THE THE THE BILL THAT THAT
THAT MEANS THAT HE WORKED WITH
MR PAT AND AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
THREE WHICH I FORTUNATELY
REMEMBER.
WHICH WHICH YOU KNOW TELLS YOU
HOW LONG I'VE BEEN DOING THIS
THERE REALLY WERE NO MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FOR CHILDREN
EXCEPT WHAT ANY INDIVIDUAL
COUNTY SCRATCH TOGETHER --
IT DIDN'T OCCUR IT DIDN'T MATTER
WHAT THE NEEDS OF THE CHILD
WHERE IT DIDN'T MATTER WHETHER
IN A GROUP HOME WHERE FOSTER
FAMILY HOME IT JUST DIDN'T
MATTER THE THE SERVICES WERE
WERE BARELY THERE --
IN --
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE WITH THE
ADVENT OF THE OF THE LITIGATION
THAT LED TO THE THE THE USE OF
THE PST T.. TO PROVIDE THOSE SIR
TO PAY FOR THE SERVICES FOR YOU
THROUGH THE MEDICARE PROGRAM --
THEN IF IT BECAME RESPONSIBILITY
INDIVIDUAL COUNTIES AND AS I SAY
A BIG PROBLEM IS IS THAT EACH
COUNTY DOES IT'S YOU KNOW HAS
ITS OWN.
STUFF THAT IT DOES AND I WILL
TELL YOU THAT.
IS SOMEWHERE IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD
OF TWENTY TO FORTY CENTS VERY
MEDI CAL DOLLARS THAT'S THAT'S
PAY THAT SPENT ON AND YOU USE
THAT YOU SPEND FOR THE MIDDLE OF
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR YOUTH.
IS SPENT ON Q. A MEANING MAKING
SURE THAT YOU MAKE SURE ALL YOUR
TEASER THIS --
THE IS --
TAKEN CARE OF AND THAT'S IT
LARGELY INTO A GREAT EXTENT THAT
HAS TO DO WITH --
WITH MULTIPLE COUNTY CONTRACTS
MULTIPLE DEMANDS ON THAT SORT OF
THING SAVE GOT THAT PROBLEM --
THE AND THEN THE THE THE THEN
THE THE JUST THAT THE THE
COMPLEXITY OF WHEN AS I SAY I
COUNTY FROM SAY SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PLATES AT THE PLACE
IS A JOB WITH THAT --
WITH A EITHER WITH A RELATIVE OR
IN A FFA OR WITH A GROUP HOME.
IN CENTRAL CALIFORNIA --
THE DID THE NCAPACITY IN THE
DIFFICULTY AND HAVING THAT THE
THE THE MENTAL HEALTH PLAN OF
THAT CAT THE THE OF THE PLACING
COUNTY COORDINATE WITH SERVICES
IN THAT RECEIVING COUNTIES IS
REALLY REALLY DIFFICULT --
AND SO I I I I UNDERSTAND I IS
POINT ABOUT THE THAT IT HAS
WORKED OUT WELL FOR FOR YOUTH
AND IN THAT --
IN RESIDENTIAL PROGRAMS.
BUT ACTUALLY IN IN TERMS THE HOW
THE MONEY FLOWS WE HAD A VERY
DIFFERENT APPROACH TO THAT WHEN
WE FIRST READ THE BILL --
IN WHICH IT WAS GONNA BE YOU
KNOW IT WAS IT WAS KIND OF TO
ENSURE THE COUNTIES THAT
RECEIVED AS THOSE YEARS WITH --
WERE COVERED IN THE FIRST YEAR
WITHIN A YEAR THAT THEY GOT THE
THE OF THAT THOSE COSTS WERE
COVERED FOR THEM --
SO IS IT WAS BECAUSE OF
POTENTIAL VETO THAT WE HAD TO
CHANGE THAT AND WE KNEW THAT THE
TIME WE CHANGE IT WAS GONNA BE A
PROBLEM AND FRANKLY WE REALLY
WANTED -- TO
WE WANTED TO PUSH THIS ISSUE WE
WANTED TO GET A FINAL RESOLUTION
TO THIS ISSUE BECAUSE OF IT UP
FOR SO LONG --
I THINK THE THE THE LAST THING
IS THAT THAT THE COUNTIES HAVE
TAKEN ON YOU KNOW THEIR WHERE
THEY WANTED TO OR NOT ANOTHER
ISSUE BUT I HAVE TAKEN ON A
FEDERAL ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM --
WITH THE CAPTAIN OF THE MONEY TO
PROVIDE THAT ENTITLEMENT AND AND
AND NOW THEIR BOARDS OF
SUPERVISORS ARE ARE FACING A
REALLY DIFFICULT TASK AND THAT
IS.
THAT YOU KNOW YOU THE YOUNG
PERSON WHO IS ENTITLED TO THE
SERVICES IN TITLE THE SERVICES
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THAT COUNTY
CAN PAY FOR IT.
AND THE COUNTIES OF TAKING ON
THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR PAYING
FOR IT NOW THE QUESTION BECOMES
ONE OF WELL HOW DO YOU DO THAT
HOW DO YOU MAKE SURE.
THAT THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE GET
THOSE SERVICES.
SO I IT IT'S IT'S A COMPLICATED
IT COMES.
YOU HEALTH AND IF NOT I'LL TALK.
NO.
THAT WAS THE ANSWER WHAT WE'RE
HEARING -- I
DO WANT TO THANK YOU I DO WANT
TO THANK THE PANELISTS --
I WANT TO CALL BACK.
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES OF
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. TO REJOIN THE OTHER
PANELISTS AT THE TABLE TO
DISCUSS.
POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS AND EFFORTS
BEING MADE TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS WE'VE HEARD TODAY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
VANESSA ONCE YOU HAVE A SEAT
WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN WITH YOU.
THEN I'D LIKE TO INVITE THE SS
AND DH CS TO SPEAK.
AND THEN THE REMAINING PANELISTS
CAN ALSO ADD ON IF THEY'D LIKE
[inaudible]
THE OLD.
SO POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS AND
EFFORTS BEING MADE TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS THAT WE'VE HEARD
HERE TODAY.
YES THANK YOU --
AND THE YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
THINK --
MORE BROADLY IN THE BILL OF THE
TECH KIND OF BRAINSTORMING
VISION -- A
SYSTEM THAT WOULD SERVE THE
UNIQUE NEEDS FOR OUR CHILDREN
YOUTH IN CARE --
THINKING OUT LOUD AND ON SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT INTEGRATING SOME
OF THE THINGS I'VE HEARD FROM MY
MEMBERS --
THERE'S SEVERAL IDEAS ARE START
WITH I'M ONE OF THEM PROBABLY
THE MOST PROCESS WOULD BE TO
RADICALLY MOBILIZE RESOURCES FOR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH IN CARE WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT OUR YOUNG PEOPLE IN
CONGREGATE CARE.
AND AT THE IDEA ONE OF THE CORE --
TENANTS OF C. C. R. WAS THAT A
YOUNG PERSON WOULD GET SERVICES
NO MATTER WHERE THEY WERE PLACE
THEY WOULD NOT HAVE TO FILL UP
TO A GROUP HOME OR CONGREGATE
CARE SETTING. TO GET THE
THERAPEUTIC HELP THAT THEY NEED --
AND THE THE FOLKS ARE ON THE
TABLE CAN CORRECT MY NUMBERS BUT
THE AMOUNT OF THE MONEY THAT
WE'RE SPENDING PER YOUTH PER
MONTH IN GROUP HOMES.
IS VERY VERY HIGH IF I HAD TO
GUESS WOULD BE BETWEEN EIGHT TO
TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
MONTH IF WE WERE TO USE THOSE
RESOURCES TO REALLY SUPPORT THE
FAMILY WITH WRAPAROUND SERVICES.
WITH THE SERVICES THAT MADE
SENSE TO THEM AND REALLY
SUPPORTED THEM IN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES I BET WE COULD GET A
LOT OF THINGS DONE.
I'M ANOTHER IDEA OR TO SUPPORT
THAT IDEA WOULD BE TO LOOK AT
THE ESTHER TEEPEES BY DO HAVE ON
SITE THERAPISTS AND CLINICIANS
OR ARE CONTRACTED WITH THEM.
INSTEAD OF HAVING AN ON SITE
PERSON COULD WE MOBILIZE THAT
PERSON TO GO VISIT THOSE TWELVE
YOUNG PEOPLE IN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES IS THAT A STRUCTURE
THAT MAKES SENSE. FOR CALIFORNIA.
ANOTHER THING I'D LIKE TO UPLIFT
TODAY IS WRAPAROUND SERVICES A
LOT OF THE TRUMP FAMILY TEAM IN
DIFFERENT --
MODELS THAT WE HEAR ABOUT AND
TALK ABOUT TODAY HAVE STAND OR
HAVE ELEMENTS OF WRAP AROUND --
AND THAT THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT
HAS HAD.
A LOT OF THE EVIDENCE BASED OF
PRODUCTIVE OUTCOMES THAT WOULD
BE WORTHWHILE TO RE LOOK AT
ANOTHER IDEA ANOTHER SOLUTION.
WOULD BE TO EXPAND THE NET OF
WHAT ELIGIBLE SERVICES ARE SO WE
WOULD WIDEN THE TYPES OF
SERVICES THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WOULD FIND. TO BE
MORE RELEVANT AND CONNECTED TO
THE YOUNG PEOPLE THAT THEY ARE
SERVING --
COULD INCLUDE NONTRADITIONAL OF
SUPPORT AND HEALING THIS COULD
BE COMMUNITY BASED OR CULTURALLY
BASED.
PROGRAMS AND SO THE IDEA WOULD
BE TO HAVE AN ARRAY OF SERVICES
THAT REALLY MEET YOUNG PEOPLE
WHERE THEY'RE AT IN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES.
SPECIFICALLY I'D ALSO LIKE TO
UPLIFT THE EXPANSION OF SERVICES
FOR TAE YOUNG PEOPLE.
AS THEIR NET NAVIGATING
ADULTHOOD.
A LOT OF THEM HAVE COME TO A
PLACE IN THEIR LIVES WHERE THERE
ONE TEEN RESOURCES THEY'RE
WANTING TOOLS.
AND AT THAT JUNCTURE IN TIME
THERE'S NOT A LOT TO OFFER AND
SO I'D LIKE TO SUPPORT AND
EXPAND --
WIDENING THE NET FOR TEH MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AS WELL THANK
YOU.
HOW ABOUT SOMEBODY FROM DSS?
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MY
NAME IS SERRA ROGERS AND I AM
THE BRANCH CHIEF --
BEFORE THE CONTINUUM OF CARE
REFORM OVERSEEING GENERAL
IMPLEMENTATION FORCE SIXTY ARM.
AND WE ARE THROUGH OUR C. C. R.
IMPLEMENTATION EFFORTS EXTREMELY
AWARE AND FAMILIAR WITH SOME OF
THE COROLLARY CHALLENGES --
THAT HAVE OCCURRED WITH
PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER
IMPLEMENTATION THAT KIND OF A
CREDIT EXACTLY THE SAME TIME.
AND WELL C. C. R. HAS A TACKLE
THE PROBLEM BY EMBEDDING MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES IN THE MENTAL
HEALTH OR IN THE S. T. R. T. P.
MODEL THE RESIDENTIAL SETTING.
INHERENTLY WE'RE SEEING THREE
GENERAL BUCKETS --
WHERE WE WOULD SUGGEST ARE
FOCUSING OUR EFFORTS AT THE
SOLUTION ONE IS THAT WE SEE
THERE'S A LEARNING CURVE AND SO
TO THAT END WE HAVE INVESTED
VERY HEAVILY ON A?
LOT OF REGIONAL TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WE ARE OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY ACROSS THE STATE.
ON LITERALLY A WEEKLY BASIS
TOGETHER WITH OUR PARTNER AGENCY --
DH CS WE ARE ON THE PHONE WITH
COUNTIES BOTH --
AT THE SYSTEM LEVEL BUT ACTUALLY
HAVE ALSO THROUGH C. ARE
IMPLEMENTED CHILD SPECIFIC
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CALLS WHERE
WIN -- ANY
BARRIER TO THE SERVICES ARE
OCCURRING COUNTIES ARE ACTUALLY
INVITED TO REACH OUT TO US AND
IN MANY CASES THE CHALLENGE TO
THE CHILD'S PLACEMENT OR
STABILITY --
THEIR WELL BEING IS PRESUMPTIVE
TRANSFER AND IN THOSE INSTANCES
WE ARE WORKING CLOSELY WITH OUR
ASSOCIATION PARTNERS AS WELL AS
TEACH CS TO ADDRESS THOSE
PROBLEMS.
AND FROM THAT HAVE LEARNED A LOT
ABOUT THE SYSTEMIC BARRIERS.
AND I THINK THE OTHER THE OTHER
SOLUTION FOR IT FOR THE PURPOSE
OF ADDRESSING THE LEARNING CURVE
IS THAT WE HAVE DEVELOPED
THROUGH THIS LEARNING PROCESS.
AID A TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE KIND
OF GUIDE THAT WE PLAN TO RELEASE
AND MARCH THAT I THINK BRENDA
RELATES CAN ALSO SPEAK --
TO WHERE WE ARE WE ARE
IMPLEMENTING A VERY CAREFUL STEP
BY STEP PROCESS THAT WILL
COMMUNICATE CLEARLY NOT ONLY HOW
AB WAIVER DECISION.
SHOULD BE REACHED BUT ALSO ONCE
IT IS REACHED EXACTLY WHAT NEEDS
TO HAPPEN IN ORDER TO AVOID --
THE CONFUSION ESSENTIALLY OVER
TIME CAN THING WE I DID ONE AND
PUT INTO SIZE IS THAT.
WE STILL FEEL THAT EACH CHILD
SPECIFIC DETERMINATION IS
CRITICAL THAT JUMPING TO ANOTHER
ONE SIZE FITS ALL IN THIS
SITUATION IS PROBABLY NOT WHAT
ANYONE AND I WOULD RECOMMEND --
I'M ASSUMING THAT OTHERS MIGHT
AGREE WITH ME ON THAT BUT THE
CHILD AND FAMILY TEAM --
MODEL THAT HAS BEEN IMPLEMENTED
BOTH PRIOR TO SEE SEE OUR BUT
THEN VERY MUCH EMPHASIZED IN CC
ARE.
WE THINK IS WHERE THE RUBBER
MEETS THE ROAD IN NOT ONLY
ANSWERING THIS QUESTION ABOUT
PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER BUT ALSO
ALL OF THE OTHER COMMENTS YOU
MAY HAVE HEARD AROUND.
HOW WHAT IS IT THAT WOULD BEST
MEET THE NEEDS OF THIS CHILD
WHAT OTHER TYPES OF SERVICES
WOULD MAKE A DIFFERENCE? TO
STABILIZE THE PLACEMENT TO PRINT
TO TO HELP THE FAMILY REALLY
CARE FOR THE CHILD BEFORE THEY
EVEN GET TO AN S. T. R. T. P..
AND THEN ONCE THEY'RE IN A NEST
YEAR T. P. HOW DO WE CORRECTLY
PLAN FOR AN IMPLEMENT THEIR
THEIR TRANSITION TO A HOME
SETTING --
AND SO THAT CHILD SPECIFIC
DETERMINATION I THINK IS REALLY
CRITICAL AND SO RATHER THAN.
AND I THINK THERE'S BEEN
CONFUSION AROUND THE PRESUMPTIVE
WORD PRESUMPTIVE --
AND SO AS A RESULT FOR S. T. R.
T. P. PLACEMENTS IN PARTICULAR
WE REALLY NEED TO EMPHASIZE THAT
FOR EVERY CHILD THERE HAS TO BE
A VERY CAREFUL CONSIDERATION.
AND THEN LASTLY WE WOULD
EMPHASIZE THE PLANNING AND
COLLABORATION AT THE SYSTEM
LEVEL AND SO CCAR HAS REQUIRED
PURSUANT TO AB.
EIGHTEEN ELEVEN VERY RIGOROUS
TRANSITION PLANS BOTH ACTUALLY
AT THE TOP PACIFIC LEVEL BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY FOR THIS
CONVERSATION.
AT THE SYSTEM LEVEL WHERE EVERY
COUNTY WITH IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH PLAN.
IS REQUIRED TO YES CHARITY PIECE
THEY PLAN TO PLACE AND
REGARDLESS OF THE COUNTY THAT
THAT IT'S AND SO WE ARE NOW
REALLY PRO ACTIVELY WORKING WITH
COUNTIES TO ASK WHO ARE THE
FACILITIES YOU NEED.
TO AND DO YOUR MENTAL HEALTH
PLANS HAVE OR PLAN TO HAVE.
RELATIONSHIPS ARE FINANCIAL --
CONTRACTS WITH THOSE S. T. R. T.
P. IS AND SO WE'RE REALLY TAKING
A STEP BACK AND WORKING TO
ENSURE THAT EVERY SINGLE COUNTY.
AND THEY'RE IN A MENTAL HEALTH
PLAN IS ON THE SAME PAGE ABOUT
WHO THEY BELIEVE THEY NEED AND
THAT IS.
A REALLY.
IMPORTANT EFFORT THAT WERE THAT
WERE EMBARKED ON RIGHT NOW THE
COUNTIES OF ACTUALLY SUBMITTED
US THEIR PLANS --
ALREADY AND NOW WE'RE WORKING
WITH THEM TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
CAPACITY NEED MATCHES --
AND SO WITH THAT I THINK THAT
THAT'S THE COMMENTS THAT I WOULD
LEAVE THE THE REST TO MY MY
PARTNER EACH YES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MANAGER --
RENDER GREAT WISH DIETZ YES --
SO I THINK --
ARE MY COLLEAGUE MISS ROGERS
ALREADY SAID QUITE A BIT OF WHAT
WE'RE BEEN DOING I CAN GET A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT IT ON THE FIRST
TIME I WAS UP HERE --
BUT WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
EXTENSIVELY --
WITH -- CDSS
BUT ALSO WITH OUR ASSOCIATIONS --
TO DO THE IT SOME REGULATIONS UP
THROUGH BULLETIN AUTHORITY BUT
WE'RE GOING TO PROMULGATE THEM
INFORMAL REGULATIONS --
AND ARE THE CASE SPECIFIC ISSUES
I THINK IT'S BEEN THE MOST
INTENSIVE PIECE OF THAT SO THAT
THEY'RE ACTUALLY LOOKING AT
INDIVIDUAL CASES --
AND THAT'S PRIMARILY BEEN
BETWEEN CDSS AND AND C. W. D. A
AND C. B. H. TA SO I THINK THAT
THAT'S BEEN ON A LOT OF LEARNING
FROM WE KNOW FOR OUR TEAMS BUT
ALSO -- AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL AS WELL AS FOLKS
ARE JUST TRYING TO GET A HANDLE
ON YOU KNOW IMPLEMENTING AND AND
KIND OF WORKING THROUGH THOSE
KINKS -- AND
THEN S MISS ROGERS TALKED ABOUT
THE STEP BY STEP PROCESS PROCESS
I'M I THINK YOU KNOW WE WERE IN --
MEETINGS JUST SO MANY TIMES AND
WE JUST KEPT SAYING YOU KNOW
THEY'RE JUST NEEDS TO BE LIKE A
RECIPE OR SOMETHING THAT JUST.
REALLY PRESCRIBES WHAT THAT BAT
THINKING --
CHAIN NEEDS TO LOOK LIKE AND
WHAT WHAT STEPS NEED TO HAPPEN
AND SO -- SO
WE WILL HAVE BEEN WORKING
TOGETHER ON BETWEEN THE
ASSOCIATIONS IN THE STATE
DEPARTMENT'S REALLY PUT A VERY
PRESCRIPTIVE STEP BY STEP
PROCESS TOGETHER --
SO -- WE'RE
JUST ABOUT DONE WITH THE DRAFT
ON THAT STUFF I COLDER I OKAY
AND THEN.
ULTIMATELY --
AND THAT WE'RE GOING TO DO THAT
IN THIS MONTH IN MARCH AND THIS
COMING MONTH AND SHORTLY THERE
AFTER YOU KNOW IF WE IF WE
DEPENDING ON THE FEEDBACK WE GET --
WERE PLANNING TO PUT THAT OUT IN
A JOINT INFORMATION NOTICE ALL
COUNTY LEVEL OR LETTER BETWEEN
THE DEPARTMENT SO THAT WE CAN
DISSEMINATE IT --
OUGHT TO THE COUNTY IS ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE HOUSE SO --
SO REALLY TRYING --
TO TO HELPS PROVIDE AS MUCH
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AS WE CAN --
YOU KNOW WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THE ISSUES SO THAT WE
CAN -- DO
WHAT WE CAN DO TO HELP --
BUT IT REALLY SEEMS TO COME DOWN
TO WILL --
YOU KNOW COMMUNICATION AND CALL
IT'S REALLY GONNA KNOWING WHAT
TO DO AND BEING ABLE TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN SO --
I THINK WE'RE TRYING TO MODEL
THAT AT OUR LEVELS AND THEN
YOU'RE REALLY LOOKING TO SEE
THAT --
HAPPEN IN THE COUNTIES AS WELL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HOME KATHY CENTER LÏNG.
THANK MADAM CHAIR AND AS A
MEMBER STONE --
APPRECIATE THE ABILITY TO
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
SUGGESTIONS.
I THINK ALL SORT OF GO ON THREE
TRACKS SO THE FIRST IS RELATED
TO THE PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER.
I THINK WHAT WE'RE FINDING AND
LOOKING AT THE DATA IS THAT IT'S
NOT LIKELY THAT THEY'LL BE A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL SORT OF DO OR
DON'T KIND OF ANSWER.
THAT -- DATA --
I THINK ONE OF MY PRIOR
PANELISTS MENTIONED WAS THAT IT
SEEMS LIKE LARGER COUNTIES ARE
MORE LIKELY TO WAIVE PRESUMPTIVE
TRANSFER THAN SMALLER COUNTIES
AND A WORSE TO BE THAT THAT'S
BECAUSE THEY DO HAVE A GREATER
CAPACITY TO PROVIDE.
THOSE SERVICES IN THEIR COUNTY
OR CARE COORDINATE VIA THEIR
COUNTY JUST YOU KNOW LARGER
COUNTY OFTEN EQUALS LARGER
RESOURCES.
AND SO SORT OF THAT AVAILABILITY
OF SERVICES AND THINKING ABOUT
THAT PERHAPS SOLUTIONS THERE AND
THE KIND OF WORK BOOKER COOKBOOK
THAT MS GRAY LEDGE IS TALKING
ABOUT.
CAN HELP THAT COUNTY THINK ABOUT
WHAT VERSUS WHAT THAT HOST
COUNTY MIGHT BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
AND THEN MAKE DECISIONS THAT ARE
TRULY IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
THE CHILD AND NOT JUST BASED ON
KIND OF THE AVAILABILITY OF A
PLACEMENT FOR EXAMPLE.
RELATED TO THE PRESUMPTIVE
TRANSFER WAVING IT OR NOT WAVING
AT I THINK --
WE ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO EXPAND OUR CAPACITY TO
SERVE OUR YOUTH IN OUR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH THE EPS C. T.
ENTITLEMENT IS THAT YOU HEARD
ABOUT AS WELL AND THAT.
FALL HEARING RELATED TO MENTAL
HEALTH --
IT'S IT'S PRETTY CLEAR THAT IF
THE YOUTH HAS THAT NEED THAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO GET THAT
FILLED.
AND SO I THINK CONTINUING THE
DISCUSSIONS THAT ALREADY EXIST
RELATED TO IS THE PROBLEM THAT
MORE MONEY IS NEEDED --
IS THERE A PROBLEM THAT THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
PROVIDERS ARE THERE IS A PROBLEM
THAT WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
AUTHORIZE ADDITIONAL TYPES OF
SERVICES --
DO WE NEED TO A GREATER CAPACITY
TO DO KIND OF ONE OFF CONTRACTS
WITH THE PARTICULAR PROVIDER.
I FEEL LIKE ALL OF THOSE ARE
LIKELY PART OF THE SOLUTION AND
WERE THERE WERE THERE FOR EVERY
CONVERSATION THAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN BECAUSE ALL OF THOSE
THINGS.
I THINK NEED TO BE DISCUSSED AND
THEN FINALLY I THINK THESE ARE
REALLY I MEAN I I HESITATED A
CALL THESE SOLUTIONS I I MIGHT
CALL THEM HOPEFUL THINGS WE CAN
DO TO MAKE IT BETTER.
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK THERE'S
SORT OF ONE MAGIC WAND THE OF
THESE ISSUES DON'T I'M.
SORRY I LEFT IT I LEFT IT AT
HOME -- AND
THOUGH I KEEP LOOKING FOR IT AT
ITS LOST --
I THINK I THINK ONE REALLY
CRITICAL THING AND YOU'VE HEARD
IT AS A THEME I THINK FOR ME AS
WELL AS FROM SOME OF THE OTHER --
PANELIST IS WE'VE JUST GOT TO
SUPPORT OUR FAMILY PLACEMENTS
BETTER THAT --
GETTING THOSE SERVICES TO THEM
TO THE YOUTH WHERE THEY ARE
WRAPPING THEM AROUND THE
SERVICES AND REALLY FIGURING OUT
SOMETHING THAT I DON'T THINK
WE'VE FIGURED OUT YET AS A STATE.
WHICH IS HOW TO RECRUIT AND
SUPPORT FAMILIES FOR USE WITH
HIGHER NEEDS WE'D EXPECTED AND
HOPED THAT THERE WOULD BE A A
CADRE OF FAMILIES WHO WOULD BE
WILLING AND ABLE. TO SUPPORT
THOSE YOUTH OUTSIDE OF A GROUP
HOME --
PERHAPS NOT THE RELATIVE OR
PERHAPS A RELATIVE WITH
SIGNIFICANT SUPPORT I DON'T
THINK WE'VE SEEN THOSE HOMES
REALLY MATERIALIZE SORT OF
THERAPEUTIC FOSTER CARE IS ONE
WAY OF REFERRING TO THEM WHETHER
IT IS.
WELL IT'S CHILD SPECIFIC AND WE
JUST NEED TO RECRUIT THEM AND WE
JUST NEED TO GIVE THEM WHAT EVER
THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO TO WORK
WITH THAT YOUTH AND STABILIZE
THAT FAMILY AND AND GET THEM THE
SERVICES THAT THEY ALL NEED --
MAYBE THAT SAID --
SUPPORTING THEM IN THE MOMENT --
WE'VE GOT THAT SORT OF URGENT
RESPONSE --
HOTLINE AND AND THINGS THAT WE
WANT TO ARE GOING AS WELL AS WE
WANT THEM TO TO BE ABLE TO
STABILIZE THAT FAMILY AND HELP
OVERCOME THAT.
THERE'S THINGS THAT I WE THINK
WE CAN DO --
TO BRING TO BEAR IT'S JUST A
MATTER OF OF GETTING THOSE ALL
IN PLACE AND WE'RE NOT THERE YET
SO.
MY THOUGHTS.
TICKET GOES BACK TO THE AMOUNT
OF MONEY THAT IS SPENT --
AND HOMES AND IF WE CAN USE THAT
FOR THE FAMILIES TO SUPPORT THEM
[inaudible]
MISTER SCHROEDER.
THAT SORT OF I THINK YOU'VE JUST
BEEN CAPS ELATED SIR WHAT'S THE
C. R. HAS BEEN ABOUT WHICH IS
HOW DO WE TAKE.
MONEY THAT WE WERE PREVIOUSLY
SPENDING FOR FOR PRETTY
EXPENSIVE RESIDENTIAL PLACEMENTS
IN THE THAT MONEY --
INTO --
FAMILY BASED --
SETTINGS FOR FOR YOUTH AND THEN
WRAP SERVICES SUPPORT AROUND
THAT FAMILY THAT YOUNG PERSON SO
THAT THEY CAN SUCCEED.
SO I THINK YOU'VE YOU'VE HIT THE
NAIL ON THE HEAD SO I THINK
WE'VE GOT THE MECHANISMS IN
PLACE THE QUESTION IS HOW DO WE
MAKE THIS MECHANISMS WORK --
I I EITHER THERE A COUPLE THINGS
THAT THAT COME TO MIND AS IT IS
I THINK ABOUT THIS ISSUE OF
PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER.
AND ONE IS THAT THAT CONTINUES
CARRY FORM.
SORTOF PRESUMED AND THEN MADE
SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS ABOUT --
INTEGRATION OF EFFORTS BETWEEN --
COUNTY MIDDLE HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
AND AND CHILD WELFARE
DEPARTMENTS IN JUVENILE
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS IN TERMS
OF THOSE YOUTH WHO NEED --
AND SOME TYPE OF OUT OF HOME
CARE IT'S STILL --
IS SOMETHING IT'S IN PROCESS --
THE A I THINK THAT --
THAT ONE OF THE THINGS I I CAN'T
REMEMBER DIANA POINTED OUT OR
NOT -- BUT
IF YOU HAVE A A PARTICULAR --
CHILD WELFARE AB DEPARTMENT IS
PREPARED TO PLACE A CHILD WITH A
PARTICULAR STR TP.
BUT THE MENTAL HEALTH --
PLAN IN THAT PARTICULAR COUNTY
DOESN'T HAVE A RELATIONSHIP WITH
THEM.
THEN ONE OF THINGS YOU CAN DO IS
JUST AND AND THEN IT BECOMES THE
RESPONSIBILITY THE RECEIVING
COUNTY.
AND I AND I I I THINK THAT --
THAT WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THAT
AGAIN WE'VE GOT TO TAKE A LOOK
AT AT WHAT IT MEANS IN TERMS OF
THAT KIND OF CARE FOR KIDS AND
AND ENSURING THAT THAT THAT DOES
OCCUR.
AND THAT THOSE EFFORTS ARE
COORDINATED.
I THINK THE THE BOTTOM LINE IS
IN THIS IS WHAT THIS IS ALL
ABOUT FROM DAY ONE IS TO ENSURE.
THAT YOU GET THE SERVICES THEY
NEED WHEN THEY NEED IT NAY
NOTHING NEEDED FOR AS LONG AS
THEY NEED IT I MEAN THAT'S WHAT
THIS IS ALL ABOUT --
AND THAT AT THE END OF THE DAY
THERE'S A POSITIVE OUTCOME FOR
THAT -- FOR
THE PERSPECTIVE OF OUR MEMBER
AGENCIES A PIECE OF THAT IS THAT
THE ADMINISTRATIVE PART OF THAT
CAN'T BE SO ONEROUS THAT THEY
SAY WELL.
NOW WITH I'M NOT GONNA DO IT YOU
KNOW I'M NOT GONNA BECOME AN S.
HERE TOO BECAUSE I CAN'T DO THIS
MENTAL HEALTH STUFF --
IN NOT TOO SMALL IS THIS THAT
SMALL COUNTIES THAT SMALL
PROVIDERS HAVE EVER SIMILAR
ISSUE -- AND
SO I I I THINK WE HAVE TO LOOK
AT THAT PIECE AS WELL SO THAT
ANY FIX THAT WE COME UP FOR THIS
INSURES THAT THE YOU'VE GOT WITH
A NEED.
BUT ALSO ENSURES THAT THE FOLKS
ARE PROVIDING THOSE SERVICES ARE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THEM AND ABLE TO
DO IT IN A WAY THAT DOESN'T
BECOME ADMINISTRATIVELY SO
BURDENSOME.
THAT PEOPLE.
JUST DON'T DO IT OR AS THANK YOU.
FOR LAST BUT CERTAINLY NOT LEAST.
CAT THANK YOU CONSIDER MEN FROM
C. B. H. TA.
AM I REALLY WANT TO ACTUALLY --
TELL YOU MISS HIM HERNANDEZ THAT
YOU'RE RIGHT ABOUT THE DOLLAR
AMOUNT --
THE MENTAL HEALTH PLANS ARE
EXPERIENCING ABOUT AN AVERAGE OF
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH
PER CHILD PLACED IN RESIDENTIAL
CARE.
IN AN S. HERE T. P. THAT'S
PROVIDING MEDICAL SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
AND TO THAT END AGAIN THE WHOLE --
QUESTION OF WAIVER OR NOT THERE
IS THE THE ASSOCIATION FORMALLY
FEELS VERY STRONGLY THAT --
WAIVER THAT THAT. FOR THOSE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH IN --
EST HERE TEEPEES THAT
RESPONSIBILITY RICH BECAUSE IT'S
THE FIRST TWO LETTERS ARE SHORT
TERM.
ALONG WITH THE PLACING COUNTY
FOR THAT MENTAL HEALTH PLAN TO
CONTINUE A CONTINUITY OF CARE
BECAUSE THAT WE WANT THOSE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH TO COME BACK
HOME.
SO THAT IS VERY MUCH IF YOU TAKE
THE DAHLE MENTAL HEALTH DOLLAR
AMOUNT AND THE PLACE AND THE
RESIDENTIAL RATE AMOUNT TOGETHER
YOUR YOUR YOUR SPOT ON AND SO I
WANTED TO SAY THAT.
THE OTHER THING WELL TO NOT TALK
ABOUT FINANCE FOR A MINUTE.
IS THAT JUST AS ACTUALLY AS AN
ADOPTEE.
AND SO SO IF YOU THINK ABOUT --
SIXTY YEARS AGO --
OR MORE --
ADOPTED IN BEING ADOPTED IN A
DAY AND AGE THAT THAT WAS NOT
THE NORM THAT WAS NOT COMMON.
AND AND BI RACIAL ADOPTIONS WAS
DEFINITELY NOT COMMENT MY MAIDEN
NAME IS HE WORKED.
WHICH IS A VERY GERMAN NAME --
SO -- YOU
KNOW MY SISTER AND I WERE TO OF
FOR NON WHITES IN THE TOWN WE
GREW UP IN.
SO WE WE WHAT I KNOW IS THAT
TRAUMA INFORMED CARE.
TRAINING IS GOING TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE BOTH --
FOR THE PLACING AGENCIES FOR THE
MENTAL HEALTH CLINICIANS FOR THE
FOR THE FAMILIES THE PARENTS AND
FAMILIES WHO WORK SERVING THE
CHILDREN BUT WHO ARE ALSO THE
HOPEFULLY.
THE THE KICK THE PARENTS WERE
GETTING THEIR CHILDREN BACK ARE
LEARNING AND UNDERSTANDING SOME
OF WHAT'S GOING ON SO I THINK
THAT.
TRADE IS REALLY CRITICAL AND SO
WE MORE MORE MORE ACROSS THE
BOARD WITH YOUR PROVIDER OR A
KIT -- CARE
GIVER OF ANY KIND SO I THINK
THAT'S CRITICAL AND THEN
DEFINITELY --
AS WE LOOK AT JUST THE
UNFORTUNATELY JUST STICKS OF
SERVICE THERE ARE DOCUMENTS AND
THE SOONER THOSE DOCUMENTS ARE
LINED UP AS A DETERMINATION IS
MADE ON WHERE THE CHILD IN YOU
THIS CHILD OR YOUTH IS GOING TO
GO.
THE SOONER THOSE THINGS ARE
LINED UP SO WHEN THAT CHILD GOES
WERE EVER THEY'RE GOING WHETHER
LOCALLY OR OUT OF COUNTY.
EVERYTHING IS GOOD TO GO SO THAT
IMMEDIATELY JUST AS WE SAID THE
MINUTE THAT CHILD.
GOES SOMEWHERE SERVICES FOLLOW
FOR CAN START AND I JUST THINK
THAT'S CRITICAL BECAUSE WE
ALREADY KNOW THE MORE SUPPORT WE
CAN PROVIDE THOSE CHILDREN WITH
CONTINUITY OF CARE THE BETTER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IT JUST AND
TAKING A FEW NOTES I THINK I
HAVE OVER --
TWENTY FIVE SUGGESTIONS.
AND I I I WANT TO THANK YOU
BECAUSE YOU YOU COME FROM
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCES.
SOME FROM THE VERY EXPERIENCE.
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO WORK ON AS
FOSTER YOUTH --
THE YARD IN A DISTINCT --
SITUATION WHERE YOUR LIFE
EXPERIENCES ARE GOING TO HELP US
AS WE SHAPE WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN NEXT. FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO ARE WORKING IN ADMIN
SERVICES YOU HAVE THE THE YEARS
OF EXPERIENCE OF HAVING WORKED
IN THIS.
SO YOU KNOW WHAT HAS WORKED WHAT
HASN'T WORKED I WOULD IMAGINE
SOMETIMES YOUR HANDS ARE TIED
YOU MAY BE THINKING WE REALLY
SHOULD BE DOING THIS BUT THE LAW
SAYS I'VE GOT TO DO THIS.
WE WANT TO WORK WITH YOU WE WANT
TO SEE WHAT IT IS BECAUSE I
THINK THAT THAT A COMMENT MADE
BY -- MY
COLLEAGUE MARK STONE USES WE
HAVE TO MAKE THE SYSTEM
RESPONSIVE TO THE KIDS.
IT THAT'S THAT HAS TO BE AT THE
VERY TOP OF THE LIST IT ISN'T
ABOUT HOW MANY REPORTS WE RIGHT
OR WHO'S GOING TO PAY AND HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO PAY.
ALTHOUGH THAT IS IMPORTANT.
BUT IT IS WHAT IS BEST FOR THE
KIDS
AND I AM VERY PROUD TO HAVE ALL
OF YOU WORKING ON FINDING THOSE
SOLUTIONS AND I THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
FOR GIVING US SOME OF THOSE
EXAMPLE SOME OF THOSE
SUGGESTIONS I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NOW I'D LIKE TO OPEN IT UP.
TO THE PUBLIC [inaudible]
IF.
ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WISH TO MAKE COMMENTS.
WE ASK THAT YOU LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS YOUR TESTIMONY TO ONE
MINUTE EACH.
AND I'M CHAIR MEMBERS I'M FAIRLY
STATE TING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
REPRESENTING ALL A FIFTY EIGHT
THAT CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES.
THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING TODAY THE PANELISTS WERE
WONDERFUL IN IT AS YOU CAN SEE
IT'S A VERY COMPLICATED ISSUE.
WE WORK HARD WITH THE BILL'S
SPONSORS AS THE TWELVE NINETY
NINE WAS DRAFTED AND NOW WE HAVE
A ABOUT A YEAR AND A HALF OF
EXPERIENCE AND SO SOME OF THESE
LESSONS LEARNED WERE OPEN TO
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THAT.
I THINK YOU HEARD SOME REALLY
GOOD COMMENTS FROM EVERYBODY --
ON THE PANEL ABOUT WHAT WE CAN
DO TO HELP IMPROVE IT BUT THE
LAST COMMENT I THINK IT IT
BELIEVE IT WAS MS SUDIRMAN OR
PERHAPS YOU MISSED CHAIR.
THAT THE CHILD NEEDS THE
SERVICES AND REALLY WHAT BROUGHT
SEE SACK IN THE COUNTIES TO THE
TABLE ON AS WELL AS THE
LEADERSHIP OF CW DAY WAS
ENSURING THAT KIDS GET THE
SERVICES THEY NEED.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND I THINK THAT THAT
COMMENT CAME FROM JUST ABOUT
EVERYBODY ON EVERY PANEL.
AND I WAS QUOTING MR STONE SO I
CAN'T TAKE THAT CREDIT WE ALL
ARE FEELING THE SAME THING --
THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS I REPRESENT THE
COUNTY OF AND CIARA THEY'RE VERY
INTERESTED IN THE CONVERSATION
THAT YOU'RE HAVING HERE THIS
AFTERNOON --
THEY ARE ONE OF THE QUOTE
UNQUOTE RECEIVING COUNTIES --
AND THEY'VE REALLY STRUGGLED
WITH HOW TO ADEQUATELY PROVIDE
SERVICES AND ENSURE THE BEST
OUTCOMES POSSIBLE FOR CHILDREN
AND SO TO THE EXTENT THAT
THERE'S MAYBE ADDITIONAL
CONVERSATION --
I WOULD OFFER MYSELF AND MY
CLAIM OFTEN THOSE CONVERSATIONS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
WELL AGAIN I'D LIKE TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO THANK ALL OF THE
PANELISTS I'D LIKE TO THANK.
THOSE OF YOU WHO THE PUBLIC
WHO'VE BEEN HERE WITH US.
ON THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
TOPIC IT'S JUST THE FIRST IT'S
AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING THERE'S
MUCH MORE WORK TO BE DONE AND
I'M SURE WILL BE REACHING OUT.
TO ALL OF YOU --
FOR FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS I THANK
YOU SO MUCH HAVE A WONDERFUL DAY
THIS INFORMATIONAL HEARING IS
ADJOURNED